GO AHEAD AND GET STARTED
ARMENIAN I APOLOGIZE THAT WE'RE
STARTING A LITTLE BIT LATE.
BECAUSE YOU CAN SEE WHERE BE
STARTING AS A SUBCOMMITTEE.
WORK COMMITTEE OF FIFTEEN AND
THERE ARE FOUR OF US HERE SO
WE'RE MISSING A FEW MEMBERS IT'S
A BUSY DAY IN THE CAPITAL A LOT
OF MEMBERS PRESENTING BILLS IN
THE SENATE --
OTHER FIVE EXCUSE ME.
MR THURMAN THOMAS ADJOURNMENTS
HERE OKAY SO --
WE WILL HEAR TWO WITNESSES PER
SITE WITH A LIMIT OF TIME LIMIT
OF THREE MINUTES EACH ADDITIONAL
WITNESS WILL BE ASKED TO STATE
ONLY THEIR NAME IN OUR
ORGANIZATION AND FOR THE RECORD
AND THE POSITION ON THE MEASURE.
FOR THOSE WHO HAVE A POSITION
SOMEWHERE BETWEEN SUPPORT AND
OPPOSE OR THOSE WHO HAVE NO
POSITION BECAUSE OF THE LENGTH
OF OUR AGENDA PLEASE GIVE YOUR
NAME ORGANIZATION.
AND VERY VERY BRIEFLY EXPLAIN
YOUR POSITION.
ARE REMOVED FROM THE CALENDAR
TODAY -- IS
A SENATE BILL FIVE THIRTY EIGHT
ITEM NUMBER TWO SO WE WON'T BE
HEARING THAT BILL TODAY.
AYE WE HAVE THE FOLLOWING BILLS
PROPOSED FOR CONSENT.
ITEM NUMBER ONE S. B. ONE NINETY
TWO MISTER BAO ITEM NUMBER EIGHT
SB NINE NINETY SEVEN MISTER
MONEY.
ITEM NUMBER THIRTEEN AT SENATE
BILL TEN NINETY SEVEN MISTER
HUESO ITEM NUMBER FOURTEEN
SENATE BILL --
ELEVEN THIRTY EIGHT MISS SKINNER --
I'D NUMBER TWENTY ONE SENATE
BILL TWELVE NINETY TWO MISTER
HUESO AND THEN ALSO IT'S ITEM
NUMBER TWENTY FOUR SJ ARE TWENTY
FIVE BY MISTER WILK.
SO WITH THAT WE WILL BEGIN OUR
BY HEARING OF THE VERY FIRST
BILL I SEE SENATOR WIENER HERE.
AND WE'LL START WITH STE --
ITEM NUMBER NINE SENATE BILL.
ONE ZERO ZERO FOUR OKAY WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY SIR.
I THANK YOU VERY MUCH I MISTER
CHAIRMAN THANK YOU DOING THIS
AFTER WORKING WITH US --
AND ALSO FOR ACCOMMODATING US
FORMER SENATOR --
PRESIDENT PRO TEM --
NOW MAYOR STEINBERG --
SO COLLEAGUES SENATE BILL.
ONE THOUSAND FOUR AYE SEEKS TO
STANDARDIZE --
AND STRENGTHEN OUR PREVENTION
EARLY INTERVENTION TREATMENT
ACROSS CALIFORNIA BY
ESTABLISHING STRATEGIC
PRIORITIES.
OFFER COUNTY MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES ACT FUNDAMENTAL BILL.
WE WERE NOT.
I'D LIKE TO MOVE THE BILL BUT I
CAME IN A LITTLE BIT LATE YEAH
NICE IRATE LETTER MORE.
VERY SORRY FOR THE INTERRUPTION
SENATOR WIENER OKAY IT'S A VERY --
IT'S A RAUCOUS ARRAKIS COMMITTEE
I GUESS WELCOME TO THE ASSEMBLY
CRIMINAL HA HA HA HA HA HA --
THESE PRIORITIES INCLUDE EARLY
PSYCHOSIS AND MOOD DISORDER THAT
DETECTION AND INTERVENTION AND
ACROSS THE LIFESPAN.
NOW REACH ENGAGEMENT THE TARGET
TRANSITION AGE YOUTH WITH A
PRIORITY ON COLLEGE PARTNERSHIPS.
MY CHILDHOOD TRAUMA PREVENTION
AND EARLY INTERVENTION AND I AND
CULTURALLY COMPETENT AND
LINGUISTICALLY APPROPRIATE
PREVENTION AND EARLY
INTERVENTION.
I S. B. ONE THOUSAND FOUR ALSO
REQUIRES --
THE OVERSIGHT AND ACCOUNTABILITY
COMMISSION OUGHT TO CREATE
STATEWIDE REPORTING MATRIZ
METRICS FOR TRACK TO BE OUTCOMES.
OF THESE PROGRAMS --
ALSO TO PROVIDE COUNTIES WITH
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE IB MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES ACT AS YOU KNOW
ALSO KNOWN AS THE MILLIONAIRES
TAX PROPOSITION SIXTY THREE WAS
PASSED BY THE VOTERS IN TWO
THOUSAND AND FOUR TO ADDRESS
UNMET MENTAL HEALTH NEEDS IN --
THE ACT MANDATES AT LEAST 20% OF
THE PROGRAM OF THE FUNDS HAS TO
GO TO PREVENTION AND EARLY
INTERVENTION --
WE KNOW THAT --
WHEN IT COMES TO MENTAL ILLNESS --
YOUTH ARE VERY VERY IMPACT THAT
WE HAVEN'T DONE ENOUGH. 50% OF
MENTAL HEALTH --
ISSUES --
MANIFEST BY THE AGE OF FOURTEEN
AND 75% OF BY THE AGE OF TWENTY
FIVE WE HAVE A HUGE PROBLEM --
AND CALIFORNIA IN OUR SOCIETY --
WITH YOUNG PEOPLE KIDS WERE IN
HIGH SCHOOL AND COLLEGE WHO ARE
MANIFESTING MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES
NOT BEING TREATED.
AND WE DON'T TREAT --
IT BECOMES HARDER AND HARDER
OVER TIME WE SEE AN INCREASE
RISK OF OF ADDICTION OF
HOMELESSNESS AND SO FORTH SO ARE
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE --
ADDRESSING THESE KIDS NEEDS
[inaudible]
A QUICKLY --
THERE ARE GLARING HOLES IN OUR
SYSTEM AND WE WANT TO FILL THEM
WE KNOW THAT SOME OF OUR
COUNTIES ARE DOING A GREAT JOB
WITH AND THE FUNDS SUMMER NOT
SPENDING THE MONEY OR A DOING SO
IN A NOT VERY EFFECTIVE WAY.
WHAT SB ONE THOUSAND FOUR WILL
PROVIDE SOME STRUCTURE?
WELL I WANT TO NOTE THAT THERE I
KNOW THERE HAVE BEEN SOME
CONCERNS RAISED --
OPERA PEOPLE WHO --
ADVOCATE FURTHER NEEDS OF OUR
SENIORS --
I'VE DONE A LOT OF WORK OVERTIME
BOTH THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT AND IN
THE LEGISLATURE TO SUPPORT THE
NEEDS OF OUR SENIORS --
AND THAT IS SOMETHING I AM VERY
VERY --
PASSIONATE ABOUT --
THIS BILL DOES NOT TAKE MONEY
AWAY FROM SENIORS THE BILL STILL
PROVIDES FLEXIBILITY I'D TO
COUNTIES --
TO TO UTILIZE THE FUNDS NOT JUST
FOR YOUNG PEOPLE BUT FOR OTHERS
AS WELL WE MADE SOME AMENDMENTS --
IN THAT REGARD I'D THE BILL ALSO --
DOES NOT IN ANY WAY --
DENY COUNTIES THE ABILITY TO A
CULTURALLY COMPETENT --
AND LINGUISTICALLY APPROPRIATE --
I SERVICES I'D ALWAYS BEEN THAT
WAY IN THE BILL THAT WOULD PUT
SOME LANGUAGE AND WITH
AMENDMENTS --
TO MAKE THAT CRYSTAL CLEAR THIS
IS NOT ABOUT TAKING SERVICES A
RESOURCES AWAY FROM ANYONE.
BUT IT IS ABOUT MAKING CLEAR
THAT WHEN IT COMES TO EARLY
INTERVENTION AND PREVENTION WE
WE ABSOLUTELY NEED --
TO FOCUS NOT EXCLUSIVELY BUT
FOCUS ON THE NEEDS OF OUR YOUNG
PEOPLE AND THAT'S WHAT THE BILL
DOES -- SO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
WITH ME TODAY --
IS ON THERE --
STEINBERG --
PROFIT OF?
OTHER MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES ARE --
PROP SIXTY FOUR I THINK THAT'S
THAT'S SIXTIES REAL NOBODY'S
RADIOS ARE --
AS WELL AS ALL BEYOND RECORDS
HARVEY FROM THE CALIFORNIA
COUNCIL OF COMMUNITY HAVE ALL
HEALTH AGENCIES.
AND LAUREL --
RAMEAU'S WHO HAS A SON WHO IS
SERVING AN INDEFINITE --
SENTENCE IN A PRISON AUTUMN AIR
STEINBERG.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR
WIENER THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
VICE CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE ME
IT'S GREAT TO BE --
WITH YOU AGAIN I DON'T COME HERE
TOO OFTEN BUT WHEN THERE'S A
COMPELLING BECAUSE I'M ALWAYS
HAPPY TO BE BACK UP.
LET ME -- I
I AM THE FOUNDER OF THE
INSTITUTE MENTAL HEALTH
INSTITUTE IN MY NAME.
OUR PUBLIC POLICY ADVOCACY GROUP
TRYING TO MAKE MENTAL HEALTH.
A HIGHER TIER PRIORITY AND
SPECIFICALLY.
WITH PROP SIXTY THREE THE MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICE ACT IT IS HELPING
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE BUT THERE IS
A PROBLEM AND THE PROBLEM IS
THIS.
THERE'S A LOT OF MONEY GOING OUT
TO COUNTIES THAT GENERALLY DO A
VERY GOOD JOB WITH THE MONEY.
BUT THE STATE IS NOT PROVIDED A
STRATEGIC FOCUS FOR WHAT
PROBLEMS WE ACTUALLY ONE ASSAULT
WITH THAT MONEY.
PREVENTION EARLY INTERVENTION IT
WILL AMOUNT TO ABOUT FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR.
AND THE REASON I CENTER WIENERS
BILL IS SO IMPORTANT IS THAT
WITHOUT MANDATING OR MICRO
MANAGING WHAT COUNTY SHOULD DO
IT SAYS.
CAN YOU PLEASE SPEND THE MONEY
ON ONE OF FOUR KEY CATEGORIES.
DRAMA BASED CARE FOR PEOPLE
AMONG THE AGE ABOUT AGE SPAN.
BOB COLLEGE BASED MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES EARLY PSYCHOSIS
IDENTIFICATION INTERVENTION AND
CULTURALLY COMPETENT SERVICES.
AND SO WE JUST SEEK. TO TO
PROVIDE A LITTLE BALANCE HERE IN
DIRECTIONS SO THAT THIS FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS CAN BE
SPENT IN A WAY THAT THE STATE
CAN LOOK AND SAY.
WE'VE ACCOMPLISHED SOMETHING
REAL THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON THANK YOU MY NAME
IS LAURA OVER ALMOST AND I'M
HERE TODAY IS AN AFFECTED FAMILY
MEMBER.
HOME I LIKE TO SHARE TWO PHOTOS
THAT I HAVE GOOD BY ME.
THE FIRST PHOTO IS WITH MY SON
AS A YOUNG ADULT ON GETTING
READY TO START OFF TO COLLEGE
WHEN HE FIRST STARTED TO
MANIFEST SIGNS OF BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES.
THE SECOND --
IT'S A FEW WEEKS OLD THAT I
DURING THE CALIFORNIA STATE
PRISON VISIT.
SO AS I STATED EARLIER MY NAME
IS LAURA MOST AND I'M AN
AFFECTED FAMILY MEMBER.
MY SON JONATHAN RAMEAU'S WAS
RACING SACRAMENTO GRADUATED FROM
JESUIT HIGH SCHOOL AND WAS
ACCEPTED INTO FORDHAM UNIVERSITY.
JONATHAN WAS GAINFULLY EMPLOYED
INVOLVED IN ACADEMICS
EXTRACURRICULAR ACTIVITIES AND
ENGAGE WITH FAMILY AND FRIENDS
HE IS TRULY A REMARKABLE HUMAN.
JONATHAN'S LONG TERM GOAL WAS TO
ATTEND COLUMBIA UNIVERSITY AND
PURSUE HIS ACADEMIC ENDEAVORS IN
THEORETICAL PHYSICS.
A BRILLIANT INCAPABLE MIND
INDEED.
A YOUNG MAN WITH NO HISTORY OF
VIOLENCE NO HISTORY CRIMINALITY
NO ISSUES WITH ALCOHOL OR DRUG
DRUG SUBSTANCE ABUSE.
BUT HE STRUGGLED WITH MENTAL
HEALTH.
WHEN JONATHAN WAS?
TWENTY ONE HE ATTEMPTED SUICIDE
HE IMMEDIATELY REACHED OUT TO
COUNTY EP I TRAGICALLY HE MOST
CERTAINLY DID NOT RECEIVE IT.
AS A DIRECT RESULT OF NOT
RECEIVING THE PROPER EP I
JONATHAN AT THE AGE OF TWENTY
TWO WAS SENTENCED TO AN
INDETERMINATE LIFE SENTENCE.
JONATHAN NOW LIVES IN A
CALIFORNIA STATE PRISON.
WHY I'M FORTUNATE ENOUGH TO
VISIT HIM WEEKLY?
I SUPPORT THIS BILL BECAUSE I
KNOW THAT 50% OF ALL MENTAL
ILLNESS BEGINS AT AGE.
FOURTEEN AND 75% BUT THE AGE OF
TWENTY FOUR I KNOW THIS TO BE
TRUE BECAUSE IT IS OUR LIVED
EXPERIENCE.
IT IS NOT FAIR THAT ONLY TWENTY
FOUR COUNTIES HAVE EVIDENCE
BASED EARLY PSYCHOSIS PROGRAMS.
AS AN AFFECTED FAMILY MEMBER
EXPERT TRAUMA EMERGENCY NURSE
WITH TWENTY YEARS EXPERIENCE IN
THE LEVEL ONE TRAUMA CENTER.
IN A COMMUNITY ADVOCATE.
I RESPECTFULLY AND HUMBLY ASK
FOR YOUR SUPPORT OF SENATE BILL
PEDAL.
FOR SO MUCH OF THE WE'VE GOT
TIME FOR ONE MORE IF --
TO MISTER VICE CHAIR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE RENTAL HAGER
REPRESENTING --
NOT ONLY THE CHILD PSYCHIATRIST
WITH YOUR ACT GERIATRIC KLAY --
QUALIFIED PSYCHIATRIST OF THE
COMPANIES LIKE INTERESTS MISSION
I THINK IMAGE JUMPED AHEAD IN
THE QUEUE BUT ARE YOU ARE YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON AN HONORABLE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SUDDENLY ON
CLICK HARVEY --
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
COUNCIL OF COMMUNITY BEHAVIOR
HEALTH AGENCIES I WE REPRESENT
OVER SEVENTY FIVE BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH AGENCIES ACROSS THE STATE
AND MORE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL.
ARE AGENCIES ARE COMMITTED TO
PROVIDING BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
SERVICES ACROSS THE LIFESPAN
INCLUDING ASSISTING INDIVIDUALS
WITH BEHAVIORAL HEALTH DISORDERS
MANAGE THEIR CONDITION WITH
APPROPRIATE AN INTENSIVE EARLY
INTERVENTION STRATEGIES.
OUR BELIEF IS THAT THIS BILL IS
IN CONCERT WITH OUR MISSION
MEMBERS WE ALL UNDERSTAND HOW
CRITICAL P. I SERVICES ARE BUT
HOW SPARSE POORLY FUNDED.
AND POORLY DESIGNED WE CAN BE AS
WELL AS SUCH.
STRUCTURED APPROACH TO DESIGNING
AND HAVING OVERSIGHT OF P. E. I.
PROGRAM.
WE WORKED WITH THE AUTHORS
OFFICE AND SPONSORS TO PROVIDE
AMENDMENTS THAT REFLECT
INCLUSION OF DIVERSE POPULATIONS
THIS BILL HAS COME A LONG WAY.
AND WE FEEL THE AMENDED BILL
PROVIDES A FRAMEWORK FOR
PROVIDING FUNDING AND OVERSIGHT
FOR MUCH NEEDED P. I SERVICES.
THANKS SO MUCH ADDITIONAL WHICH
IS WITNESSES AND SUPPORT PLEASE
STATE YOUR NAME ORGANIZATION
IMPOSITION ON THE GOOD AFTERNOON
VICTOR CHRISTY WITH CALIFORNIA
HEALTH PLUS DELEGATES.
BY ADVOCATING FOR COMMUNITY
HEALTH CENTERS AND THE SIX POINT
FIVE MILLION PATIENTS FROM YOUTH
OF WORKING FAMILIES AND SENIORS
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
HELENA DOWDEN TEACHERS FOR
HEALTHY KIDS IN FULL SUPPORT
BECAUSE 20% OF THE KIDS IN OUR
SCHOOLS HAVE SOME FORM OF MENTAL
THANK YOU SO MUCH IT'S JUST YOU
STATE YOUR NAME ORGANIZATION
POSITION.
KELLY BEING FOR CHILDREN NOW IN
SUPPORT.
EDUARDO I DON'T PRESCRIBE
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
NATIVE BORN AMERICAN KENNY
PEDIATRICS CALIFORNIA DIVISION
IN SUPPORT.
MARRIED ALONG WITH THE CAL STATE
UNISYS ASIAN AND SUPPORT.
LEXIE HOWARD ON BEHALF OF THE
JUVENILE COURT JUDGES OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
BRENT IN MARCH YOU WITH THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
WERE ALSO IN SUPPORT.
TIM MADDEN REPRESENT CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER OF THE AMERICAN COLLEGE
OF EMERGENCY PHYSICIANS IN
SUPPORT.
JANICE GALLON CHILDREN'S DEFENSE
FUND CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
DAVID GONZALEZ WITH AMERICA'S
VISITS POSITION GROUPS IN
SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON DANIEL CANDOR
KAISER ON BEHALF OF COMMON SENSE
KIDS ACTION WE'VE ORDERED THIS
BILL ARE STAR RATING IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
OF WEST SAM'S UNITED WAYS OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
STACY HERE MOTOR WITH REMCO THE
RACIAL AND ETHNIC MENTAL HEALTH
DISPARITIES COALITION WE ARE A
SUPPORT IF AMENDED WE REALLY
APPRECIATE THE AMENDMENTS THAT
WERE TAKEN BUT WE REALLY HOPE
THAT THANK YOU SO MUCH I
APPRECIATE IT.
RITUAL FOR CONSUMER AFFAIRS
LIAISON SOLANO COUNTY BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH WE SUPPORT OF SUCH
AMENDED TOOK INCLUDE PEOPLE
ACROSS THE LIFESPAN.
DEBORAH UP DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA SUPPORT.
ALRIGHT THE MY GONNA MOVE ON TO
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION ARE
THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION
.
COME ON UP
THANK YOU SIR YOUR FIRST.
THIS IS A REMINDER TO MINUTES.
BUT GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
OUT JIM GOMER.
THE CHAIRMAN WOULD IT MEMBERS OF
THE SENATE HEALTH COMMITTEE.
I CAME FROM OXNARD INVENTOR
COUNTY. TO PROVIDE TESTIMONY ON
THIS BILL.
I'VE RECENTLY BEEN THE PRESIDENT
OF A WELL KNOWN STATEWIDE MENTAL
HEALTH ORGANIZATION.
I'M CURRENTLY ON THE BOARD OF
DIRECTORS OF SEVERAL
ORGANIZATIONS THERE SERVE
RESIDENTS FROM ALL OVER THE
STATE.
TODAY I COME TO YOU OFFER AS A
MAN WHO HAS SPENT.
MANY MANY HOURS MENTORING.
AND VOLUNTEERING FOR MANY HIGH
RISK YOUTH PARTICULARLY YOUTH OF
COLOR.
I REPRESENT MANY OF THESE
INDIVIDUALS.
WHO CANNOT TRAVEL HERE
SACRAMENTO TODAY TO TALK TO YOU?
WE ARE VERY GRATEFUL.
THAT THE BILL HAS BEEN AMENDED.
SUBSTANTIALLY SINCE IT WAS FIRST
INTRODUCED IN THE SENATE.
BUT THERE ARE STILL SOME SECTION
OF THE BILL THAT ARE VERY
CONCERNING.
KNOWING TO COMMITTEES OF COLOR
BUT TO HARD TO REACH GROUPS AS
WELL.
THIS SECTION OF THE BILL AVERAGE
ENGAGEMENT THAT.
TARGETS TRANSITION AID YOUTH
STILL POWERS TYPE PRIORITIZES
[inaudible]
UP.
STUDENTS ENROLLED IN COLLEGE.
WE'RE NOT ARGUING THAT STUDENTS
IN COLLEGE WHO USE MORE MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES.
WE'RE STILL UNABLE TO UNDERSTAND
WHY THERE WOULD BE A PRIORITY ON
THEM OVER YOUTH WERE NOT ABLE TO
GO TO COLLEGE ESPECIALLY HIGH
RISK YOU.
WHO ARE DISTRICT PROPORTIONING
ANA COLLEGE YOUTH OF COLOR?
FOSTER CARE YOU FROM LGBT Q.
YOUTH AND BALLOT IN VIOLENCE.
YOUTH INTIMIDATED WITH GANGS.
YOUTH WHO ARE IN TRANSITION.
FURTHERMORE YOUTH WHO HAVE
MENTAL HEALTH CHALLENGES ARE
OFTEN NOT ABLE TO ENTER OR RE
ENTER COLLEGE BECAUSE OF THEIR
MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES.
AND FRANKLY MANY OF THESE YOUTH.
OR EVEN ANGLO.
WE WANT TRANSITION AGE YOUTH.
WHO HAVE POTENTIAL MOUTH MENTAL
HEALTH CONDITIONS TO BE SERVICE
AND HAVE ACCESS TO PROGRAMS?
WHY WE FAVOR THOSE IN COLLEGE
WHEN MANY OF THOSE YOUTH ARE
PRIVILEGED AND THEIR MENTAL
HEALTH PROGRAMS ON EVERY CAMPUS
AREN'T THOSE YOUTH?
AS EVER DESERVING OF THOSE WHO
WERE FORTUNATE ENOUGH TO BE
GOING TO COLLEGE.
I WISH I COULD SAY THAT THERE
WERE MANY MENTAL HEALTH
PREVENTION PROGRAMS.
AND COMMUNITIES OF COLOR AND
NEIGHBORHOODS WERE GRAYSON AT
THE COMMUNITY EXISTS.
BUT WE KNOW THIS IS NOT THE CASE.
YOU THERE YOU IT WOULD BE EASY
TO REMOVE THE PREFERENCE FOR
COLLEGE PROGRAMS.
NOT TOO LONG AGO AS I CLOSE
NAFTA AMERICAN TRANSITION AID
YOU IN THIS CITY OF SACRAMENTO
STEPHEN CLARK.
TRAGICALLY KILLED BY POLICE AND
GRANDMOTHER'S BACKYARD.
HIS GRIEVING BROTHERS TO VONTADE
ALSO A TRANSITION AGE YOUTH
EXHIBITED SIGNS OF MENTAL HEALTH
ISSUES.
AND EVEN HAD TO BE HOSPITALIZED
SHORTLY AFTER THIS INCIDENT. TO
MY UNDERSTANDING NEITHER OF
THESE YOUNG MEN WERE COLLEGE
KIDS [inaudible]
SO THEREFORE.
I'M HERE TODAY.
AND THESE YOUNG MAN.
AND MANY COMMUNITIES AND
NEIGHBORHOODS LIKE THEM FROM.
THE BORDER TOWNS OF CHULA VISTA.
SKID ROW TO COMPTON. TO HEAR IN
SACRAMENTO TO THE RULE
AGRICULTURE COMMUNITIES LIKE IN
OXNARD.
THEY WILL BE [inaudible]
MS STOVER [inaudible]
PLEASE.
EXPAND THIS PROGRAM TO ALL YOU
THINK.
JANET FRANK --
I'M A FACULTY MEMBER AT UCLA
CENTER FOR HEALTH POLICY
RESEARCH AND I AM THE DIRECTOR
OF THE ONE AND ONLY STUDY THAT'S
BEEN DONE ABOUT MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICE ACT AND OLDER ADULTS.
SOMEBODY TO SHARE SOME
INFORMATION ABOUT MY STUDY.
AND ASK FOR ADDITIONAL
AMENDMENTS TO THE BILL.
IN RECOGNITION OF THE IMPORTANCE
OF PREVENTION AND EARLIER VAN
AND EARLY INTERVENTION PROGRAMS
FOR OLDER ADULTS --
I HAVE SEVERAL CONCERNS ABOUT
THE BILL. ONE IS THE ENTIRE --
ISSUE OF THE COMMISSION --
SETTING THE PRIORITIES RATHER
THAN.
THE ARE A HALLMARK REALLY OF THE
MHSAA WHICH WAS --
WHICH IS A ROBUST LOCAL
STAKEHOLDER.
SO I HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT THAT
NOT.
I HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT THE FACT
THAT THERE WAS A I BELIEVE IN
AMENDED PORTION PUT INTO THE
BILL THAT IF COUNTIES. ONE AND
TWO IDENTIFY PROGRAMS THAT WERE
OUTSIDE THE PRIORITIES OF THE
YOUTH AND TRANSITIONAL AGE YOUTH --
THAT THEY WOULD NEED TO DO
ADDITIONAL WORK AND SO THIS OF
COURSE IS A DISINCENTIVE. FOR
COUNTIES TO ARM. TO PROMOTE
PROGRAMS THAT HAVE --
OTHER PRIORITIES SUCH AS THOSE
FOR ADULTS AND OLDER ADULTS.
THAT THIS CREATES A DOUBLE
STANDARD.
AND I BELIEVE THAT ALL THE
DIFFERENT PROGRAMS SHOULD BE
HELD TO THE SAME STANDARD IF IF
THEY GO FORWARD.
MY PRIMARY CONCERN IS REALLY HOW
THE DID DEFINITION IN THE BILL.
IS AROUND OUTREACH AND
ENGAGEMENT WHICH IS QUITE
LIMITED AND FOCUSED AS I QUOTE
HERE.
ON A SECONDARY SCHOOL IN
TRANSITION AGE YOUTH WHAT THE
PRIORITY ON PARTNERING WITH
COLLEGES --
I AGREE THAT MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES FOR COLLEGE STUDENTS
ARE IMPORTANT.
BUT CURRENTLY --
THERE IS QUITE A DISPARITY IN
THE TYPES OF SERVICES THAT ARE
BEING GIVEN TO PEOPLE ACROSS THE
LIFESPAN.
AND A MENTAL HEALTH --
COMMISSION STUDY.
I ACTUALLY SHOWED THAT CURRENTLY
AROUND 80%.
OF FUNDING OF FUNDING FOR
PREVENTION PROGRAMS IS GOING TO
CHILDREN AND YOUTH.
ABOUT 19% TO ADULTS AND ONE
POINT 5% TO OLDER ADULTS.
THIS BILL WILL LASSEN AN
INCREASE THAT DISPARITY EVEN
FURTHER.
SO I BELIEVE THAT OLDER ADULTS
SHOULD ACTUALLY BE OUR PRIORITY
POPULATION. FOR THIS BILL
BECAUSE THEY HAVE A NUMBER OF
MENTAL HEALTH NEEDS AND I JUST
WANTED TO QUICKLY REVIEW SOME OF
THOSE.
THEY HAVE SIGNIFICANT RISK OF
MENTAL HEALTH CONDITIONS DO TO
FAILING HEALTH ISOLATION
ECONOMIC AND SECURITY.
AND VULNERABILITY TO
EXPLOITATION.
OLDER ADULTS ARE THE LARGEST OUR
FASTEST GROWING AGE COHORT IN
THE NATION AND ALSO IN
CALIFORNIA.
A IT WILL SOON BE 20%.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SO MUCH
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
BOB ANY FURTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION JUST STATE YOUR NAME
ORGANIZATION A POSITION ONLY.
CAROL SO FROM THE CALIFORNIA
COMMISSION WE REQUEST THAT YOU
CONSIDER ADDITIONAL AMENDMENTS
AS SOMETHING THANK YOU SO MUCH
LAST WEEK APPRECIATE IT ANYMORE
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION JUST
YOUR NAME AND ORGANIZATION IN
YOUR POSITION.
HE HAD THERE ARE CAL TO WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF AREA
AGENCIES ON AGING [inaudible]
WE OPPOSE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
JANET HEATH MULTIPURPOSE SENIOR
SERVICES PROGRAM SIDE
ASSOCIATION WE OPPOSE.
PLEASE A COLEMAN CALIFORNIA LONG
TERM CARE OMBUDSMAN ASSOCIATION
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED.
JEFF TARGET KIA HAPTIC IT
[inaudible]
UNINTENTIONAL CONSEQUENCES
CARA OWL --
LET'S SEE THANK YOU JOHN REPRISE
JUST.
YOU ASKED ORGANIZATIONS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
BRING IT BACK HIS ANYMORE LOVE
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
GOD WANTS BRING IT BACK ANY
QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS OR YES
MISTER CHAIRMAN.
I THINK MISTER CHAIR I THINK THE
AUTHOR FOR THE BILL.
ARM AND IN ALL THOSE WHO --
PROVIDED TESTIMONY LIKE TO THANK
OUR WITNESSES FOR YOUR TESTIMONY
IN SHARING YOUR YOUR SON'S
EXPERIENCE.
IN PROVIDING THE CONTEXT Y. MORE
IS NEEDED --
THANK YOU SENATOR STEINBERG AND
ALL FOR YOUR TESTIMONY IN YOUR
WORK IN THIS AREA --
YOU KNOW I'VE BEEN --
I'VE BEEN A MEMBER OF THIS
COMMISSION --
AND I'VE SPENT A GOOD PART OF MY
CAREER DOING WORK --
FOR MIDDLE HEALTH AGENCIES --
WITH YOUTH AND SOMETIMES IT
SENIORS.
AND AND I KNOW THE WORK OF THE
AUTHOR AND I DO IT TO THE AUTHOR --
IS VERY THOUGHTFUL AND INCLUSIVE
AND HOW HE APPROACHES --
ANYTHING THAT HE WORKS ON AND SO.
I I'D LIKE TO GIVE THE AUTHOR AN
OPPORTUNITY TO TALK ABOUT.
THE CONCERNS THAT WERE RAISED
APPRECIATE THE OPPOSITION
WITNESSES FOR FOR SAYING THAT --
ABSOLUTELY WE SHOULD SUPPORT
YOUNG PEOPLE WHO EXPERIENCE
STRESS WHILE IN COLLEGE BUT WE
ABSOLUTELY MUST SUPPORT YOUNG
PEOPLE WHEREVER THEY ARE.
AS WE SAY IN SOCIAL WORK WE
SUPPORT YOUNG PEOPLE WHEREVER
THEY ARE AND IT YOU SHOULD HAVE
GOOD COLLEGE GET THOSE SERVICES
I DON'T.
I DON'T UNDERSTAND THIS BILL TO
MAKE THAT DIFFERENTIATION IN AND
I'D LIKE TO ASK THE SENATOR
SPEAK. TO THAT END TO IN TO
SPEAK TO ON HOW HOW SENIORS
WOULD BE SERVED YOU KNOW I YOU
KNOW I YOU KNOW I WORK IN A I
WORKED IN AN AGENCY THAT USED.
MEDI CAL JUST PROVIDE SCHOOL
BASED MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES AND
WE'D NEVER HAD ENOUGH. TO SERVE
ALL THOSE WHO NEEDED IT AND SO
WHAT I LIKE ABOUT THIS BILL IS
THAT IT RECOGNIZES THAT THERE
ARE DOLLARS THAT HAVE BEEN
ALLOCATED FOR EVER REASON.
WE GOT A FAIR WITH THOSE
BARRIERS ARE GET THOSE DOLLARS
INTO THE COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS INTO COUNTY
PROGRAMS INTO SCHOOL BASED
PROGRAMS INTO SENIOR PROGRAMS.
BUT GET THE SERVICES FUNDED SO
THAT THE WORK CAN CAN BE
ENHANCED AND WE'VE SEEN AN
INCREASE IN SUICIDE.
UP IN STRESS --
IN TRAMO IN SO I APPRECIATE
WOODS IS GOING TO LIKE TO ASK
THE AUTHOR.
SPEAK DIRECTLY TO OF THE
CONCERNS THAT WERE RAISED ABOUT
SENIORS NOT BE ABLE TO ACCESS
THE SERVICES AND UNDERPRIVILEGED
YOUTH.
THANK YOU I REALLY APPRECIATE
THAT THAT QUESTION THAT SOMEONE --
AND I THINK UP FOR SO SOME OF
THE TENSION NEVER SEEN HERE HAS
TO DO WITH THE FACT SERVICES
SYSTEM IN GENERAL.
IN THIS COUNTRY IS UNDER FUNDED
AND SO UNFORTUNATELY WE IT WITH
LIMITED RESOURCES SOMETIMES AS A
PUSH IN A POLL.
BUT THIS IS A SIGNIFICANT.
PART OF MONEY IT'S FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS ODDS ARE GROWING
TO THAT AMOUNT WILL PROBABLY
GROW MORE --
AND SO THERE IS A SIGNIFICANT
AMOUNT OF FUNDING A TO GO AROUND
EVEN THOUGH WE ALWAYS NEED TO DO
MORE -- THIS
BILL DOES NOT IN ANY WAY.
LIMIT THE ABILITY OF COUNTIES
HAVE FUN SERVICES FOR SENIORS
THE FUND SERVICES FOR YOUNG
PEOPLE WHO ARE NOT IN COLLEGE.
OUGHT TO FIND SERVICES FOR
PEOPLE FOR KIPPER PEOPLE ON THE
LGBT COMMUNITY OR COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR OR ANY COMMUNITY THAT THAT
NEED SUPPORT.
AND I WANNA POINT TO A FEW
THINGS.
WE REPEATEDLY AND THIS BILL TALK
USE THE PRAISE ACROSS THEIR
LIFESPAN.
WE USE THAT IN THE PART TALKING
ABOUT UNDERSERVED CULTURAL
POPULATIONS --
WE USE IT AND ITEM ARE IN THE IN
TERMS OF THE FIVE PRIORITIES --
NUMBER TWO TALKS ABOUT --
EARLY PSYCHOSIS AND NEW DISORDER
DETENTION INTERVENTION INCLUDING
MOOD DISORDER PROGRAMMING THAT
OCCURS ACROSS.
THE LIFESPAN WHEN YOU LOOK AT
THE FIVE CATEGORIES --
TWO OF THEM ARE ABOUT YOUTH
CHILD EARLY HIGH CHILDHOOD
TRAUMA AND THEN --
A RETURN ENGAGEMENT STRATEGIES
FOCUSING ON CAUGHT KIDS IN
COLLEGE THE OTHER THREE ARE.
FOR ANYONE OF ANY AGE COLLEGE
NOT COLLEGE SO THREE OF THE FIVE
ARE NOT SPECIFIC A TO YOUNG
PEOPLE. TO OUR AYE AND THAT
MEANS THAT FOR KIDS WHO ARE NOT
IN COLLEGE FOUR OF THE FIVE
APPLY TO THEM DOESN'T ONLY.
ONE THAT TALKS ABOUT AN EMPHASIS
ON KIDSWHO ARE IN COLLEGE LIKE
THE CSU KIDS WHO HAVE BEEN
COMING OUT.
SUPPORT THIS BILL SO THIS --
THIS BILL DOES NOT BLOCK SENIORS
OUT DOES NOT BOX ANYONE OUT --
THE OTHER THING I WON I'D NOTICE
I THERE WAS A STATEMENT MADE
BEFORE ABOUT HOW THE COMMISSION
SETS.
STANDARDS AND THEN IT TAKES THEM
TAKE A LOT OF WORK. TO TRY TO
CHANGE IT AYE YOU LOOK AT IT IS --
ALL FIVE EIGHT FOUR POINT SEVEN
DE.
WHERE IT SAYS PACIFIC LATE?
I COUNTY MAY INCLUDE OTHER
PRIORITIES AS DETERMINED THROUGH
THE STAKEHOLDER PROCESS EITHER
IN PLACE OF OR IN ADDITION TO
THE ESTABLISH PRIORITIES.
IF THE COUNTY CHOOSES TO INCLUDE
OTHER PROGRAMS THE PLAN SHALL
INCLUDE DESCRIPTION.
OF WHY THOSE PROGRAMS ARE
INCLUDED AND METRICS BY WHICH
EFFECT IN THIS.
OF THOSE PROGRAMS IS TO BE
MEASURED AND THAT'S THE WAY THAT
IN ADDITION TO THE BROAD
FLEXIBILITY IN THE FIVE
CATEGORIES.
THAT A COUNTY CAN SELL YOU KNOW
WHAT WE HAVE SOME DIFFERENT
NEEDS -- WE
WANT TO SPEND THE MONEY A LITTLE
DIFFERENTLY BUT WE ARE REQUIRING
THEM. TO BE RIGOROUS ABOUT IT
AND THE SAY WHY THEY'RE DOING
THAT HOW THEY'RE GONNA DO IT
WHAT ARE THE METRICS.
AS PART OF THE PROBLEM WE HAVE
WITH --
DAMAGE TO SAY.
IS WE HAVE COUNTIES THAT THERE'S
NOT A LOT OF ACCOUNTABILITY OR
STRUCTURE.
SOME COUNTIES DO REALLY WELL
SOME COUNTIES --
LESS SO SOME COUNTIES THAT ARE
IN SPENDING THE MONEY AT ALL --
AND SO WE WANT TO SAYS AT LEAST
REQUIRE.
I AND THEN FINALLY I'M IN TERMS
OF COMMITTEES WERE REACHING.
ALL COMMUNITIES YEAH WE'VE TAKEN
A LOT OF AMENDMENTS TO THIS BILL
IN WORKING WITH SOME OF THE
OPPONENTS WE REALLY APPRECIATE
THEM.
CONSTRUCTIVELY ENGAGE IN WITH US
MAYBE NOT EVERYONE THAT'S
EXACTLY WHAT THEY'RE ASKING FOR
BUT WE MADE AMENDMENTS TO REALLY
ADDRESS THESE CONCERNS.
I AM WE HAVE FOR PRIORITY NUMBER
FOUR CULTURALLY COMPETENT AND
LINGUISTICALLY APPROPRIATE
PROGRAMS --
YEAR WE HAVE --
I THINK A REALLY BROAD
DEFINITIONS BECAUSE BUT SOMEONE
WHO -- YOU
KNOW COMES FROM A COMMUNITY OF
LGBT COMMUNITY WHERE YOU KNOW
THAT IS A VERY MARGINALIZED
COMMUNITY A LOT OF WAYS WHERE HE
ABOUT YOUNG PEOPLE AND SENIORS
EX STRUGGLE ALIVE.
I WOULD THAT WOULD BE THE LAST
THING I'D EVER WANT TO DO IT TO
SAY THAT WE'RE NOT GONNA.
FOCUS ON ALL COMMUNITIES SO I
RESPECT THE OPPOSITION --
BUT I DO BELIEVE WE'VE ADDRESSED --
THOSE CONCERNS.
THANK YOU SOONER I I YOU KNOW
I'M AND I'M PREPARED SPORTS
ABILITY DAY I WILL OWN WHENEVER
WE HAVE QUORUM I'M HAPPY TO MAKE
MOTION I I LIKE TO ASK YOU TO
KEEP WORKING WORKS.
WITH THOSE WHO'VE RAISE CONCERNS
I SUSPECT A LOT OF THIS ABOUT
THE CHANGE AND THERE'S BEEN A
LOT OF TALK ABOUT HOW THE
DOLLARS THAT HADN'T BEEN
ALLOCATED SHOULD GET USE AND I
THINK THAT CREATES SOME TENSIONS
IN AND OF ITSELF.
AND THE MORE THAT WE CAN HEAR
ALL PERSPECTIVES ABOUT HOW WE
MAKE THIS WORK THE BETTER IN
THIS -- ONE
ENCOURAGE YOU TO CONTINUE DOING
THAT -- BUT
HABITS PORTUGAL DAY AND HOPE TO
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
OPPOSITION --
TO TO TO AS YOUR SHAPING EXCEPT
THAT WE HAVE A GREAT COMMISSION
AND I KNOW THAT THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTORS HERE THAT'S GREAT
STAFF ON THIS COMMISSION GREAT
COMMISSIONERS.
OUR THAT HAS A PROCESS FOR INPUT
IS THERE SOME KIND OF A
FRAMEWORK FOR PEOPLE WHO WANT TO
GIVE MORE INPUT.
ABOUT HOW THE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE COMPONENTS OF THIS
BILL WOULD GET SHAPED --
I YES ON THE BILL DOES REQUIRE
STAKEHOLDER INPUT I WOULD DEFER
TO THE COMMISSION TO TALK ABOUT
THEIR PROCESS UP BUT I WILL ALSO
SAY WE ABSOLUTELY ARE COMMITTED
TO CONTINUING DIALOGUE.
OF WITH WITH PEOPLE WHO HAVE.
INSTRUCTIVE CONCERNS ABOUT THE
BILL THANK YOU THINGS BECAUSE
WE'RE GONNA NAM MOVED TO
ESTABLISH A QUORUM BOMBS CALL
THE ROLL [inaudible]
WOULD.
MAYES HERE AGUIAR-CURRY
[inaudible]
BIGELOW [inaudible]
BONTA [inaudible]
BURKE [inaudible]
CARILLO [inaudible]
FLORA [inaudible]
LIMON [inaudible]
MCCARTY [inaudible]
NAZARIAN.
RODRIGUEZ SANTIAGO BERMAN.
WALDRON.
HER EARLIEST AUSA QUORUM AND
THEN I'M TO THURMAN DID YOU
INDICATE THAT YOU WANT TO MAKE A
MOTION AS OUR SECOND.
THE SECOND AND THE MISSILE OR
CREATE A QUESTION.
NO I JUST WANTED TO COMMENT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR BRINGING
IN SUPPORT THE KEY TO ME HERE IN
ALL THIS MENTAL ILLNESS.
DISCUSSIONS ARE HAVING IS
PREVENTION AND EARLY
INTERVENTION.
AND THERE'S SO MANY THINGS THAT
WE COULD COULD OF DONE MAYBE
YEARS AGO BUT YOU KNOW WHAT
RIGHT NOW WE HAVE TO HAVE A
VISION.
AND WE'RE GONNA GO FORTH THESE
OF THESE CHILDREN THAT HAVE
DIFFICULTIES OTHER TESTIMONY BY
THE OF MISTER MISS WRONGNESS --
I TRULY APPRECIATE IT BECAUSE
ALL OF A SUDDEN SOMETHING CLICKS.
AND BE ABLE TO IDENTIFY AND
PREVENT SOMETHING OFFER THAT HER
FAMILY IT WOULD HAVE BEEN
FABULOUS AND THERE'S HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF FAMILIES THAT HAVE
THE SAME ISSUE --
I REALLY APPRECIATE THE FACT
THEIR YOU KNOW THERE'S THERE IS
A DISPARITY ABOUT HOW EACH
COUNTY SPENDS A MONEY.
AND WE NEED TO LOCK THAT DOWN
BECAUSE WHAT'S GOOD IN RURAL AND
URBAN MAY NOT ALWAYS BE THE SAME
BUT EACH COUNTY WAS GONNA KNOW
WHAT THEY'RE GONNA DO BUT WE
NEED TO MAKE.
S. TAKING CARE --
I REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR
BRINGING OF FOR A MY GOAL IN
LIFE YOURS IS TO HELP PREVENT --
SOME OF THE THINGS AND YOU KNOW
I'M HOPING THAT --
AS WE GO FORWARD THAT IN TEN
YEARS FROM NOW YOU AND I ARE
LOOKING EACH OTHER AND SAYING
LOOK AT HOW MANY.
YOUNG PEOPLE THAT WE HAVE HELPED
SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
ANY FURTHER QUESTIONS FROM
MEMBERS.
SENATOR WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE.
RESPECT WITH LENOVO WE DO HAVE A
MOTION AND WHICH IS DUE PASSED
APPROPRIATIONS MOTION AND A
SECOND --
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
WOULD.
WOULD AYE MAYES AYE MAYES AYE
AGUIAR-CURRY.
HACKER CREE AYE BIGELOW.
BIGELOW AYE BONTA [inaudible]
BURKE.
BURKE I CARILLO.
CARILLO AYE FLORA.
FLORA I'M LIMON.
LIMON AYE MCCARTY MCCARTY AYE
NAZARIAN.
RODRIGUEZ SANTIAGO BERMAN.
THURMOND AYE WALDRON WALDRON AYE.
YOU ELEVEN VOTES SET THOSE OUT
AND WILL MAKE THE ROLE OF THE
FOR OTHER STAT ON WRITING
ASSIGNMENTS.
WHIMS OF APOLOGIZE FOR HAVING TO
STEP OUT IT WAS IN YOUR
COMMITTEE BY THE WAY AND SO.
THE ALL SEEING YOUR NAME PLATE
THERE.
OKAY SO SORRY SORRY FOR NOT
BEING THERE ARE FEWER AND AFTER
PULLING A POSITION I DOUBT IT SO.
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY SENATOR
[inaudible]
OKAY --
COLLEAGUES AYE AYE SENATE BILL --
TEN TWENTY ONE EXTENDS AND
EXPANDS UPON THE CRITICAL
CONSUMER PROTECTION PROVISIONS
OF AB.
THREE THIRTY NINE A BILL
AUTHORED BY THEN ASSEMBLY MEN
RICH GORDON.
OUT OF A SIGN IN THE LONG TWENTY
FIFTEEN EXPIRES AT THE END
TWENTY NINETEEN AND NOT BILL --
ARE PLACED A TO A COPAYS FOR
PRESCRIPTION MEDICATION --
AND THIS BILL WILL.
STAND BACK HAPPEN YOU KEEP IT IN
PLACE [inaudible]
ARE.
BEFORE THESE PROTECTIONS WERE
ENACTED.
ARE CONSUMERS WITH INSURANCE --
WERE STARTING TO BE HIT WITH
HUGE COPAYS.
OFFER EXAMPLE ALMOST ALL ITS A.
B. DRUGS AND CAR CALIFORNIA WERE
MOVED ON TO SO CALLED SPECIAL TO
TEARS.
ARE SO THAT ARE HIV POSITIVE
PEOPLE WERE ASKED TO PAY MONTHLY
COPAYS -- UP
TO EIGHT HUNDRED OR TWELVE
HUNDRED DOLLARS A MONTH.
I SAME WITH PEOPLE WITH AN S.
CELIAC DISEASE OTHER CONDITIONS.
I FIRST HEARD OF THIS ISSUE --
WHEN I WAS A MEMBER OF THE SAN
FRANCISCO BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
REPRESENTING --
AT A DISTRICT WITH VERY HIGH
POPULATION OF PEOPLE LIVING WITH
HIV.
AND I STARTED TO GET EMAILS.
AND PHONE CALLS FROM
CONSTITUENTS AND AYE TO SHOWED
UP AT THE PHARMACY THEY TOLD ME
I HAD TO PAY A THOUSAND DOLLARS
FOR MY DRUGS.
I CAN'T AFFORD IT AND SO I'M
GOING TO DIE --
AND WE ALL WORKED A LOCALLY IN A
STATE LEVEL IN THE LEGISLATURE --
EVEN THOUGH TO COOK THE THEY
STILL PLAY A LITTLE HIGHER THAN
I WOULD PREFER --
IT WAS CERTAINLY A HECK OF A LOT
BETTER THAN MONTH --
AND A LOT OF PEOPLE WERE ABLE.
TO CONTINUE TO TAKE THEIR
MEDICATION --
SO S. B. TEN TWENTY ONE WILL
KEEP THAT INTO AND THAT HAPPENED
PLACE WILL EXTEND THAT --
BY A FEW YEARS.
AYE AND ALSO --
I INCLUDES A PROVISION AND
RELATING --
TO CRAPPER PRE EXPOSURE
PROPHYLAXIS WHICH IS A ONE PILL
A DAY ON MEDICATION THAT ALMOST
ENTIRELY ELIMINATES THE RISK.
OF HIV -- IT
IS A KEY COMPONENT OF OUR EFFORT
TO ANN'S NEW HIV INFECTIONS ARE
ON THE BILL PUT SOME PROTECTIONS
IN PLACE.
US SO THAT I'M IF AND WHEN A TO
PILL --
GENERIC COMES ONTO THE MARKET.
WE DON'T SEE PEOPLE BEING FORCED
ONTO THE TO POLL REGIMEN BECAUSE
WE KNOW THAT WHEN YOU GO FROM
ONE PILL TO CALL THE MORE PILLS
PRESIDENT TO TAKE.
THE LOWER THE ADHERENCE AND WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
MAINTAIN.
I'D HEAR AND WE HAVE HAD A
NUMBER OF HEARINGS OUR OUR
FRIENDS AND HEALTH PLANS AND I'M
HAPPY TO ANNOUNCE THAT AFTER
EXTENSIVE NEGOTIATIONS AYE WE
HAVE I THINK COME.
TO ON A GOOD COMPROMISE --
THAT WILL ENSURE THAT PEOPLE CAN
ACCESS THE SINGLE PILL --
OPERA EXPOSURE PROPHYLAXIS I
DON'T SPEAK FOR THE HEALTH PLANS
BUT I'M I I AND I THINK WE'VE
COME -- TO
WHAT I HOPE IS A RESOLUTION --
SOCOG COLLEAGUES ARE THIS IS A I
THINK AN IMPORTANT.
APPETITE CHEN AND I ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE.
WHO'S NOT ILL.
AND WITH ME TODAY IS I'M
ARAMBULA THAT'S OF HEALTH ACCESS
AND COURTNEY PIERCE AND THE SAN
FRANCISCO AIDS FOUNDATION.
AND ARE MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS
NEARLY THOUSAND HEALTHAXIS
CALIFORNIA SPONSORS OF S. B..
TEN TWENTY ONE S. B. TEN TWENTY
ONE CONTAINS CONSUMER
PROTECTIONS SO THAT CONSUMERS
ARE CAUGHT IN THE MIDDLE BETWEEN
DRUG COMPANIES AND HEALTH PLANS.
COKIE CAPS HELP CONSUMERS AFFORD
THEIR PRESCRIPTION DRUGS AND AS
THE SENATOR WAS MENTIONING
BEFORE AB THREE THREE NINE
PROTECTIONS WERE PUT IN PLACE
AND TWENTY FIFTEEN CALIFORNIANS
WITH SERIOUS AND CHRONIC
CONDITIONS LIKE CANCER.
HIV AIDS MULTIPLE SCLEROSIS AND
LUPUS MORE PARTICULARLY
VULNERABLE TO HIGHER OUT OF
POCKET COSTS BECAUSE A HIGH COST
SPECIALTY DRUGS ROTH OFTEN PLACE
ON THE HIGHEST TIER OF DRUG
FORMULARIES WITH COAST
COINSURANCE OF THOUSANDS OF
DOLLARS. FOR SOME FAMILIES
FEELING JUST ONE PRESCRIPTION
MEANT CONSUMERS HAVE TO PAY
THEIRMAXIMUM OUT OF POCKET
LIMIT THAT SIX THOUSAND DOLLARS
FOR THAT ONE PRESCRIPTION IN
JANUARY OR THE FIRST FEW MONTHS
OF THE YEAR.
AND MOST OF US DON'T HAVE SIX
THOUSAND DOLLARS SAVED IN THE
BANK JUST A PAPER ONE DRUG.
AND THE COOKIE CAPS IN TWENTY
FIFTEEN FOR THAT THIRTY DAY
SUPPLY --
HELPED CONSUME BE MORE ABLE TO
FOR THEIR DRUGS BUT ALSO
PROHIBITED HEALTH PLANS FROM
PLACING MOST OR ALL OF THE DRUGS
TO TREAT ONE CONDITION ON THE
HIGHEST TIER OF A DRUG FORMULARY.
AND THIS HELPS PREVENT
DISCRIMINATION BASED ON A HEALTH
CONDITION.
OUT RECENT AMENDMENTS CLARIFY
FORMULAE STANDARDS AND I'M SURE
THAT --
PLANS DON'T REPLACE SINGLE
TABLET REGIMENTS WITH MULTI
TABLET --
RICHMOND FOR PREVENTION OF HIV
AND AIDS --
AND WE'D WOULD ALSO LIKE TO
THANK THE CHAIR AND THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR WORKING WITH
THE FUNDAMENTAL INCIDENTS
PROVISION AND I'VE MENTIONED
BEFORE THE BILL WILL HELP ENSURE
CALIFORNIANS ARE ABLE TO AFFORD
AND MORE EASILY ACCESS.
THEIR PRESCRIPTION DRUGS OF ANY
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M MY NAME IS
COURTNEY MULHEARN PEARSON WITH
THE SAN FRANCISCO AIDS
FOUNDATION AND ALSO THE CO CHAIR
OF THE CALIFONIA HIV ALLIANCE.
I'M HERE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SB
TEN TWENTY ONE ON WHICH AS
MENTIONED INCLUDES CRITICAL
PROTECTIONS FOR PEOPLE LIVING
WITH AN AT RISK FOR HIV.
BY ENSURING THEM ACCESS TO LIFE
SAVING AND MEDICATIONS
SPECIFICALLY THE AS MENTIONED
THE REQUIREMENT THAT HEALTH
PLANS COVER A SINGLE TABLET
REGIMENT ARE ASKED HE ARE FOR
THE TREATMENT AND PREVENTION --
OF EJB IS NECESSARY TO ENSURE
ACCESS TREATMENT AND PREVENTION
OF THE TAVY HAS COME A LONG WAY
OVER THE LAST TWENTY YEARS AND
WELL EARLY TREATMENT REGIMENS
CONSISTED OF MORE THAN.
TWENTY FIVE PILLS PER DAY SINGLE
TABLET REGIMENS HAVE SINCE BEEN
DEVELOPED THAT SIGNIFICANTLY
REDUCED PILL BURDEN INCREASE AT
KAREN'S IMPROVE HEALTH OUTCOMES.
AND LOWER THE LIKELIHOOD THAT
THE VIRUS WILL BECOME RESISTANT
TO TREATMENT.
OUT AGAIN AS MENTIONED IN TWENTY
TWELVE AND THE USE OF PROP TWO
BOTTAS PREP WAS APPROVED BY THE
FDA -- AND
IT THIS PROP IS A HIGHLY
EFFECTIVE PREVENTION STRATEGY --
IN WHICH HIV NEGATIVE
INDIVIDUALS TAKE A DAILY
MEDICATION TO REDUCE THEIR RISK
OF ACQUIRING --
HIV ALTHOUGH MULTI HAVE.
VARIANCE WITH HIV TREATMENT
SUGGEST THAT REDUCING KILBOURNE
IS MORE LIKELY TO INCREASE
ADHERENCE AND ENSURE THAT
VULNERABLE INDIVIDUALS REMAIN
HIV NEGATIVE --
INTELLIGENT ERIC SINGLE TABLET
REGIMEN FOR CRAP IS DEVELOPED IT
IS IMPORTANT TO IMPLEMENT STRONG
CONSUMER PROTECTIONS AND ENSURE
THAT VULNERABLE INDIVIDUALS ARE
NOT FORCED TO SWITCH TO MULTI
TABLET REGIMEN.
THAT MAY RESULT IN WHERE SAID
HEARINGS AN INCREASED RISK FOR
HIV HARM AND AGAIN NOTHING IN
THIS BILL PROHIBITS THE USE OF A
SINGLE GENERIC SINGLE TABLET
REGIMEN --
WHEN THEY BECOME AVAILABLE THANK
YOU?
BEST PAL FOR HEALTH ACCESS JUST
YEAR TO ANSWER A QUESTION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OTHERS IN
SUPPORT JUST TO NAME AN
ORGANIZATION PLEASE MAXINE
MENTALITY BEHALF THE NATIONAL
MULTIPLE SCLEROSIS SOCIETY IN
SUPPORT.
STEVEN SCHULTZ WITH ARTHRITIS
FOUNDATION IN SUPPORT.
KIMBERLY JUMPING UP THE
CALIFORNIA PAN ETHNIC HEALTH
NETWORK IN SPORTS.
TIM AND WORKS IN THE CALIFORNIA
RHEUMATOLOGY ALLIANCE IN SUPPORT.
NICK LEON RALPH THE ACLU OF
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
THAT SYMBOLS FROM CONSUMERS
UNION IN SUPPORT.
REDUCING DAVIS CALIFORNIA BY
KILL THAT WORK IN SUPPORT.
CAN CRABTREE I'M A VOLUNTEER FOR
A A RP SUPPORT.
GEN FLORA BEHALF OF WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY IN
SUPPORT.
AND THE GREATEST AMERICAN LUNG
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
REBECCA GONZALEZ NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN SUPPORT.
A MIKE MONTGOMERY WITH THE
CONGRESS OF CALIFORNIA SENIORS
WE SUPPORT.
JERRY HEX REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF FAMILY
PHYSICIANS IN SUPPORT.
AFTERNOON SEAMUS WITH CROWLEY ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA CLINIC
YOUR COALITION WORD SUPPORT.
ARE COVERED WITH SMALL BUSINESS
MAJORITY AND SUPPORT
[inaudible]
ANYONE ELSE.
SEE NO ONE OPPOSITION.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS THERESA
START WITH KAISER PERMANENTE A
WE DID HAVE CONCERNS.
ABOUT THIS BILL ON THE SENATE
SIDE WE WANTED TO BE.
SURE THAT WE DIDN'T
INADVERTENTLY LIMIT OPTIONS FOR
PREVENTION AND IS THE AUTHOR
STATED -- WE
HAVE BEEN ABLE TO WORK OUT
LANGUAGE SO WE WILL BE REMOVING
OPPOSITION AND WE WANNA THINK
THE AUTHOR.
AND THE SPONSORS AND THE
SUPPORTERS FOR WORKING WITH US
ON THAT WE UNDERSTAND THERE MAY
BE STILL OVER THE FINE TUNING OF
THE LANGUAGE SO WE WANT TO STAY
IN CLOSE TOUCH ON THAT WOULD WE
APPRECIATE IT THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIRMAN PRESIDENT LOUISE
US ON BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF HEALTH PLANS --
WOULD LIKE TO THINK THE AUTHOR
HIS STAFF SPONSOR IN THE
COMMITTEE --
FOR WORKING WITH US AND HOLDING
A SERIES OF MEETINGS ON THIS
BILL -- THAT
WE'RE NOT JUST CHECK THE BOX
MEETINGS WE WE WE APPRECIATE THE
LEVEL OF OUR CONVERSATION ON
THIS I'M AS A TWO THE RECENT
AMENDMENTS ARE HELPFUL WELL WITH
RESPECT TO THE BILL.
ABOUT S. YOU ALSO STATED THERE
MIGHT THERE MAY BE SOME FINE
TUNING OF THE LANGUAGE AS SUCH
OUR POLICY NOT TO OFFICIALLY OR
FORMALLY REMOVE OUR OPPOSITION
TO WE SEE SOME FINAL LANGUAGE
BUT WE HAVE MADE CONSIDERABLE
PROGRESS SO.
WE'VE OFFICIALLY REMAIN OPPOSED
TO THE BILL UNTIL --
WE SEE SOMETHING MORE FINAL JUST
ARE ON ANOTHER NOTE --
THE REASON WE OPPOSE A THESE
TYPES OF COPYCAT BILLS IS
BECAUSE THESE PRICE CONTROLS ON
OR BENEFIT HAVE A NEGATIVE
CORRESPONDING IMPACT ON PREMIUMS --
THE SUNSET THAT WAS ADDED TO
THIS BILL CERTAINLY IS HELPFUL
ON IN THE FUTURE WHEN THE SUNSET
ROLLS AROUND WE THINK OF A
PROPER.
ANALYSIS BY THE CALIFORNIA
HEALTH BENEFITS IN REVIEW
PROGRAM --
THAT WOULD BE TO ANALYZE WHAT
THE POSITIVE IMPACT OR PREMIUM
RELIEF WOULD BE --
IF THESE COPAKE CAPS --
WERE ON EXPIRED OR MODIFIED ON
BECAUSE THE MONTHLY PREMIUM IS
ARE OBVIOUSLY VERY IMPORTANT
FOLKS -- WHO
WERE SHOPPING FOR COVERAGE SO --
WITH THOSE COMMENTS --
WE LOOK FOR FURTHER DISCUSSION
SEEING HOW LANGUAGE SHAPES OUT
IN THE FINAL VERSION SO THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU AND ANYONE WITH
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA LIFE
AND HEALTH INSURANCE COMPANIES
WERE IN THE SAME POSITION AS OUR
COLLEAGUES FROM CAP AND UP THE
HOPE THAT WE CAN SOON TAKE OFF
OUR OPPOSITION AMONG I THINK THE
AUTHOR AND THE COMMITTEE STAFF
FOR WORKING WITH US THANK YOU SO.
MUCH.
GARY MUCH ANYONE ELSE.
SEE NO WERE BRING BACK TO
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS ANYONE COMMITTEE.
SEEING NONE OF THE LIKE CLOSE
CENTER WINNER I THANK YOU AND I
I'M I'M GONNA GO OUT THANK.
BOTH OUR SUPPORTERS NAY
OPPOSITION OF ROOM FOR WORKING
TOGETHER I JUST WANT TO KNOW IN
TERMS OF COMMENT UP THROUGH THE
HEALTH PLANS I RESPECT --
INSURANCE COMPANIES ARE ALWAYS
IN US AND YOU KNOW THAT THEY'VE
GOT A TOUGH SPOT WHEN DRUG
PRICES.
ARE AS HIGH AS THEY ARE I DON'T
WANNA UNDERESTIMATE OUT BY --
AND WE CAN TALK ABOUT
CONTROLLING COSTS WHICH IS
IMPORTANT BUT THE PURPOSE OF
INSURANCE IS THAT WE SPREAD RISK
AROUND SO AND IF YOU HAVE
SOMEONE SHOWING UP AT THE
PHARMACY BEING CHARGED A
THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR A MONTHLY
SUPPLY.
OUT DODD IS NOT SPREADING RISK
AND PEOPLE NEED TO BE ABLE TO
ACTUALLY ACCESS OR COVERED
THAT'S WHAT THIS IS ABOUT SO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK WHEN I GO.
WELL THANK YOU VERY MUCH THAT
THE BILL DOES ENJOY DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION I'M AND COMMEND
YOU ON YOUR WORK WITH THE
OPPOSITION AND I KNOW THAT WE
CAN YOU'RE GOING FORWARD CAN
APPRECIATE YOU BRINGING THIS
BILL FORWARD SO.
IT'S IMPORTANT FOR PATIENTS AND
SUPPORT FOR HEALTHCARE AND I
APPRECIATE YOUR WORK ON THE AYE
SO.
I WITHOUT MADAM SECRETARY THE
MOTION WE DO HAVE A MOTION --
MADE BY --
SEGERA CURRY IN A SECOND BY MISS
WALDRON THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS MEMSIC TRIP
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL WOULD I
WOULD I MAYES.
MAYES AYE AGUIAR-CURRY.
AND HERE CURRY AYE BIGELOW.
BIGELOW AYE.
BONTA [inaudible]
BURKE.
BURKE I CARILLO.
CARILLO AYE FLORA.
FLORA AYE LOW MOAN.
LIMON AYE MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE NAZARIAN
[inaudible]
RODRIGUEZ.
RODRIGUEZ I SANTIAGO
[inaudible]
THURMOND [inaudible]
THURMOND I WALDRON. ELEVEN VOTES
WILL LEAP THAT'S THAT'S MORE
THAN ENOUGH TO GET OUT COMMITTEE
WILL LEAVE IT ON OPEN FOR OTHERS
TO ADD ON TAKES MUCH SENATOR
[inaudible]
SENATE CANNELLA.
YOU HAVE --
SENATE BILL SEVEN OH SEVEN
CENTER CAN NOW.
MY AREA CODE.
AS CHAIR OF THE BILL.
THANK YOU AS CHAIRMAN --
FOLLOW UP ON LEGISLATION THAT A
TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN IT WAS OUT
OF THIS COMMITTEE I THINK
UNANIMOUSLY WHAT TO
APPROPRIATIONS WAS GOT INTO A
REPORT --
DEPARTMENTS WAS FIVE MONTHS
LATER GIVE US THE REPORT I'M
STILL CONCERNED SO WE'RE GOING
TO PERSONAL EXCEPT THE
AMENDMENTS I THINK IT MAKES THE
BILL BETTER.
AND I ASKED FOR A JENNIFER
CANADA WITH AARON READING
ASSOCIATES ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA DENTAL HYGIENISTS
ASSOCIATION.
CD HA MEMBERS INCLUDE A HIGH
JANICE WHO CONTRACTOR UGLY WOULD
DENY CALLUM PROVIDE PREVENTIVE.
DENTAL HYGIENE CARE TO ELDERLY
AND DISABLED POPULATIONS
PATIENTS IN NURSING HOMES AND TO
THOSE WHO ARE HOMEBOUND THE
DEPARTMENT ENACTED RECENT
POLICIES CREATING ROADBLOCKS TO
CARE SUCH AS SLASHING THE
REIMBURSEMENT. FOR PERIODONTAL
DISEASE CARE REQUIRING DENTAL
HYGIENISTS TO GET PRIOR
AUTHORIZATION FROM THE
DEPARTMENT BEFORE PROVIDING
XRAYS.
BUT BEFORE PROVIDING THE
REQUIRED CARE AND REQUIRING.
PATIENT THE PATIENTS TO TAKE
MORE X. RAYS THESE POLICIES
DELAY AND DENY CARE AND ARE
HARMFUL TO PATIENTS CD HA ECHOES
THE CONCERNS RAISED BY THE
LITTLE HOOVER COMMISSION AND THE
STATE AUDITOR.
WE AGREE SYSTEMIC CHANGES
CONTINUE TO BE NEEDED IT WITH
DEBT WITHIN TEN A CAL IN ORDER
TO HAVE A PROGRAM THAT CAN
OBTAIN PROVIDERS AND ENABLE
PATIENTS.
WHO NEED THE PROGRAM THE MOST TO
TRULY ACCESS CARE CREATING AN
ADVISORY GROUP OF EXPERTS IN
EVIDENCE BASED PREVENTIVE AND
RESTORATIVE ORAL HEALTH CARE
WILL HELP THE DEPARTMENT CREATE
POLICIES BASED ON THE BEST?
HEALTH CARE EVIDENCE AND
OUTCOMES HERE I THINK.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS JEANIE
WILL FIND THE ACTING EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR FOR THE LITTLE HOOVER
COMMISSION.
AND I AM HERE TO EXPRESS THE
COMMISSION SUPPORT FOR S. B..
SEVEN OH SEVEN AS YOU KNOW THE
LITTLE HOOVER COMMISSION IS AN
OVERSIGHT AGENCY WE PRIMARILY
EXPLORE WAYS TO MAKE GOVERNMENT
AGENCIES AND PROGRAMS MORE
EFFICIENT.
AND EFFECTIVE.
I IN APRIL OF TWO THOUSAND
FIFTEEN SENATOR RICHARD PAN AND
CHAIRMAN WOULD.
SENATE JOINT LETTER TO THE
COMMISSION ASKING THE COMMISSION
TO EXAMINE THE DECK HELP PROGRAM.
THE COMMISSION AGREED AND
CONDUCTED AT A YEAR LONG STUDY
OF THE PROGRAM WITH A FOCUS ON
HOW TO IMPROVE.
THE DENTAL CALLISON OFFICES.
THROUGH HEARINGS IN INTERVIEWS
OF STAKEHOLDERS MANY WHO WERE
EXPERTS IN DENTISTRY TREATMENT
AND CARE.
THE COMMISSION HEARD COMPLAINTS
ABOUT THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH
CARE SERVICES UNILATERAL
DECISION MAKING.
COMMISSIONERS LEARNED THAT THIS
LACK OF MEANINGFUL COMMUNICATION.
BETWEEN DATE D. EIGHT C. A. S.
M. STAKEHOLDERS NEGATIVELY
IMPACTED ACCESS CARE.
WE RECEIVE SUGGESTIONS FOR AN
EVIDENCE BASED ADVISORY
COMMITTEE. TO ASSESS THE
DECISION MAKING.
ABDI EIGHT CS WITH.
RECIPROCALLY WITH REGARD TO DENY
CAO.
AFTER DELIBERATION AND
THOUGHTFUL CONSIDERATION THE
COMMISSION AGREED.
THAT THE CREATION OF AN EVIDENCE
BASED ADVISORY GROUP WOULD BE
THE BEST WAY TO ASSESS AND
IMPROVE DE EIGHT C. S.'S
POLICYMAKING PROCESS.
WHEN IT COMES TO DEMOCRATS?
THE COMMISSION MADE THIS
RECOMMENDATION IN ITS APRIL TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN REPORT CALLED
FIXING DINNER CAL.
LAST YEAR THE COMMISSION
SUPPORTED A PREVIOUS VERSION OF
SB SEVEN OF SEVEN THAT WAS S. B.
TEN NINETY EIGHT ALSO AUTHORED
BY SENATOR CANNELLA WHO ALSO
SERVES ON THE LITTLE HOOVER
COMMISSION.
THE COMMISSION STRONGLY SUPPORTS
S. B. SEVEN OH SEVEN THIS BILL
ENSURES THERE WILL BE
KNOWLEDGEABLE EXPERTS ON THE
ADVISORY COMMITTEE.
THE BILL ALSO ENSURE
TRANSPARENCY BY REQUIRING AN IN
AN ANNUAL REPORT TO THE
LEGISLATURE WHICH MUST BE POSTED
ON THE D. EIGHT CS WEBSITE.
THIS BILL THAT'S CREATES AND
MUCH NEEDED MEANINGFUL FEEDBACK
LOOP THAT WILL ONLY BENEFIT IN
APPROVED IN A CAL I SUGGEST THIS
BILL IS NOT JUST A GOOD IDEA
IT'S IMPERATIVE FOR THIS PROGRAM.
THERE FOR THE COMMISSION URGES
AN AYE VOTE ON SB SEVEN ON SEVEN
THANK YOU.
YOU VERY MUCH FATHER SINCE
SUPPORT.
LINDA WAY WITH WESTERN CENTER ON
LAW AND POVERTY IN SUPPORT AND
APPRECIATE THE AMENDMENTS.
I GOOD AFTERNOON BRAND APARTMENT
SPONSOR WITH THE CALIFORNIA
DENTAL ASSOCIATION ACTUALLY HERE
WITH THE SUPPORT OF AMENDED
POSITION --
I THINK I WOULD BE REMISS IF I
DIDN'T ACKNOWLEDGE ALL THE WORK
AND THAT TENSION THAT HAS GONE
INTO THE DENTAL PROGRAM SINCE A
LITTLE COOPER COMMISSION REPORT
WAS PUBLISHED IN TWENTY SIXTEEN
INCLUDING.
INVESTMENTS THROUGH PROPOSITION
FIFTY SIX REALLY APPRECIATE DE
AYE WORK OF THE AUTHOR ON BEING
SO DEDICATED TO THE PROGRAM INTO
IMPROVEMENTS WE KNOW THEY'RE
STILL LONG WAY TO GO.
ALSO ONE APPRECIATE THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS ESPECIALLY
I'M EXPANDING THE FOCUS OF THE
GROUP TO INCLUDE ADULTS AS WELL
AS CHILDREN WHENEVER INITIAL
REQUEST WAS MADE.
THERE WAS NO ADULT PROGRAM SO WE
THINK THAT I'M ANY ADVICE RECOUP
REALLY DOES NEED TO LOOK AT
ADULTS.
THEY WERE ALSO SAY THAT AND WE
CONTINUE TO THINK THAT I'M MORE
A SMALLER AND MORE NARROWLY
FOCUSED ADVISORY GROUP WOULD BE
MORE BENEFICIAL.
AND BUT POTENTIALLY LESS
DUPLICATIVE OF THE EXISTING
STAKEHOLDER GROUPS THAT ARE OUT
THERE THERE ARE A NUMBER OF THEM
WOULD REALLY LIKE TO SEE I
PERIODIC REVIEW OF THE BENEFIT
PACKAGE THE COVERED CODES.
SOMETHINGS ARE VERY CLINICAL AND
VERY EVIDENCE BASED THAT MAKE
SURE THAT THE DENTAL PROGRAM.
DOES MATCH UP WITH AND EXIT
BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT THEY OFTEN
SORT OF LAGGED BEHIND AS THAT --
IN AS A PROFESSIONS ARE VAULTS
SO EXPERT AS SUPPORTIVE AMENDED
BY APPRECIATE THE WORK OF THE
COMMITTEE THINK.
IS THERE ANYONE IN OPPOSITION.
NUMBER BRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE.
SEEING NONE SENATOR CANNELLA
JUST CLOSE YET THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN JUST THIS IS A PROBLEM
AND IT CONTINUES TO BE A PROBLEM
AND ANYTHING WE CAN DO. TO
INCREASE THE THE RATES OF OF
ADULTS AND CHILDREN USING DATA
CAL I THINK IS WHEN I THINK THIS
IS A MODEST STEP BEFORE THAT ASK
FOR ABOUT.
THANKS VERY MUCH SENATOR I
APPRECIATE YOU BRINGING THIS
BILL FORWARD I THINK I THINK
IT'S THE RIGHT BILL THE RIGHT
TIME AND IT DIDN'T JOYS A DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION FOR YOUR
DEDICATION TO THIS EFFORT.
ON AN ONGOING BASIS FOR QUITE
AWHILE NOW SO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH -- WITH
THAT -- THE
MOTION -- WE
DON'T HAVE A MUCH WE HAVE MOTION
OF SORRY WE HAVE MOTION FOR
MISTER MAYES A SECOND BY MISTER
BIGELOW THE MOTIONS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
WOULD I WOULD I MAYES MAYES AYE
AGAR CURRY FIGURE CREE AYE
BIGELOW AYE BIGELOW AYE BONTA
[inaudible]
BURKE.
BURKE I CARILLO.
CARILLO AYE FLORA.
FLORA ISLA MODE.
LIMON AYE MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE NOSE AREA
[inaudible]
RODRIGUEZ.
RODRIGUEZ I SANTIAGO
[inaudible]
THURMOND.
BERMAN I WALDRON. ELEVEN ZERO
YOUR BILL IS OUT LEAVE THE ROLE
OPEN FOR OTHERS TO ADD ON THANKS
VERY MUCH SENATOR.
DR HERNANDEZ.
YOU HAVE FOR BILLS BEFORE US
SENATOR HERNANDEZ IF THEY DO
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS GOOD
AFTERNOON.
YOU DON'T MIND CAN WE START OFF
WITH S. B. NINE TEN PERFECT
THINK SO MUCH.
AS CHAIR MEMBERS OF THIS BILL
MAKES IT CLEAR THAT SHORT TERM
LIMITED DURATION HEALTH
INSURANCE MAY NOT BE SOLD IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
THESE POLICIES REQUIRE EXTENSIVE
HEALTH QUESTION YEARS USED BY
THE CARRY TO RATHER DENY
COVERAGE.
OR EXCLUDE COVERAGE IF THE
PERSON IS ALLOWED TO PURCHASE
ONE OF THESE POLICIES.
YEAH VARIOUS SIDE DEDUCTIBLE
AMOUNTS THEY HAVE BENEFIT
LIFETIME BENEFITS OF UP TO SEVEN
AND FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS --
AND THEY DO HAVE PREEXISTING
CONDITION EXCLUSIONS.
THE POLICY WILL NOT PROVIDE
BENEFITS FOR ANY LOSS CAUSED BY
OR RESULTING PRE EXISTING
CONDITION THEY DEFINE A PRE
EXISTING CONDITION AS ANY
MEDICAL CONDITION.
OR SICKNESS FOR WHICH THE
MEDICAL ADVICE CARE DIAGNOSIS
TREATMENT CONSULTATION
MEDICATION WITH A RECOMMENDATION
RECEIVE FROM A DOCTOR WITHIN THE
SIX MONTHS.
IMMEDIATE PRECEDING THE COVERED
PERSONS EFFECTIVE DATE OF
COVERAGE OR SYMPTOMS WITHIN THE
SIX MONTHS AMELIA PRIOR TO
COVERAGE THAT WOULD CAUSE A
REASONABLE PERSON TO SEEK
DIAGNOSIS CARE.
OR TREATMENT.
I HAVE NUMEROUS EXAMPLES OF
SEEMINGLY HEALTHY INDIVIDUALS
WHO WERE HARMED BY THESE
PRODUCTS WHO HAD A RIGHT TO
RESORT TO LITIGATION TO GET
THEIR BILLS PAID.
AND SOME OF THE COURTS THEN RULE
IN THE FAVOR THE POLICYHOLDER
BECAUSE OF THE PRE EXISTING
CONDITIONS.
THE PROPONENTS OF SHORT TERM
LIMIT IT --
INSURANCE --
ARGUE THAT THERE ARE NEEDED FOR
LIFE TRANSITIONS ARE SOMETIMES
WHEN INDIVIDUALS ARE IN BETWEEN
JOBS.
THE AFFORDABLE CARE ACT AS WE
KNOW HAS SPECIAL ROMAN PERIOD IF
THE TRANSITION HAPPENS.
OUTSIDE OF OPEN ENROLLMENT
PERIOD IN AN ELIGIBLE PERSON CAN
ROLE IN MEDI CAL IT ANYTIME.
THE YEAR MEDI CAL HAS NO OPEN
ROMAN PERIOD.
SHORT TERM INSURANCE RESULTS AN
INCREASE IN THE COST OF THE
AFFORDABLE CARE ACT PLANS BY
DRAWING THE YOUNGER HEALTHIER
INDIVIDUALS OUT OF THE ACA
MARKET.
AND INTO AND REENTER WHEN THEY
HAVE HEALTHY OR CARE CRISIS.
THE PROMOTION OF THESE PLANS IS
THE SABOTAGE IN THE AFFORDABLE
CARE ACT WHEN KERRY OF THE
PRODUCT IS OFFERING HIGH
COMMISSION RATES AS HIGH AS 22%.
TO INSURANCE AGENTS WITH BONUSES
FOR SHORT TERM PLANS WITHOUT
MEMBERS THEY HAVE RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE NAME
INDIVIDUALS LIKE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF THE MEASURE THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHEN MEMBERS
MANAGING FORESTS ON BEHALF OF
HEALTHAXIS CALIFORNIA AT THE
STATEWIDE HEALTHCARE CONSUMER
ADVOCACY COALITION.
WE'RE PROUD TO SPONSOR AND
SUPPORT S. B. NINE TEN WHICH
WOULD BAN THE SALE OF SHORT TERM
INSURANCE WHICH ARE JUNK
INSURANCE PLANS.
SHORT TERM INSURANCE PROVIDES
VERY LIMITED BENEFITS AND IS NOT
OFFERED THE SAME CONSUMER
PROTECTIONS OR ESSENTIAL HEALTH
BENEFITS.
THAT A CA PLANTS DO PEOPLE CAN
BE DENIED FOR PRE EXISTING
CONDITIONS AND ALSO BENEFITS ARE
LIMITED.
CONSUMERS CAN ALREADY GET SHORT
TERM COVERAGE FROM COVER
CALIFORNIA SINCE TWENTY FOURTEEN
COVER CALIFORNIA HAS SERVED MORE
THAN THIRTY THREE MILLION PEOPLE.
HALF OF THEM HAVE HAD COVERAGE
FOR LESS THAN A YEAR.
CONSUMERS WHO GO TO COVER
CALIFORNIA FOR COVERAGE P
SUBSIDIES TO HELP PAY FOR
MONTHLY PREMIUMS.
ANDTHEY CAN GET COMPREHENSIVE
COVERAGE WITH NO PRE EXISTING
CONDITION DENIALS.
CONSUMERS WHO LOSE THEIR JOBS
AND BECOME UNEMPLOYED
TEMPORARILY CAN GET MEDI CAL AT
ZERO COST. FOR PREMIUMS AND ALSO
COPAYS.
WE HAVE LOOKED THAT SHORT TERM
INSURANCE AND TRIED TO FIGURE
OUT IF IT'S USEFUL TO CONSUMERS
AND WHAT YOU WILL HEAR THE
OPPOSITION SAY IS THAT IF PEOPLE
MISSED THE OPEN ENROLLMENT
PERIODS.
THEY CANNOT GET COVERAGE.
THAT IS PARTLY RIGHT AND PARTLY
WRONG IF SOMEONE LOSES THEIR
COVERS BECAUSE THEY LOSE THEIR
JOB THEY GET DIVORCED OR FOR
SOME OTHER REASON THEY WOULD
QUALIFY FOR SPECIAL ENROLLMENT
PERIOD.
THROUGH COVER CALIFORNIA OR
THROUGH MEDI CAL.
WHAT ABOUT IF SOMEBODY MISSES
THE OPEN ENROLLMENT PERIOD AND
DOES NOT QUALIFY FOR SPECIAL
ENROLLMENT?
WE HAVE OPEN ENROLLMENT AND
SPECIAL ENROLLMENT PERIODS FOR A
REASON I'M DOING THE STRUCTURE
OF OPEN ENROLLMENT AND SPECIAL
ENROLLMENT PERIODS ON THOSE ARE
INDIVIDUAL MARKET RULES AND ALSO
DESTABILIZES OR INDIVIDUAL
INSURANCE MARKETS.
WHICH WOULD ACTUALLY INCREASE
PREMIUMS FOR CONSUMERS.
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION
PROPOSED.
SABOTAGE I'M DUE THE ACA AND
THAT IS JUST WHAT IT DOES --
THOSE WHO WANT TO SELL THESE
PRODUCTS WANT TO UNDO THE ECA
FOR THESE REASONS WE ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
OF THE BILL.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE ON
BETSY IN HOPES FOR CONSUMERS
UNION THE ADVOCACY DIVISION OF
CONSUMER REPORT SOME ALSO A
CONSUMER REPRESENTATIVE AT THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
INSURANCE COMMISSIONERS WHERE
THIS ISSUE OF SHORT TERM PLANS.
AND AS A MATTER OF CONCERN.
NUMBER PROUD TO SUPPORT THIS
BILL TO MATT MITIGATE THE
EXPECTED DAMAGE FROM THE FEDERAL
RULE WHICH IS DUE OUT ANY DAY
NOW ONTO X. INTENDED TO EXPAND
THE USE OF SHORT TERM I
INSURANCE POLICIES WITH LIMITED
COVERAGE.
CONSUMER REPORTS IS CALLED THESE
LOW VALUE PLANS JUNK INSURANCE A
FULL OF GARAGES AND GIMMICKS ALL
THE THINGS THAT MADE US --
SUPPORT THE AFFORDABLE CARE ACT
ON REFORMS TO BEGIN WITH.
I'M WE ARE ALREADY SEEING MORE
AGGRESSIVE ON AND DECEPTIVELY --
MARKETED PRODUCTS OF THIS KIND
AND EXPECT A SPIKE IN MARKETING --
AS THESE --
PLANS CARRY COMMISSIONS THAT ARE
SIX TO EIGHT TIMES WE UNDERSTAND
THE AMOUNT OF COMMISSIONS FOR
AFFORDABLE CARE ACT PLANS.
HERE'S AN EXAMPLE THAT CAME TO
CONSUMERS UNION BEFORE THE
AFFORDABLE CARE ACT BUT WHAT
WOULD BE ALLOWED AS A SHORT TERM
PLAN TODAY.
ON JUDITH BELIEVED HER HEALTH
PLAN -- THAT
SHE BUT WAS COMPREHENSIVE
INSURANCE ONLY WHEN SHE WAS
DIAGNOSED WITH BREAST CANCER DID
SHE LEARN OF IT SEVERE
LIMITATIONS THE THOUSAND DOLLAR
LIMIT FOR CHEMOTHERAPY ON AN
OUTPATIENT BASIS AND TWO
THOUSAND DOLLARS.
LIMIT FOR HOSPITALIZATION.
FACING A THIRTY THOUSAND DOLLAR
BILL --
ESTIMATE SHE DELAYED HER
TREATMENT UNTIL THE SURGEON SAID
WE CAN'T YOU CAN'T WAIT ANY
LONGER IT WAS THREE CENTIMETERS
WHEN THEY FOUND IT AND NINE
CENTIMETERS WHEN THEY TOOK IT
OUT REQUIRING A DOUBLE
MASTECTOMY.
ON END OF RADIATION AND
RECONSTRUCTIVE SURGERY AND SHE
WAS LEFT WITH A TWENTY EIGHT
THOUSAND DOLLAR A HOSPITAL BILL
WE DON'T WANT OTHER CONSUMERS
STUCK WITH THIS KIND OF BIND
THAT DEVASTATE BOTH THEIR HEALTH
AND THEIR FAMILY FINANCES --
MISS FLORES IS DESCRIBE THE
THINGS THAT ARE LACKING IN THESE
POLICIES THEY AIM TO ATTRACT
YOUNGER AND HEALTHIER.
OF CONSUMERS AND THEREFORE WOULD
DRAIN THE AND SIPHON OFF THOSE
HEALTHY CONSUMERS FROM THE
INDIVIDUAL MARKET THE OVERALL
RESULT WILL BE A FRAGMENTED
DESTABILIZED INDIVIDUAL MARKET.
A IN THE STATE WITH HIGHER COSTS
FOR THOSE COMPREHENSIVE COVERAGE
THAT OF THE AFFORDABLE CARE ACT.
WOULD ALLOW ON NINE TEN WOULD
AVERT THESE PROBLEMS AND WE URGE
YOUR STRONG SUPPORT TO PUT
CALIFORNIA IN THE FOREFRONT WITH
A COUPLE OF OTHER STATES THAT
HAVE.
MOVED TO ON TO BUY THESE PLANTS
THANK YOU.
AFTER BELFER HEALTHAXIS JUST
YEAR TO ANSWERING QUESTIONS.
OTHERS TO SUPPORT JUST NAME
ORGANIZATION PLEASE KIMBERLY TEN
ARE PATH THE CALIFORNIA PAN
ETHNIC HEALTH NETWORK IN SUPPORT
PICK YOU.
MICHELLE EDITOR WITH SEIU
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
GEN FLORES WESTERN CENTER ON LAW
AND POVERTY IN SUPPORT.
IT'S IN DAVIS CALIFORNIA BY KILL
THAT WORK IN SUPPORT.
DEBORAH DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA SUPPORT.
MAXINE MANTLE BEHALF THE
NATIONAL MULTIPLE SCLEROSIS
SOCIETY IN SUPPORT.
THERESA START BECAUSE A
PERMANENT A STRONG SUPPORT.
BECAUSE SUPPORT A BUSHEL OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
CHAU OR OCARINA HEALTHCARE IN
SUPPORT. TO YOU ON THE CITY THEY
FOR THE ALAMEDA COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN SUPPORT.
ALTAMONT AND SMITH WITH THE
AMERICAN CANCER SOCIETY CANCER
ACTION NETWORK ALSO IN SUPPORT.
WHEN THE GREATEST AMERICAN LUNG
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT?
A DAVID GONZALEZ AMERICA'S VISIT
PHYSICIAN GROUPS AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
SHIPMENTS BEEN GROWING ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA CLINIC YOUR
COALITION IN SUPPORT.
MY COVER WITH SMALL BUSINESS
MAJORITY IN STRONG SUPPORT.
ERIC HARRIS ON BEHALF THE
MARKDOWNS IN SUPPORT.
MIKE MONTGOMERY CONGRESS OF
CALIFORNIA SENIORS IN SUPPORT.
JANICE CANAL ON WITH THE
CHILDREN'S DEFENSE FUND AND ON
BEHALF OF THE CHILDREN'S HEALTH
COVERAGE COALITION IN SUPPORT.
SARAH FLOCKS CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION IN SUPPORT SECURE.
CHRIS KILEY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT POLICY
CENTER IN SUPPORT.
ANGELIQUE YORK WITH NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
AND SUPPORT. TO MADDEN HERBS IN
THE CALIFORNIA CHAPTER THE
AMERICAN COLLEGE OF EMERGENCY
PHYSICIANS AND SPORT
[inaudible]
ANYONE ELSE.
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME'S JIM
MORRISON WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF HEALTH
UNDERWRITERS.
OR ONE OF THE LARGEST --
GROUPS MET PROFESSIONAL HEALTH
INSURANCE AGENTS IN CALIFORNIA.
WE APPRECIATE THIS BILL THE
OTHER BRING THIS BILL FORWARD
AGREEMENT ABOUT ENSURING THE
CONSUMERS ON ROLE IN CONFERENCE
OF COVERAGE IN ENSURING THE
STABILITY THE MARKETPLACE.
HOWEVER WE ASK FOR SOME
CONSIDERATION OF SOME AMENDMENTS.
MAKING THESE PLANS AVAILABLE
ONLY TO THOSE WHO OR OTHERWISE
PROHIBITED FOR PURCHASING OTHER
COMPREHENSIVE COVERAGE.
UNTIL THE OPEN ENROLLMENT PERIOD
MAKING THEM NON RENEWABLE.
AND JUST KEEPING THEM AND LIKE I
SAID A SHORTER PERIOD SO I CAN
GET THEM TO THE OPEN ENROLLMENT
PERIOD. ONE OF OUR GOALS AT WE
FOUND IS THAT A LOT EASIER TO
TRANSITION SOMEONE FROM A SHORT
TERM PLAN TO A MORE PERMANENT
COMPREHENSIVE COVERAGE.
THAT IS IF WE DON'T KNOW ABOUT
THEM IN THE FIRST PLACE.
WE DON'T WANT TO REPLACE THESE
ARE USED THESE IN PLACE OF
CONFERENCE OF COVERAGE WE WANTED
JUST BASICALLY GUIDE THEM TO THE
PATH. TO ENSURE STABILITY
[inaudible]
SO.
ALSO WOODS ONE REFERENCE NUMBER
THE EXAMPLES THAT WERE ISSUE
JUST A FEW MOMENTS AGO.
TEND TO BE UP FOR PRACTICES THAT
ARE NOT COMMON IN CALIFORNIA
THAT TEND TO BE MORE OUT OF
STATE TYPE OF PRACTICES.
THIS IS A VERY VERY SMALL
SEGMENT OF THE POPULATION THAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT BUT WHEN
SOMEONE COMES TO AN OFFICE LIKE
MINE IN NEED COVERAGE AND WE
DON'T HAVE ANYWHERE ELSE TO GO
THIS IS ONE TOOL THAT WE HAVE
LEFT IN THE TOOLBOX TO USE.
SO WITH THESE AMENDMENTS WE
THINK IT CAN BE DOABLE.
I THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEAK TO YOU TODAY WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR IF HE'S OPEN TO THESE
AMENDMENTS THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIRMAN REYES LARA
BENNETT WITH TECH NETS MAYBE ASK
ME WHY I'M HERE TODAY IS FOR
INTERNET COMPANIES THAT ALLOW
CONSUMERS TO GO ONLINE AND LOOK
IN OPTIONS ARE AVAILABLE TO THEM.
I HAVE MY MY COMMENTS FOR THOSE
OF MY COLLEAGUE BEFORE ME THEM
IF THEY WERE SEEKING TODAY
MERELY ALLOW FOR THIS OFFERING
OF INSURANCE UNDER SOME GUARD
RAILS PARAMETERS. TO ELIMINATE
SOME OF THE CIRCUMSTANCES THAT
WERE ALLOWED TODAY IE PASS OUT A
REPORT TO MOST OF YOU IN YOUR
OFFICES OF YOU TO RECEIVE A
PLEASE LET ME KNOW.
WHENEVER COMPANIES SURVEYED
THEIR CONSUMERS THAT BOT SHORT
TERM INSURANCE OVER 50% OF THEM
SAID THAT IF THEY DID NOT HAVE
THIS CAPABILITY OF A BY THIS
INSURANCE THEY WOULD GO
UNINSURED.
GOING ON ENSURE IS GOING TO
RAISE COSTS IN THE HEALTHCARE
SYSTEM WE ASK THAT YOU CONSIDER
THESE AMENDMENTS AND WITHOUT OF
THE MEMBERS RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE
TODAY.
YOU VERY MUCH.
NO ONE ELSE.
SEE NO ONE BRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE.
FOR WE DO A MOTION.
WE NOW BECAUSE WE HAVE MOTION
AND FIRST WELL THANK YOU A
SENATOR FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD --
WE WORKED HARD TO WRAP.
MAINTAIN CONSUMER PROTECTIONS
UNDER THE ACA.
INCLUDING BANS ON PRE EXISTING
CONDITIONS MINIMUM COVERAGE
REQUIREMENTS THAT DID NOT EXIST
BEFORE.
AND I'M REALLY HESITANT TO
RETURN TO MARKETPLACE THAT WERE
POLICIES OFFER BENEFITS.
WITH LIMITATIONS ACOSTA INFUSION
AS TO WHAT'S ACTUALLY COVERED
AND FOR HOW HOW MUCH WHEN WE
DON'T REALLY NEED.
TO WE NEED TO FOCUS ON
STRENGTHENING THE COVERAGE WE
HAVE NOW.
I APPRECIATE YOU BRINGING THIS
BILL FORWARD IT DOES ENJOY DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION.
I WE HAVE A MOTION --
FROM --
MISSILE YEAR CURRY A SECOND FROM
MISTER RODRIGUEZ MOTIONS TO PASS
TO APPROPRIATIONS AND MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
WOULD I WOULD I MAYES.
MAYES NO VOTING AGUIAR-CURRY.
ACTOR CORY I BIGELOW.
BIGELOW NOT VOTING [inaudible]
BONTA.
BURKE BURKE AYE CARILLO.
CARILLO AYE FLORA.
FLORIDA VOTING.
LIMON.
LEVINE AYE MCCARTY.
MCCARTY I NAZARIAN [inaudible]
RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ I SANTIAGO
[inaudible]
THURMOND [inaudible]
WALDRON.
S. SEVEN VOTES WHO WE ONE MORE
WE HAVE SEVERAL MEMBERS MISSING
SO WILL OUR LEGACY CHAIR MEMBERS.
WE DO AS SCREEN NINE NINE TWO
PERFECT THANK YOU SIR THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MISTER CHAIRMAN
THERE'S A WILL START BY
ACCEPTING THE TECHNICAL
AMENDMENTS TO CLARIFY.
THE D. EIGHT C. EIGHT S.
AUTHORITY TO SUSPEND OR REVOKE
LICENSES AND TO TERMINATE REVIEW
OF AN APPLICATION WHEN THE
LICENSES BEEN PREVIOUSLY SPENT A
REVOKED.
WE'VE BEEN HEARING ABOUT SOME
TROUBLING PRACTICES HAPPENING
AND SUBSTANCE ABUSE TREATMENT
INDUSTRY.
WHILE THE MAJORITY OF TREATMENT
SYSTEMS ARE OPERATE WITHIN THE
LAW THERE ARE A FEW BAD ACTORS
OUT THERE AND WE NEED.
TO PROTECT INDIVIDUALS WITH
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDERS WHO
NEEDED A RANGE OF SERVICES
INDIVIDUALS WITH SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDERS DESERVE ACCESS TO
COMPREHENSIVE QUALITY CARE IN
THE SAME WAY.
THOSE WITH PHYSICAL HEALTH.
HAVE ACCESS TO THIS BILL
STRENGTHENS OVERSIGHT OF LICENSE
AND CERTIFY TREATMENT PROGRAMS
BY REQUIRING THEM TO DISCLOSE
CERTAIN BUSINESS RELATIONSHIPS
INCLUDING THOSE WITH I'M LICENSE
OVER LIVING HOMES.
THIS BILL ALSO KINDS CURRENT LAW
TO IMPROVE TREATMENT SERVICES
AND PROVIDE THE DEPARTMENT MORE
OVERSIGHT AUTHORITY OVER RISEN
ACHIEVING FACILITIES AND WITH
THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK WHENEVER.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS HOLDING
MECHON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF ALCOHOL AND DRUG
PROGRAM EXECUTIVES WE ARE THE
STATEWIDE ASSOCIATION OF
COMMUNITY BASED.
NONPROFIT DRUG TREATMENT ALCOHOL
RECOVERY PROGRAMS IN ALL OF OUR
MEMBERS ARE LICENSED CERTIFIED
UNDER THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
AND IT SURE TO ALL OF THE RULES
AND REGULATIONS SET FORTH BY THE
THE STATE.
OF FIRST I'D LIKE TO THINK
SENATOR HERNANDEZ FOR BRINGING --
WHAT THE ISSUES THAT CAME FOR A
pTO TO THE COMMITTEE IN TERMS OF
A BILL ON AND WE LOOK AT THE THE
PROVISIONS IN THE BILL IS
SENATOR HERNANDEZ OUTLINED IT
WILL STRENGTHEN.
US DID OVERSIGHT FOR AS YOU DE
TREATMENT AND WILL HOPEFULLY
BEGIN TO ELIMINATE SOME OF THE
BAD ACTORS THAT HAVE --
I'VE BEEN --
OPERATING IN THE STATE.
A WE ALSO --
ASUPPORT THE BILL BECAUSE IT
WILL UPDATE DE REGULATIONS IN
STATE LAW.
AND BRING THOSE STATE LAWS AND
REGULATIONS INTO BEST PRACTICES
THAT ARE --
AYE IT'S CURRENTLY BEING --
USED IN THE FIELD SO WITH THAT
WE SUPPORT THE BILL AND ASK FOR
YOUR IPHONE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN WAS
TOM RENT FREE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA BE ABLE HEALTH
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION I'M JUST
GOING TO LINE MY COMMENTS WITH --
SENATOR HERNANDEZ ANDERSON --
MACHAR AND NOW WE SUPPORT THE
BILL FULLY THANK YOU.
IF YOU VERY MUCH OTHERS IN
SUPPORT.
ANYONE WITH THE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA LIFE AND HEALTH
INSURANCE COMPANIES WERE IN
STRONG SUPPORT IF YOU.
DEB BROUGHT DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA SPORT.
NICK WAY OF THE ACLU OF
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
SHERRI DAILY WITH CALIFORNIA
CONSORTIUM OF ADDICTION PROGRAMS
AND PROFESSIONALS IN SUPPORT.
THE UNDERCARD HARVEY CALIFORNIA
COUNCIL OF COMMUNITY BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH AGENCIES IN SUPPORT.
VERY MUCH DATING ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION
OF COUNTIES IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
ANYONE ELSE.
IS THERE ANYONE IN OPPOSITION.
SEE KNOWN TO BRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
[inaudible]
RIGHT.
SOME THANK YOU SENATOR FOR
BRINGING US FORWARD AND PORCIUS
IN A SHAME THAT WE HAVE TO DO
BILLS FOR ABOUT ACTORS.
IT JUST SO FRUSTRATING TO ME --
LET ME SUPPORTING YOUR BILL
TODAY I REALLY APPRECIATE THE
OVERSIGHT AND REPORTING.
YOU MAKE SURE YOU CAN KEEP TRACK
OF THOSE AND AGAIN THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR BRING IT FOR AND I
WILL.
MAKE THE MOTION [inaudible]
ANYONE ELSE.
YOU KNOW WE HAVE A MOTION.
AND A SECOND NOW WE HAVE MOTION
BY MISS AGUIAR-CURRY A SECOND BY --
MISS CARILLO --
MOTIONS TO PASS AS AMENDED
PROBES AS SENATOR WHICH LIKE TO
CLOSE.
S. WHENEVER WAS CHAIR.
VERY MUCH MEANT SECTOR PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL WOULD I WOULD I
MAYES.
ACKER CURRY TIGER CURRY I
BIGELOW.
BIGELOW AYE BONTA [inaudible]
BURKE.
BURKE I CARILLO.
CREEL AYE FLORA.
FLORA I WILL MODE.
LIMON AYE MCCARTY.
MCCARTY I NAZARIAN.
RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ AYE
[inaudible]
SANTIAGO [inaudible]
CURRENT [inaudible]
WALDRON.
AS NINE SO THAT BUT THOSE THAT
WE THROW LOOKING FOR OTHERS TO I
DON'T THINK A RESEARCHER AND
MEMBERS ARE I'LL DO SP FOURTEEN
TWENTY THREE THAT'S OKAY.
PLEASE --
THIS BILL IS A CLEAN UP HIS
SPEECH ON TWO TWO THREE THE
ATKINS BILL FROM LAST YEAR THAT
A LINE CALIFORNIA LAW WITH
FEDERAL REQUIREMENTS ON
INTERPRETER SERVICES.
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES REQUESTED SOME
REVISIONS TO THE LA RELATED TO
MEDI CAL AND THOSE ARE THE
CHANGES CONTAINED IN THIS BILL.
APARTMENT DESCRIBES THESE THIS
TECHNICAL IN CLARIFYING THE FOR
IMPLEMENTATION PURPOSES AND
ASKING ABOUT.
MISTER CHAIRMAN RISK KIMBERLY
CHEN ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA PAN
ETHNIC HELP MOVE FORWARD IN
SUPPORT OF THIS --
MEASURE A SEGMENT SPONSORED SP
TWO TO THREE WHICH CODIFIED MANY
PROVISIONS OF THE EFFORT WILL
CARE ACT'S --
IMPLEMENTING REGULATIONS --
SUBSEQUENTLY THERE WERE SOME
TECH GLARES AT DEPARTMENT I
NOTICED AFTER THE BILL WAS
SIGNED IN THIS BILL CORRECTS
THOSE YES VERY VOTE.
YOU VERY MUCH OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
MARY VALDEZ HEALTHAXIS
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
AGREEMENT.
IS THERE ANYONE IN OPPOSITION.
SEEN KNOWN BRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
THE SCENE HAS SEEN NO QUESTIONS
ARE -- WE
HAVE A MOTION BY MISTAKE AIR
CURRIE'S TAKEN BY MISTER
RODRIGUEZ --
THE WHICH I CLOSE CENTER
PROPHETESS WHENEVER I THINK YOU
VERY MUCH TO MOTIONS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS SPEND SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
WOULD I WOULD I MAYES.
AGUIAR-CURRY ACTOR CURRY I
BIGELOW.
BIGELOW NO BONTA [inaudible]
BURKE.
BURKE I CARILLO [inaudible]
FLORA.
FLORA NO LIMON.
LIMON AYE MCCARTY.
MCCARTY I NAZARIAN.
RODRIGUEZ.
RODRIGUEZ I SANTIAGO
[inaudible]
THURMAN [inaudible]
WALDRON.
AS SIX WE SUB MEMBERS MISSING SO
INEVITABLY THAT WILL COME BACK
THINGS CHAIR MEMBERS ARE ON CALL
FINISH OFF WITHOUT SP FOURTEEN
FIFTY SEVEN I'LL BE ACCEPTING
AND MEMBERS SUBSCRIBE AND
COMMENT FOR IN THE ANALYSIS.
ON THIS BILL IS NEEDED TO
CAPTURE COMPLETE INFORMATION
ABOUT THE CALIFORNIA MEDICARE
SUPPLEMENTAL INSURANCE
CONTRIBUTE TO THE ACCURACY OF
THE NATIONAL DATA AND PROMOTE
MORE PARTICIPATION BY DEPARTMENT
OF MANAGED HEALTHCARE.
AT THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
INSURANCE COMMISSIONERS TO
ENSURE COMPLIANCE WITH FEDERAL
REGULATIONS.
I NATIONAL --
MEDIGAP THAT IS RELIED UPON BY
THE MEDICARE PAYMENT ADVISORY
COMMISSION RESEARCHERS AND OTHER
FEDERALLY POLICY MAKERS WHO ARE
STUDYING.
AND MAKING RECOMMENDATIONS ABOUT
THE HEALTHCARE COSTS FROM PAIRS.
OF THOSE COSTS.
IT'S CRUCIAL THAT ALL CALIFORNIA
MEDICARE CARRIERS REPORT TO AN
E. I SEE.
THIS BILL WILL HELP FACILITATE
AND EXPRESSED THE INTENT OF THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE DEPARTMENT
PARTICIPATES IN THE NATIONAL
DISCUSSION AND WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK WHENEVER
[inaudible]
MUCH.
IF OTHERS IN SUPPORT ANYONE IT'S
PART OF HIS POINT.
AB ONE IN OPPOSITION.
SAY NO MORE BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS [inaudible]
SEEING NONE.
THE MOTION BY MISS A YEAR CURRY
A SECOND BY --
MR MCCARTY.
THAT'S RIGHT FOR FOR FOR HARRY.
I'M JUST WHAT IT.
WAS WHEN NO THE I WAS WHEN I WAS
WONDER IF YOU WANT TO DATE
EASIEST BILL LAST.
HER FIRST AND SELL IT ON THE
LIKELY STRATEGY TODAY.
I JUST WANT IN ORDER THE WE HAD
A VERY GOES IS ALL ABOUT THE
NUMBERS THANK YOU --
SO WE DO HAVE A MOTION --
BY THE SAY YOUR CURRY SECOND I
MISSED MCCARTY EMOTIONS DO PASS
AS AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS.
BUT AS I'VE A FEW DEMOS THINK
ALRIGHT MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL WAY I WOULD AYE
MAYES [inaudible]
AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY I BIGELOW.
BIGELOW AYE BONTA BURKE.
BURKE I CARILLO.
FLORA FLORA ISLA MOAN.
ABOUT AYE MCCARTY TYPE MCCARTY
I'M THIS AREA.
RODRIGUEZ.
RODRIGUEZ AYE SANTIAGO THURMOND
WALDRON [inaudible] EIGHT THAT'S
EIGHT ZERO IT SOUNDS IKE THEY
COOLEY THAT OPEN FOR OTHERS TO
ADD ON SO [inaudible]
SENATOR VAL.
SENATOR YOU HAVE TWO BILLS
BEFORE US ITEMS NUMBER FOUR SP.
NINE OH SIX FIFTY MIND STARTING
THEIR THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN --
THIS IS --
S. B. NINE NINE ZERO SIX SO PURE
PROVIDER CERTIFICATION --
THANK YOU --
MR CHAIRMAN --
THIS IS SOMETHING I THINK IS
LONG TIME COMING.
CALIFORNIA O. IS BEHIND THE
TIMES ACTUALLY AND IN THIS ISSUE
MORE THAN FORTY STATES ALREADY
HAVE.
THIS PROGRAM FORTY STATES ARE
AHEAD OF US SO --
THIS WORD --
REALLY TREMENDOUSLY EIGHT ARE
MALE HEALTH.
SYSTEM.
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT ACTUALLY
ENCOURAGES STATES TO ADOPT THE
CERTIFICATION PROGRAMS.
STANDARDIZED BEST PRACTICES.
BETTER YET MEDICAID
REIMBURSEMENT THE PERCENT OF THE
COST APPEAR SERVICES TO STATE
CERTIFICATION PROGRAM SO
ESTABLISHING.
A PROGRAM WOULD REDUCE THE
FINANCIAL BURDEN ON OUR COUNTY
PROVIDERS --
THE FEDERAL REGULATIONS WERE
RELEASED IN --
TWENTY LIKE. ELEVEN YEARS AGO.
WE HAD THE REGULATIONS ELEVEN
YEARS AGO.
AND IT'S BEEN A LONG TIME COMING.
WE HAVE NOT ACTED AND THE
RESEARCH IS CLEAR --
PEOPLE SUFFERING FROM MENTAL
ILLNESS OR SUBSTANCE ABUSE.
DISORDERS HAVE BETTER OUTCOMES
IF THEY CAN BOND WITH TRAINED
PEERS SUPPORTERS DURING
TREATMENT --
THIS IS WHAT THE BILL WILL DO.
AND WE HAVE WITNESSES ALTERNATE
MODE TORE WITNESSES.
ALL WE HAVE ARE.
MISTER CHAIRMAN.
OUR I WOULD LIKE --
TO MY CO AUTHOR WOULD LIKE TO
MAKE A PRESENTATION IF IT'S OKAY
LE CENTER HER --
FROM SAN DIEGO SENATOR ANDERSON
CENTER ACTUALLY MATERIAL DO YOU.
THANK YOU AB ARE MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS.
I AM PLEASED A JOINT AUTHORED SP
NINE OH SIX WITH MY GOOD
COLLEAGUE SENATOR BELT.
I I THINK THIS BILL BECAUSE I
BELIEVE THAT EXPANDING ACCESS TO
MENTAL HEALTH TREATMENT IS OF
VITAL --
RESOURCE TO CALIFORNIANS.
QUANTITATIVE INDEPENDENT
RESEARCH SUPPORTS THE IMPORTANCE
OF PEER SUPPORT SPECIALIST.
PEER SUPPORT A SERVICES HELP
PEOPLE NAVIGATE CARE REMOVE
BARRIERS TO RECOVERY.
STAYING GAUGE CAN RECOVERY IN
LIVE FULL LIVES.
I I KNOW YOU HAVE A LONG DAY
SOME A COVER REMARKS SHORT BUT
THANK YOU SO MUCH [inaudible]
VERY MUCH.
ADRIN SHELTON WITH THE STEINBERG
INSTITUTE I DECIDE WHERE THAT
PROUD OF SPONSORS OF THIS
MEASURE WHICH WOULD SET UP A
COMPREHENSIVE FRAMEWORK TO
CERTIFY.
AND TRAIN PEERS IN CALIFORNIA
IT'S TIME THAT WE ACTED OVER
FORTY STATES HAVE CERTIFICATION
PROGRAMS THAT EVIDENCE BASED
PRACTICE SO WE ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT TODAY THINK IF.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MEANINGLESS CA
TARA SALAMI TAMPLIN ON BEHALF OF
ALAMEDA COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
CARE SERVICES RHYME THE CONSUMER
EMPOWERMENT MANAGER.
AND THE MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
OVERSIGHT INCOME ABILITY
COMMISSION AROUND THE VICE CHAIR
WE ARE PROUD TO BE IN SUPPORT OF
THE SPELL.
HAS BEEN NINE US SIX I'M A
PERSON WHO HAS UTILIZED BUT PROP
PUBLIC AND PRIVATE MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES.
I STARTED RECEIVING PUBLIC
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES AS A
CHILD AFTER MY FAMILY ESCAPED
AFGHANISTAN WHEN I WAS.
THREE GROWING UP I STRUGGLED
WITH ISSUES SUCH AS ADHD
DEPRESSION ANXIETY PANIC ATTACKS
AND EXPERIENCE TRAUMA SUCH AS
LOSING A CHILD IN TWO THOUSAND
AND NINE ON THE MOST CRITICAL
SUPPORT I RECEIVED.
TODAY AND WHY I'M A PASSIONATE
ADVOCATE FOR PEER SUPPORT
SERVICES ONE I WAS SUICIDAL AND
STRUGGLING WITH MY HOPE
CHALLENGES.
PEER SUPPORT HELPED ME THROUGH
THE PAIN I WAS IN AND SAVE MY
LIFE I DO NOT FEEL ALONE AND
STARTED.
SLOWLY REGAINING HOPE AGAIN AS
THE COUNTIES CONSUMER
EMPOWERMENT MANAGER I HAVE THE
PRIVILEGE TO WORK WITH
INDIVIDUALS RECEIVING PUBLIC
MAHAL SERVICES FROM AROUND THE
STATE.
IN BOTH MY ROLE AT THE COUNTY
AND ALSO MY ROLE AS A
COMMISSIONER.
IN PARTICULAR WHAT --
I WORK WITH A GROUP CALLED THE
METAL FULL OF CONSUMER CHAMPIONS
WE HAVE OVER A THOUSAND FIVE
HUNDRED INDIVIDUALS IN OUR
COUNTY THAT ARE CONSUMERS OF OUR
SERVICES.
INACTIVE AND PEER SUPPORT AND
ADVOCACY I SEE ON A DAY TO DAY
BASIS HOW PEER SUPPORT HOPES IN
MY WORK -- I
SEE HOW IT HELPS THAT SERVE THE
PEOPLE HARDEST TO REACH PEOPLE
IN CRISIS FROM UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES THAT WON'T TRUST
ANYBODY ELSE EXCEPT PEOPLE WHO
HAVE BEEN THROUGH THE SAME THING.
AS A HIRING MANAGER OF PEERS I
WANNA KNOW THAT THE PEERS I HIRE
ARE TRAINED AND HAVE ACCESS TO
THESE TRAININGS AND KNOW THE
SKILLS --
AND THIS IS QUALITY ASSURANCE S.
B. NINE ó SIX WILL HELP CREATE
THAT COMMON UNDERSTANDING
AMONGST COUNTIES AND PURE
SUPPORTERS ON WHAT THE ROLE IS --
AND ALSO A PROFESSIONAL ICE PEER
SUPPORT SERVICES INCREASE
STANDARDS OF CARE IN WHICH PEER
SUPPORTERS WILL GET TO EXCEL IN
THE WORK THEY DO.
IT WILL HELP VALIDATE THE WORK
OF PEER SUPPORT AND WORK THAT
MANY LIKE ME WILL TELL YOU IS
SAVED OUR LIVES --
PLEASE SUPPORT THE BILL THANK
YOU.
YOU VERY MUCH.
OTHER SUPPORT TOUCHES YOUR NAME
IN ORG IS PLEASE.
MY NAME IS RACHEL FOR ON THE
CONSUMER AFFAIRS LIAISON I'M A
PERSON WITH MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES
I ATTEMPTED SUICIDE FOUR TIMES
AND APPEAR PROVIDER SAVED MY
LIFE.
AND BROUGHT ME TO TWENTY THREE
YEARS OF WORKING IN THE MENTAL
HEALTH FIELD PEER PROVIDERS SAVE
LIVES AS GUITARIST SAID AND WE
NEED MORE PURE PROVIDERS IN THE
FIELD I SUPPORT THE BILL THANK
YOU.
JUST NAME AND ORGANIZATION
PLEASE.
JERRY HERE A SOLANO COUNTY
WALLACE RECOVERY UNIT SUPPORT
BILL.
PULLING MESURE BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
ALCOHOL DRUG PROGRAM EXECUTIVES
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
WE HONOR CLICK HARVEY AND HAVE
THE CALIFORNIA.
COAST AND COMMUNITY BIGGER HOPE
AGENCIES IN SUPPORT.
DANIEL ALL A CALIFORNIA A CHILD
AND FAMILY SERVICES IN SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON AREA THEY'RE THE
COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
CAPS SALAS ADMIN EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
ORGANIZATIONS WE SUPPORT BECAUSE
IT WILL PROFESSIONAL LIVES
VALIDATE.
AND STANDARDIZE.
OF SERVICE THAT IS HAPPENING
OVER THE STATE RIGHT NOW THANK
YOU.
NAME AND ORGANIZATION.
I'M GORDON RE PLC SEE POLITICAL
SO MUCH HAPPENED CHAIRPERSON AND
I SUPPORT BO.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M VIRGINIA HALL
ALAMEDA COUNTY BEHAVIOR
HEALTHCARE SERVICES POLITICAL
SUMMER CHAMPIONS I'M JUST A
RECENT PAST GRADUATE.
WELCOME UP I'M A PEER SUPPORT
SPECIALIST.
THANK YOU I SUPPORT THE BILL
[inaudible]
ROCK [inaudible]
P. OCC.
MY NAME IS JAMES GRADUATE OF A
PEER SUPPORT TRAINING AND I
SUPPORT THE BILL. TWENTY EIGHT
ZERO PEER SUPPORT SPECIALIST
ALSO RECENT GRADUATE FROM THE
PROGRAM IF YOU TO PASS THIS BILL
WOULD BE.
WOULD MEAN A LOT TO ME THANK YOU.
ERNEST HARMON THAT THIRD MENTAL
HEALTH BOARD OF DIRECTORS --
DISTRICT.
FIVE A I SUPPORT.
CURTIS THREE JUNIA POOL OF
CONSUMER CHAMPIONS [inaudible]
I SUPPORT.
ANGELIQUE DARK NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS IN
SUPPORT.
JUST FOR OPEN SEND WITH EACH MY
MATTERS IN SUPPORT.
MENTALLY THE CALIFORNIA
PSYCHOLOGICALASSOCIATION
SUPPORT.
DR JORGE ONE WITH RICHMOND AREA
MULTISERVICE INTIMACIES CHO WE
HAVE A TRAINING PROGRAM WE
GRADUALLY SIXTEEN COHORTS TO
DATE.
LIKELY A SEAL YOUR CALIFORNIA
AND SUPPORT.
CONNIE DELGADO WITH A CALIFORNIA
HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
HERMIT DATING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES IN SUPPORT.
KELLY BUCKS ON BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
HEALTHCARE DISTRICTS THE COUNTY
WELFARE DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION
AND THE BUT TRY COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS HERE IN SUPPORT.
KIANA CITY ON BEHALF OF THE
ALAMEDA COUNTY PART OF
SUPERVISORS AND SUPPORT THE
MICHELLE KEPT IT UP WITH A CA
YOU CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
LEXIE HOWARD ON BEHALF OF THE
JUVENILE COURT JUDGES OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
HER CHILD DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIAN VERY STRONG SUPPORT.
HI KAY UNCHAIN NAM OF
CALIFORNIANS.
LINDA WAY WITH WESTERN CENTER ON
LAW AND POVERTY IN SUPPORT.
JAN ASKED ALLEN TOLD US DEFENSE
FUND CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
TIM AND REPRESENT THE CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER THE RECORD BECAUSE
EMERGENCY PHYSICIANS IN SPORT
[inaudible]
ANYONE ELSE.
IS THERE ANYONE IN OPPOSITION.
SEE NO WILL BRING BACK COMMITTEE
FOR QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
LEGISLATURE WHICH OUGHT TO CLOSE.
MERGER SUPPORT FOR THIS.
YOU VERY MUCH AND THINK IT THANK
YOU FOR BRINGING THIS BILL
FORWARD AND THANK YOU TO ALL THE
WITNESSES WHO CAME.
SUSPECT FROM LONG DISTANCES TO
BE HERE TODAY TO SUPPORT YOU --
WE DO HAVE A MOTION --
BOTH SENATORS THANK YOU --
QUESTION BY MISTAKE YEAR CURRY A
SECOND BY MISTER FLORA THE
MOTIONS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS --
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL WOULD I WOULD I MAYES.
HAVE YOUR COURAGE.
NEGER CURRY I THINK A LOT.
BIGELOW AYE.
BONTA [inaudible]
BURKE.
BURKE I CARILLO.
CARILLO AYE FLORA.
FLORA AYE LIMOS [inaudible]
MCCARTY.
IN THIS AREA.
RODRIGUEZ.
RODRIGUEZ I SANTIAGO.
BERMAN [inaudible]
WALDRON. SEVEN VOTES WE NEED ONE
WHERE WE HAVE SOME MISSING
MEMBERS IT'S IT'S ONE OF THOSE
DAYS SENATOR YEAH.
WE'RE DOING THE SAME THING
ACROSS THE HALL.
YOUR NAME IS IDEAL ITEM NUMBER
TEN S. B..
TEN NINETEEN I THINK THIS DAY
HAS THE MOST COMMITTEE MEETINGS
AND THE ASSEMBLY HOUSE AT OF ALL
THE ALL ALL YEAR.
IT UNDERSERVED FEELS LIKE IT.
DOES NOT.
WE'RE JUST ALL WORKING HARD --
MISTER CHAIR --
AND HAPPY TO PRESENT MY NEXT
BILL THIS IS --
SP -- TEN
NINETEEN THANK YOU --
MISTER MISTER CHAIRMAN --
THIS IS BEEN A LONG JOURNEY --
OF FOR ME FOR ABOUT FIVE YEARS
OF TRYING TO GET [inaudible]
SCHOOLS.
AND THE MENTAL HEALTH SYSTEM
[inaudible]
TOGETHER.
LOT OF WORK --
THE CHAIRMAN BASED ON OUR
DISCUSSION --
I INTEND TO I WANTED TO TO
ANNOUNCE TODAY THAT I'M TENDING
TO MEND THIS BILL.
IN THE SENATE IN THE HEALTH
COMMITTEE --
AFTER THE HEALTH COMMITTEE BILL
MEETING [inaudible] TO DESIGNATE
THE MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
OVERSIGHT AND ACCOUNTABILITY
COMMISSION AS THE GRANT
ADMINISTRATOR. FOR THE SCHOOL
NOW HELPS PARTNERSHIPS.
OF IT INSTEAD OF WHAT'S IN
CURRENTLY IN THE BILL THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION.
SOMEONE URBAN REALIZE THAT SO
WEIRD.
MAKING A CHANGE IN WHO
ADMINISTERS [inaudible]
MORE APPROPRIATE --
THE DEPARTMENT EDUCATION HOWEVER.
WILL CONTINUE TO PROVIDE
GUIDANCE AND INPUT. TO THE
COMMISSION [inaudible]
AND THIS BILL S. B. --
TEN TEN NINETEEN CRATES PARITY
IN THE ALLOCATION OF PROP.
SIX THREE CRISIS INTERVENTION
FUNDS.
THESE ARE COMMONLY REFERRED TO
AS TRIAGE FUNDS --
IT BOOSTERS THE MENTAL HEALTH.
CARE PARTNERSHIPS BETWEEN
SCHOOLS AND REGIONAL MENTAL
HEALTH AGENCIES.
HISTORICALLY THE BILL ALLOWS --
ALLOCATES RELEASED HAVE TO
TRIAGE GRANT FUNDS FOR SERVICES
TARGETED TO YOUTH IN CRATES
PARTNERSHIPS BETWEEN SCHOOLS.
AND LOCAL MENTAL HEALTH
PROVIDERS OPERATING IN THE
COUNTY NETWORK.
CURRENTLY THE CRISIS MENTAL
HEALTH FUNDING FOR USE CENTRIC.
PROGRAMS RECEIVED ONLY 15% OF
THE GRANTS PREVIOUSLY WROTE
AWARDED WITH THE REMAINING 85%
ALLOCATED TO ADULTS --
THIS --
WOULD CHANGE IT A PRIORITY
[inaudible]
S. RECOMMENDED.
BY THE MIL HEALTH SERVICES
OVERSIGHT AND ACCOUNTABILITY
COMMISSION --
THE PARTNERSHIPS BETWEEN SCHOOLS
AND COMMUNITY MENTAL HEALTH
[inaudible]
PROFESSIONALS.
OFFER STUDENTS AND FAMILIES AND
EXTENDED NETWORK OF MENTAL
HEALTH PROGRAMS AND SERVICES
THAT ARE LEASES IS EASILY
ACCESSIBLE --
THIS INSURANCE COLLABORATION
WITH BOTH THE MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES OVERSIGHT AND
ACCOUNTABILITY COMMISSION AND
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION.
OF THE BILL IS SUPPORTED AND
SPONSORED --
BY -- THE
MALE HEALTH SERVICES AND
OVERSIGHT ACCOUNTABILITY
COMMISSION --
WHICH THE THIS THE LEGISLATIVE
REPRESENTATIVES ARE MYSELF AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CARRILLO --
WE ALSO ENJOY THE SPORT OF
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION
WERE TURNED OVER TO WITNESSES
WITH OF OUR EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR.
TOBY YELLING TOBY ATTORNEY OR
YOU AND THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS MY NAME IS TOBY
DOING ON THE EXECUTOR AFTER THE
HOUSE SERVICES OVERSIGHT AND
ACCOUNTABILITY COMMISSION.
HAVE WHERE HERE IN SUPPORT AND
WE ARE THE SPONSOR OF S. B. TEN
NINETEEN WOULD LIKE TO THANK
SENATOR BELL HAS BEEN WORKING AS
YOU MENTION FOR SEVERAL YEARS TO
TRY TO STRENGTHEN THE SCHOOL
COMMUNITY PARTNERSHIPS.
IN TERMS OF ENSURING THAT
CHILDREN CALIFORNIA HAVE ACCESS
TO THE CARE THEY NEED.
IN WAYS THAT ARE APPROPRIATE FOR
CHILDREN AS AS MANY OF YOU KNOW
CHILDREN SPEND MUCH OF THEIR
TIME IN SCHOOLS AND THAT'S WHERE
THEIR MENTAL HEALTH NEEDS OFTEN
COME TO THE ATTENTION OF CARE
GIVERS AND THE PEOPLE.
THAT ARE IMPORTANT IN THEIR
LIVES THIS BILL WOULD WOULD
FOSTER THE STRONGER SCHOOL
COMMUNITY MENTAL HEALTH
PARTNERSHIPS THAT CAN HELP
STUDENTS SUCCEED BOTH
EDUCATIONALLY AND AS WELL IN
TERMS OF THEIR MENTAL HEALTH.
THE COMMISSION SUPPORTS THIS
BILL BECAUSE WE SEE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO STRENGTHEN ACCESS
TO CARE FOR CHILDREN BECAUSE WE
SEE THE NEED TO IMPROVE THE
SCHOOL COMMUNITY PARTNERSHIPS.
AND BECAUSE WE SEE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO USE MY HOUSE
SERVICES THAT FUNDS TO
INCENTIVIZE THESE PARTNERSHIPS
IN WAYS THAT THEY CAN BE IN
DURING FOR THE CHILDREN THAT ARE
SO IMPORTANT IN CALIFORNIA.
HAM WE'VE BEEN WORKING WITH THE
SENATOR ON WE'VE WE APPRECIATE
HIS WILLINGNESS TO ENGAGE THE
BROAD STAKEHOLDERS AROUND MAKING
THIS BILL WORK.
AND WE'RE VERY MUCH IN SUPPORT
OF THIS AND BE HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT HAVE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
LINDA WAY WITH WESTERN CENTER ON
LAW AND POVERTY PLEASED TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL A LISTENER
RECENT AUDITOR'S REPORT FOUND
THAT. SEVEN HUNDRED THOUSAND
STUDENTS HAVE A SERIOUS
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH CONDITION BUT
ONLY A FRACTION ABOUT 20% OF
THOSE RECEVE THERAPY OR
COUNSELING AS PART OF THEIR
INDIVIDUALIZED EDUCATION PROGRAM.
A LACK OF COORDINATED INTEGRATED
APPROACHES BY COUNTIES AND
SCHOOLS TO ADDRESS SCHOOL MENTAL
HEALTH AND SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDERS PARTICULARLY FOR THOSE
MOST DEEPLY IMPACTED BY
CHILDHOOD ADVERSITY CONTRIBUTES
TO STUDENT.
MENTAL HEALTH NEEDS NOT BEING
THAT WE SUPPORT THIS BILL AS A
WAY TO INCREASE ACCESS TO NEEDED
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES AND WE
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR'S
INTENTION.
BUT INTENDED AMENDMENTS TO HAVE
THE COMMISSION ADMINISTER THE
FUNDS AS WE BELIEVE THAT ALLOWS
FOR ACCOUNTABILITY AND OVERSIGHT
APPROPRIATE OVERSIGHT THINKING --
OTHERS TO SUPPORT JUST YOUR NAME
AND ORGANIZATION.
HELEN ROTH THOUSAND TEACHERS FOR
HEALTHY KIDS WE NEED TO GET THIS
RIGHT THANK YOU.
AND ANOTHER ON WHAT THE WHITE I
MEAN GROUP REPRESENTING NEXT IN
CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT.
JANICE CANAL ON CHILDREN'S
DEFENSE FUND IN SUPPORT.
ROBERT HARRIS WITH CALIFORNIA
SOCIETY OF ADDICTION MEDICINE
IT'S FINALLY TIME TO INTEGRATE
THE SERVICE'S THANK YOU.
MAYBE ONE REPRESENTING AMERICAN
ACADEMY OF PEDIATRICS AS WELL AS
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL NURSES BOTH IN
SUPPORT.
KELLY BOX ON BEHALF OF THE
COUNTY WELFARE DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION HERE IN SUPPORT.
AFFIRMATIVE TING ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATE
OF ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES WE
ARE UPENDING POSITION WITH THE
WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR IN THE
RECENT AMENDMENTS ARE REMOVED A
GREAT MOVE IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION --
AND WE DO BELIEVE THAT
PARTNERSHIPS BETWEEN COUNTIES
AND SCHOOLS WILL HELP CHILDREN
SO WE'RE LOOKING FOR TO WORKING
WITH CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
SENATOR PELL.
AND WE APPRECIATE HIS COMMITMENT
TO CHILDREN'S MENTAL HEALTH
[inaudible]
ANYONE ELSE.
SO ANYONE IN OPPOSITION.
INCOME UP TO THE TABLE HERE.
YOU COMMITTED TABLE COULD WISH.
UP NOT OPPOSITION OWE YOU KNOW
I'M SORRY SORRY WE WERE LATE
COMING UP BECAUSE WE WERE IN
OPPOSITION OKAY BUT WITH THE
SENATORS SUGGESTED AMENDMENTS
AROUND ADMINISTRATION.
BOB WE WILL SUPPORT THE BILL.
CRISTO NUMBER IT'S FROM LINCOLN.
CERTAINLY UNDER CLICK HARVEY
FROM THE CALIFORNIA COUNCIL
COMMUNITY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
AGENCIES I WE'VE BEEN WORKING
WITH THE SENATOR SINCE APRIL
WITH FAT AMENDMENTS AND BASED ON
WHAT'S COMMITTED TODAY IN
HEARING WE WOULD BE ABLE TO MOVE
TO SUPPORT.
IF WE ARE ABLE TO TAKE THOSE AND
IF WE DO HAVE THOSE AMENDMENTS
ON AND HEALTH COMMITTEE OR IN
EDUCATION COMMITTEE.
DANIEL MAILLET CALIFORNIA LINES
JOHN FAMILY SERVICES ALSO IN THE
SAME POSITION AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH SENATOR --
ON THESE CHANGES AND WILL MOVE
TO A SUPERPOSITION ONCE THE
MANAGER TAKEN.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH IS
THERE ANYONE ELSE.
MOVE THE BILL. TO MOTIONS SECOND
HAVE IS THERE --
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
THE COMMITTEE.
I HAVE A COMMENT ON HIS.
SENATE BILL THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR BRINGING US FOREIGN --
OF MIL HEALTH CRISIS ARE SO
EVIDENT TO SCHOOL CAMPUSES.
AND I SPENT TIME WHEN I WAS THE
MAYOR YEARS AGO AND USED TO READ
TO KINDERGARTNERS.
AND YOU CAN PICK OUT ISSUES
FAMILY ISSUES AND I ALWAYS
THOUGHT TO MYSELF WOULDN'T BE
NICE IF WE PARTNERED WITH THE
SCHOOLS MORE.
AND I THINK IT'S SUCH AN
IMPORTANT PLACE THAT FAMILIES
COME TOGETHER YOU SEE THEM.
AND YOU --
APPRECIATE THE FACT OF WHAT MAY
BE A CHILD'S GOING THROUGH SO I
REALLY APPRECIATE THIS COMING
FISCAL [inaudible]
THIS WALDRON.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR ARM.
YOU KNOW WAS WE SEE AND SEVERAL
OF THESE BILLS ON OUR
DISCUSSIONS THAT IT'S THE YOUNG
PEOPLE IN THAT VERY YOU KNOW
TUMULTUOUS AGENT TEENAGE AND ON
TO YOU KNOW YOUNG.
YOU USED THAT THEIR OF THE MOST
VULNERABLE TO HAVING MENTAL
HEALTH YOU KNOW ISSUES RISE HOME
FROM TRAUMAS IN THEIR THEIR LIFE
IS YOUNG PEOPLE THE CO OCCURRING
DISORDERS WITH SUBSTANCE USE.
ALSO ABUSE --
ALL OF THOSE THINGS KIND OF
WINTER TOWING AND IT'S ALMOST
LIKE THE MENTAL HEALTH WHO'S
BEEN KIND OF LEFT OUT IT'S
ALWAYS THE SEPARATE THING FROM
HEALTH AND IT REALLY IS HEALTH
AND THE TO BE.
INCLUDED.
SO YOU KNOW IT'S I THINK IT'S A
GOOD THING THAT WE'RE WORKING ON
DOING MORE OF THIS.
YOU VERY MUCH ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
I JUST LIKE TO SAY THANK YOU FOR
COMING BY THIS MORNING AND THINK
AND TALKING WITH ME AND AS WE
WORK THROUGH SOME OF THE SOME OF
THE INTRICACIES OF THIS
PARTICULAR BILL I APPRECIATE
THAT.
I WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE AND YEAH I
HAVE -- A
NIECE THAT WAS SO.
A ARM VICTIM OF HER MOTHER WAS A
VICTIM OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE.
AND MY MOTHER WHO'S GOT A
MASTER'S DEGREE IN EDUCATION --
SHOWED ME HER HOMEWORK.
THAT SHE DID --
THREE MONTHS BEFORE THE THE
TREMONT TRAUMA THAT OCCURRED.
SHOW ME THE HOMEWORK SHE DID
AFTER.
AND ONE WAS AN A MINUS AND ONE
WAS A DOOZY.
BECAUSE THE ONE THAT WAS THE D.
SHE WASN'T ABLE.
TO CLERK THOUGHTS TOGETHER AND
WRITE [inaudible]
IN A CLEAR MANNER.
AND WE HAD MY NASCENT THERAPY.
AND SHE RECOVERED SHE IS DOING
WELL [inaudible]
AND THOSE OF THE KINDS OF THINGS
WE NEED IN THE SCHOOL WE NEED
GOOD TEACHERS CONFINED.
THEY CAN LOOK AT THE HALLMARK OF
THE STUDENTS AND THEY CAN TELL.
IF THERE'S A PROBLEM
[inaudible]
JUST YOU KNOW IF YOU'RE A GOOD
TEACHER.
SO WE NEED THE TEACHERS AND THE
MENTAL HEALTH PEOPLE TO WORK AND
WORK TOGETHER.
AND THAT'S WHY A RICH AND I VOTE
ON THIS BECAUSE I THINK IT WOULD
CREATE A CREASED.
NOW I THE BETTER BETTERMENT OF
MENTAL HEALTH THAT WOULD
INCREASE THE ACADEMIC
PERFORMANCE.
THIS A SERVANT A NEW AREA FOR A
LOT OF US.
AND THAT'S WHY WHICH HARD TO GET
THE TWO SIDES TO WORK TOGETHER.
BUT I THINK THERE A COMMON GOAL
THAT WE HAVE.
THAT WE CAN ALL WORK FORESIGHT
YOU'RE NOT BONUS.
YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR.
WE HAVE A MOTION --
BY MISS CARILLO A SECOND BY MISS.
AT YOUR CURRENT EMOTIONS DO
PASSED TO EDUCATION --
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL WHAT I'VE TO WORTH AYE
MAYES [inaudible]
AGAR HURRY.
I AGREE I BIGELOW [inaudible]
BONTA [inaudible]
BURKE.
BURKE I CARILLO.
CARILLO AYE FLORA.
FLORA I LOOK.
LIMON AYE MCCARTY MCCARTY AYE
NAZARIAN.
RODRIGUEZ.
SANTIAGO THURMAN WALDRON WALDRON
AYE.
THAT THOSE EIGHT VOTES IT'S OUR
BELIEF THAT --
THE ROLE OF THE BROTHERS THAT ON
TAKE VERY MUCH SENATOR
[inaudible]
SKINNER LARA
.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
THERE'S BEGIN WITH A MADE SEVEN
FOR PERFECT THANK YOU THANK YOU
MEMBERS AS YOU KNOW WE CONTINUE
TO WORK ON MY BILL DECREASE IN
THE NUMBER OF AND UNDOCUMENTED
FOLKS THAT I LACK ACCESS TO CARE.
THE ASSEMBLY WERE WORKING WHILE
I'M COVERING IN ADULTS IN THE
SENATE WERE WORKING TO COVER
ELDERS.
THIS IS THE OLDEST PIECE OF THE
BILL AND WE CONTINUE.
RESPECT THE S. RIVAL
[inaudible]
BUT JUSTICE.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS CHRISTOPHER GAGLIANO
FROM CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT POLICY
CENTER ON PRACTICAL SPONSORED S.
B. -- NINE
SEVEN FOUR WHILE.
AT IT AGING A DOCUMENT
CALIFORNIA'S HAVE LIVED IN THE
STATE FOR DECADES OTHER WORKING
PARENTS GRANDPARENTS ARE
CAREGIVERS NEIGHBORS AND LOVED
ONES.
AYE WHILE THEY HAVE WORKED FOR
DECADES OTHER IMMIGRATION STATUS
BARS THEM FROM RETIREMENT OF
FORCE AT AND SAFETY NET PROGRAMS
AND MANY IF NOT ALL WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK PAST THE AGE OF
RETIREMENT TO SUPPORT THEIR
FAMILIES AND LOVED ONES.
I CALIFORNIA'S A SECOND HIGHEST
SUPPLEMENTAL POVERTY RATE FOR
ADULTS OVER THE AGE OF SIXTY
FIVE IN THE NATION.
OFFERING DOCUMENT IT ALL THERE'S
A SYSTEMIC EXCLUSIONS TO HEALTH
CARE FURTHER EXACERBATE THE
DETRIMENTAL IMPACTS OF POVERTY
ON THERE WILL BE --
IN ADDITION UNRELENTING FEDERAL
ATTACKS ON IMMIGRANTS AND THEIR
FAMILIES CONTINUE TO PLACE
COMMUNITIES UNDER INCREDIBLE --
GIRAFFES AND EVEN TOXIC STRESS
ARE THIS TRAUMA DISRUPTS THEIR
PHYSICAL AND MENTAL WELL BEING
AND EXACERBATES THEIR NEED FOR
CARE.
OFFER FAMILY TO TAKE CARE OF
UNDOCUMENTED AGING RELATIVES
EXCLUSIONS FROM HEALTH CARE CAN
RESULT IN EASILY TREATABLE
CONDITIONS BECOMING.
LIFE THREATENING AND ENTIRE
FAMILIES FACING AN INCREASED
RISK OF MEDICAL DEBT THAT
DISRUPTS THE FINANCIAL WELL
BEING OF OUR HOUSEHOLD I TAKE
FOR EXAMPLE --
IDEA SINGLE MOTHER THAT ALSO
CARES FOR AGING FATHER WHO
RECENTLY HAD AN EMERGENCY HEART
SURGERY YET CONTINUES TO BE
WITHOUT VITAL ROUTINE FOLLOW UP
CARE BECAUSE OF HIS IMMIGRATION
STATUS.
AYE WHETHER IT'S OUR OWN HEALTH
A LESS MEDICINE --
THE UNEXPECTED OUT OF POCKET
COSTS THAT RESULT FROM BEING
LOCKED OUT OF HEALTH CARE PUSH
FAMILIES LIKE HERS INTO DEEPER
POVERTY --
OR TAKE FOR EXAMPLE KAREN I
DOCTOR RECIPIENT WHOSE AGING
FATHER PUTS DOWN ROOTS IN THIS
WHO PUT DOWN ROOTS IN THE STATE
FOR DECADES DECADES AGO.
AND WORKS DAY IN AND DAY OUT OP
BUT WHOSE HEALTH SUFFER SOME
TYPE TWO DIABETES HYPERTENSION
AND JOINT PAIN PAIN.
ARE CHRONIC CONDITIONS THAT
REQUIRE ROUTINE FOLLOW UP
IMPROPER TREATMENT A THESE ARE
SOME OF THE STORIES OF THE BRAVE
CALIFORNIANS WHO WILL NOT STOP
FIGHTING TO ENSURE THEIR LOVED
ONES HAVE ACCESS. TO
COMPREHENSIVE AND LIFESAVING
CARE I EVEN BEFORE THEMSELVES A
CALIFORNIA NEEDS AN EQUITABLE
HEALTHCARE SYSTEM THAT WORKS FOR
OUR MIX STATUS STATE.
I IMMIGRATION HASN'T STATUS IS
NOT TO FIND THE CREDIBLE SOCIAL
ECONOMIC AND CULTURAL
CONTRIBUTIONS THAT ARE
COMMUNITIES HAVE MADE IN
CALIFORNIA.
YET OUR POLICIES CONTINUE TO
REAL THAT AS A BARRIER TO
CRITICAL HEALTH CARE AND
ASSISTANCE.
ARE ARE DOCUMENTED ELDERS AND
THEIR FAMILIES CAN NO LONGER
WAIT FOR THESE REASONS WE ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU
[inaudible]
DEFINITELY.
CAMPERS THANK YOU OUT NEAR ABOUT
AS OF HEALTH ACCESS CALIFORNIA
WHERE CO SPONSORS OF S. B..
NINE SEVEN FOUR THINGS TO THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE AFFORDABLE
CARE ACT CALIFORNIA'S UNINSURED
RATE IS AT A HISTORIC LOW OF SIX
POINT 8%.
THE ACA BROUGHT HEALTH COVERAGE
TO AN ADDITIONAL SEVEN MILLION
CALIFORNIANS UNFORTUNATELY
FEDERAL LAW EXPLICITLY AND
UNJUSTLY EXCLUDES UNDOCUMENTED
INDIVIDUALS.
INCLUDING ELDERS OVER THE AGE OF
SIXTY FIVE WHO WOULD OTHERWISE
BE ELIGIBLE BUT FOR THEIR
IMMIGRATION STATUS FOR RECEIVING
HEALTH COVERAGE TO OUR STATE
MEDI CAL PROGRAM.
IN TWO THOUSAND TEN THAT THE
SOCIAL SECURITY ADMINISTRATION
ESTIMATED THAT NATION WIDE
UNDOCUMENTED WORKERS AND THEIR
EMPLOYEES CONTRIBUTED TEN TWELVE
I SHOULD SAY BILLION.
DOLLARS TO SOCIAL SECURITY AGING
UNDOCUMENTED CALIFORNIANS WHO'VE
LIVED IN OUR STATE FOR DECADES
AND RAISING FAMILIES PAYING
BILLIONS AND LOCAL AND STATE
TAXES AS WELL AS MEDICARE AND
SOCIAL.
SECURITY DO NOT SHARE IN TO
PUBLIC BENEFIT PROGRAMS THEY
WOULD OTHERWISE BE ELIGIBLE FOR
BUT FOR THEIR IMMIGRATION STATUS.
I'VE BEEN NINE SEVEN FOR
INSURERS ARE AGING UNDOCUMENTED
CALIFORNIANS HAVE ACCESS TO
HEALTH CARE AFTER A LIFETIME OF
ECONOMIC CONTRIBUTIONS TO OUR
STATE.
AND IT ALSO CONTINUES OUR
STATE'S PROGRESS TOWARDS
UNIVERSAL COVERAGE EVERY
CALIFORNIAN BENEFITS WHEN
EVERYONE IS COVERED AND FOR
THESE REASONS WE RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR A AYE VOTE.
BEST PAL FOR HEALTHAXIS
CALIFORNIA I WOULD ONLY ADD THAT
EVERYONE OVER SIXTY FIVE ARE TO
HAVE HEALTH INSURANCE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
YOU VERY MUCH OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
DOES THE SUPPORT.
LINDA WAY WITH WESTERN CENTER ON
LAW AND POVERTY IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
CAN REALLY TELL THE CALIFORNIA
PAN ETHNIC HEALTH THAT WORK IN
SUPPORT.
MICHELLE CAPITA WITH SEIU
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT IF YOU.
BUT SOME DAVIS CALIFORNIA BY
HEALTH THAT WORK IN SUPPORT.
MARY THERE WITH THE CAN BE A
REAL HELP DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION
INITIALLY DIRECT NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS IN
SUPPORT.
SARAH FLOCKS CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION IN SUPPORT.
YOU WANT COULD THE INNOCENT TO
HELP SHEILA AND WE'RE STRONG
SUPPORT.
AND YOU MEDINA ASIAN AMERICANS
ADVANCING JUSTICE CALIFORNIA
CHUNK SUPPORT.
AB GOT MONO WHERE PEOPLE
CALIFORNIANS STRONG SUPPORT.
I HAD OTHER I'M REPRESENTING
NEXT IN CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT.
WEST SAM'S ON BEHALF OF UNITED
WAYS OF CALIFORNIA AND THE
CALIFORNIA CHILDREN'S HEALTH
COALITION IN SUPPORT --
MICHAEL RAN AGAIN ON BEHALF OF
THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS SANTA
CLARA COUNTY IN SPORT THANK YOU.
KELLY BROKE SOME BEHALF OF THAT
COUNTY HEALTH EXECUTIVES
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA AND
THE COUNTY WELFARE DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION HERE IN SUPPORT.
NICK LEON BADLY SO YOUR
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
LARA PARHAM BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF FAMILY
PHYSICIANS IN SUPPORT.
ERIC HARRIS ON THE HAVE THE
MARCH OF DIMES IN SUPPORT.
JANICE COUNTENANCE DEFENSE AND
CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT.
JENNIFER ALEX CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION HEALTH PLANS IN
SUPPORT.
CUT THE MUSTARD LOOK HEALTH
PLANS AND SUPPORTS.
VIDEO PORN AMERICAN KENNY
PEDIATRICS CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
NURSES AND SUPPORT.
MILLION AS LATINO COALITION FOR
HEALTHY CALIFORNIA WE EXPORT
THINK YOU PICK YOUR GEN HAMAS ON
BEHALF OF PUBLIC HEALTH
ADVOCATES IN SUPPORT.
TIM MADDEN REPS IN CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER THE AMERICAN COLLEGE OF
EMERGENCY PHYSICIANS IN SUPPORT.
THANK CONSUMERS ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA HEALTH PLUS ADVOCATES
IN SUPPORT.
HER CHILD DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
OKAY TO HAVE TO RUN.
SADAKO THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION SUPPORT.
DO YOU ANNOUNCE.
THERE ANYONE IN OPPOSITION.
THE SCENE NO ONE WILL BRING BACK
MEASUREMENT OF SOME SORT.
GET UP TO A ANYONE IN ANY
COMMENTS QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
BUT YOU WERE JUST A LITTLE BIT
LATE ON THAT MISTER.
MISS AGUILAR CURRY MOVE THE BILL.
AND MISS LIMON SECONDED.
HOW HOME SORRY [inaudible]
CHAU.
AND WE HAVE AN ERROR HERE WILL
FIX THAT.
THINGS CARILLO WELL YEAH YOU
EVEN DO IT ALL DAY SO MISS KOREA
MOVE THE BILL AND THEN
[inaudible]
THE SECOND.
MS BURKE IT'S Y. HOW WOULD RATE.
YEAH.
MR MCCARTY JIM QUESTION YEAH FOR
YOU ONE OF THOSE YOU ONE OF THE
BILL.
BUT IT.
YEAH THANK YOU SENATOR AND I YOU
KNOW I SUPPORT THIS MOST MOST OF
US DO YEAR AYE AYE SUMAN HEALTH
CARE FOR ALL MEANS HEALTHCARE
FOR ALL I THINK YOU KNOW THAT
THIS IS THE SENIOR VERSION IN
THE ASSEMBLY IS PUSHING THE THEY
PERSON FOR OUR YOUTH.
AND DOWN I KNOW THAT YOU TRIED.
TO BUDGET AND THAT WAS THE BIG
DISAPPOINTMENT FOR YOU AS WELL
AS ALL OF US BUT HE TO STAY AT
IT SO I GUESS MY QUESTION IS I
KNOW IN THE BILL YOU YOU YOU
REFERENCE THAT [inaudible]
THIS IS SUBJECT TO APPROPRIATION.
WHICH WAS FIRST THE SORT OF
QUESTION GOING ON IN TERMS OF
THE FUTURE OF WILL PROP FIFTY
SIX FUNDS OKAY SO WE STYLE
ONGOING DISCUSSIONS AND THIS IS
WHY.
WE'RE SUPPORTING MOVING THE THE
BOTH MEASURES FORWARD AS COMPETE
AS DISCUSSIONS CONTINUE ON THE
FUTURE OF THE PROPHET
[inaudible]
GOTCHA.
THANK YOU THANK YOU [inaudible]
ANYONE ELSE.
I DON'T THINK YOU FOR CONTINUING
EMPRESS PERSEVERING HERE I THINK
THE GOAL FOR ALL OF US GET
EVERYONE IN CALIFORNIA COVERED
PERIOD.
OF I THINK BY THEN THAT'S THE
ONLY WAY WE HAVE A HEALTHIER
SYSTEM --
AND AND HEALTHIER OUTCOMES FOR
EVERYONE SO I THINK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR PERSISTENCE AND
AND AND YOUR MISSION.
AND THIS OBVIOUS EVES BY HAS A
DO DO.
HOUSE A RECOMMENDATION FROM THE
CHAIR --
WHEN WE HAVE A MOTION AND I SO
SORRY ABOUT HOW MANY PEOPLE MADE
THE MOTION HERE BUT?
BUT I THINK I'VE GOT RIGHT NOW
IT LOOKS LIKE --
MISS CARILLO MADE THE MOTION WAS
SECONDED BY MISTER FOR THE
MOTION IS TO PASS --
TO APPROPRIATIONS WOULD LIKE TO
CLOSE SENATORS THANK YOU AGAINST
A CHAIR FOR YOUR YOUR HELP IN
YOUR WORK ON THIS ISSUE AS WELL.
THIS IS AN ONGOING ISSUE FOR US
HERE IN CALIFORNIA ESPECIALLY
WHEN WE'VE REALLY COME DOWN TO A
NOW REALLY SELECTING THE WHOLE
[inaudible]
CARE -- AND
YOU KNOW WE LOOK AT POTENTIAL
SAVINGS SO WE CAN GET ACTUALLY
BY REMOVING THESE FOLKS FROM THE
EMERGENCY ROOM THAT COST US
THREE TIMES THE AMOUNT.
NOT ONLY THAT THE MORE MORAL
RIGHT THING TO DO BUT SO
FISCALLY SOUND THING TO DO FOR
STATE I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR I
THINK YOU VERY MUCH SO THE
MOTION IS TO PASS APPROPRIATIONS
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
WHAT I WOULD AYE MAYES?
THANK YOU HURRY.
HACKER CURRY I BIGELOW
[inaudible]
FATAH [inaudible]
BURKE.
BURKE I CARILLO.
CREEL AYE FLORA.
FLORA NO LIMON.
LEVINE I MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE THIS AREA
[inaudible]
RODRIGUEZ SANTIAGO [inaudible]
THURMOND.
BERMAN I WALDRON.
THE SEVENTY ONE MORE WE'VE GOT
SOME MEMBERS MISSING SO THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR.
CRITICS BILL S. B. TWELVE TWENTY
EIGHT PERFECT THANK YOU WANT TO
THANK THE COMMITTEE STAFF AND
ACCEPT A HAS AUTHORS AMENDMENTS
THE LANGUAGE SUGGESTED IN THE
ANALYSIS.
THAT THE CERTIFICATION IS
STRICTLY VOLUNTARY.
AND I COMMIT TO TAKE THAT
AMENDMENT IN THE NEXT POLICY
COMMITTEE.
MEMBERS AS WE TALK TWENTY EIGHT
DEFINES ADVANCE PATIENT BROKE
GRAIN WHICH MEANS REFERRING A
PATIENT IN EXCHANGE FOR A
KICKBACK.
COMMISSION OR ANY KIND OF
ECONOMIC BENEFIT AYE AS WE TALK
TO ME IT ALSO RAISES NONCLINICAL
STANDARDS FOR SUBSTANCE ABUSE.
USE DISORDER CONTINUUM OF CARE
THAT PROTECT CONSUMERS FROM
ABUSE BILLS INCLUDE TRANSPIRE
TRANSPARENT FINANCIAL RULES
REPORTING OF PATIENT DEATHS ARE
OCCURRING NALOXONE WHICH IS --
THE OVERDOSE PREVENTING DRUG
AVAILABLE WITHOUT PRESCRIPTION
THE BILL ALSO REQUIRES LICENSE
RECOVERY PROGRAMS TO REFER
PATIENTS TO ONLY FACILITIES THAT
PROTECT PATIENTS --
FROM PHYSICAL AND FINANCIAL
ABUSE TO DO THIS THE DEPARTMENT
OF HEALTH CARE SERVICES WILL
SELECT A CERTIFYING ORGANIZATION
THAT WILL ENSURE HIGH STANDARDS
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE.
HELLO EVERYONE I AM WAY
SCHNEIDER AND A CEO AND
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF CASA
TREATMENT CENTER.
IN PASADENA CASA HAS BEEN AND OF
PROVIDING ADDICTION TREATMENT
SERVICES SINCE.
NINETEEN SIXTY EIGHT AS ONE OF
THE FIRST GENDER SPECIFIC
TREATMENT CENTERS IN THE COUNTRY
OUR PROGRAM IS DESIGNED. TO
ADDRESS THE IT FOR A DIVERSE AND
UNIQUE NEEDS OF WOMEN WITH
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDERS.
ARE TREATMENT APPROACHES ARE IN
ALIGNMENT WITH BEHAVIOR.
SAYS ENTER PROVIDED THROUGHOUT
HER ENTIRE CONTINUUM OF CARE.
BECAUSE AS A NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATION WHOSE CORE VALUES
INCLUDE QUALITY AND ETHICAL
DELIVERY OF SERVICES WE DO NOT
PATIENT WE WE DO NOT PARTICIPATE
IN CLIENT BROKERING.
AND WE DO NOT OFFER RECEIVER
ENUMERATION FOR CLIENT REFERRALS.
I'VE BEEN WORKING IN THE FIELD
OF ADDICTION TREATMENT FOR A THE
MENTAL HEALTH PARITY AND
ADDICTION EQUITY ACT OF TWO
THOUSAND EIGHT BY EQUAL HEALTH
INSURANCE COVERAGE FOR MENTAL
HEALTH AND ATTACKED ADDICTIVE
DISORDERS.
THE AFFORDABLE CARE ACT OF TWO
THOUSAND TEN BEMBA HEALTH
INSURANCE COVERAGE TO MILLIONS
OF PEOPLE IN OUR COMMUNITIES.
THROUGHOUT THIS COUNTRY.
PRIOR TO THE PASSAGES OF TO THE
PASSAGE OF THESE ACTS ADDICTION
TREATMENT AND BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
CARE.
WAS A LARGELY UNRECOGNIZED FIELD.
THESE MONUMENTAL ACTS HAD A
PROFOUND IMPACT ON CREATING
ACCESSIBILITY TO CARE IN NEW
OPPORTUNITIES FOR PEOPLE TO
RECOVER FROM ADDICTION.
BUT ALSO CAME WITH THE PASSAGE
OF THESE ACTS WAS AN UNTAPPED
PROFIT DRIVEN MARKET.
CREATING COMPETITION OVER
INSURANCE REIMBURSEMENT RATES.
HIGHLY COMPETITIVE MARKET
MARKETS CAN DRIVE FRAUDULENT
ACTIVITY.
THIS IS BEING EVIDENCED AN
INCREASED FREQUENCY HEARING
CALIFORNIA. FOR EXAMPLE SOME
TREATMENT CENTERS ARE PROVIDING
ARE SOME TREATMENT CENTER
PROVIDERS HAVE BEEN PAYING FOR
INSURANCE PREMIUMS OF THEIR
CLIENTS IN ADDITION TO COVERING
THE COSTS OF THEIR HOUSING AND
ENDS ABILITIES.
THE COMPETITIVE MARKET HAS OFF
ALSO DRIVEN UNETHICAL PRACTICES
OF REFERRING CLIENTS BASED ON
THEIR POTENTIAL PROFITABILITY.
OVER THEIR MEDICAL CLINICAL AND
ENVIRONMENTAL INDICATIONS.
I SUPPORT SB ONE TWO TO EIGHT
BECAUSE IT WILL REINFORCE THE
VALUE SYSTEMS THAT THE FIELD OF
ADDICTION TREATMENT WAS FOUNDED
ON HELPING OTHERS.
BECAUSE AS A LONG HISTORY OF
HELPING PEOPLE TRANSFORM THEIR
LIVES BUT WE NEED YOUR HELP TO
CONTINUE DOING OUR WORK.
ETHICAL PROVIDERS LIKE US CAN'T
COMPETE WITH THE GROWING NUMBER
OF UNETHICAL PROVIDERS THAT ARE
CAPITALIZING ON INDIVIDUALS IN A
LIFE CRISIS.
I SUPPORT SB ONE TWO TWO EIGHT
BECAUSE IT WILL BE ON PATIENT
BROKERING.
BY LICENSE TREATMENT FACILITIES
AND PROMOTE BUSINESS PRACTICES
THAT ARE GROUNDED IN CONSUMER
PROTECTIONS.
IT WILL PROTECT AGAINST
FINANCIAL ABUSE AND ENCOURAGE
NON DISCRIMINATION AND
CULTURALLY COMPETENT BUSINESS
PRACTICES.
I SUPPORT SB.
ONE TWO TWO EIGHT BECAUSE IT IS
A STEP TOWARDS CREATING A
TREATMENT ENVIRONMENT THAT IS
FOCUSED ON WHAT IS IN THE BEST
INTEREST OF THE PERSON.
WHO IS SEEKING A LIFE IN
RECOVERY FROM ADDICTION?
I URGE YOU TO AND USE OF YOUR
SUPPORT TO THIS LEGISLATION.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
AND A ONE WITH ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA LIFE AND HEALTH
INSURANCE COMPANIES IN SUPPORT.
TIFFANY VAN BEHALF OF RECOVERY
FROM NOW IN SUPPORT [inaudible]
ANYONE ELSE. TWO IN OPPOSITION.
I'M SORRY MY HEARING A VERY GOOD
I COULDN'T TELL WHO MOVED THE
BILL.
SO THIS BURKE OF THE BILL THANK
YOU.
SIR.
HOW MISTER CHAIR MEMBER KURT
CHILD THAT DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA --
WE REGRETFULLY AND RESPECTFULLY --
OPPOSE THIS BILL PRIMARILY
BECAUSE OF THE RESIDENCE --
CERTIFICATION PROVISIONS BILL SO
I FIRST LET ME SAY THAT WE ARE
SUPPORTIVE OF PROVISIONS THAT
WOULD RESTRICT CREATION
BROKERING THOSE HAVE A A
HORRENDOUS EFFECT ON INDIVIDUALS --
WHO ARE IN THE --
TREATMENT --
CONTINUUM AND WE AGREE THAT
THERE MUST BE RESTRICTIONS AND
LIMITATIONS ON THAT PRACTICE.
BUT WE ARE OPPOSED --
TO THE CERTIFICATION OF PROGRAM
THAT'S ESTABLISHED IN THE BILL
AND HAVE HISTORICALLY EACH TIME
THAT --
THESE COME BEFORE THIS COMMITTEE
AND OTHER COMMITTEES OPPOSE
THOSE -- AND
EVEN IF IT IS VOLUNTARY AND I
CERTAINLY APPRECIATE THE EFFORTS
THAT.
ARE BEING MADE TO BE TO CLARIFY
THAT IT IS A FACT --
VOLUNTARILY VOLUNTARY BUT WE DO
BELIEVE THAT EVEN A VOLUNTARY
PROGRAM STILL VIOLATES --
BOTH FEDERAL AND STATE FAIR
HOUSING --
LAWS A IT'S A IT'S A RESTRICTION
THAT IS BEING PLACED --
ON THESE OF RESIDENCES AND AGAIN
A REMINDER THAT THESE ARE INDEED --
RESIDENTS AND NOT TREATMENT
FACILITIES --
WITH A STATE SANCTIONED AND THEY
ARE --
PROTECTED FROM THESE RESIDENCES
ARE PROTECTED FROM --
RESTRICTIVE --
REGULATIONS AND THAT'S
PARTICULARLY TRUE WHEN
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE IN THESE --
RESIDENTS ARE INDIVIDUALS WHO
ARE IN TREATMENT PROGRAMS AND
THEREFORE PROTECTED --
AS PERSONS WITH --
WITH DISABILITIES --
SO IT WHAT WHAT EVEN IN THE CASE
WHERE IS THIS IS A A VOLUNTARY
PROGRAM --
WHAT IT DOES IS HAS THE EFFECT
OF ESSENTIALLY LIMITING --
FOR INDIVIDUALS WHO MAY CHOOSE
NOT TO LIVE IN THOSE --
ENTITIES AND NOT BE ABLE TO GET
THE REFERRALS --
TO OTHER RESIDENTS THAT --
MAY NOT CHOOSE --
TO VOLUNTARILY --
PARTICIPATE SO WE BELIEVE THAT
THIS AMOUNTS TO AN END RUN ON
TIME FAIR HOUSING LAWS AND WE'D
ARCHER NO VOTE ON THE BILL.
VERY MUCH IS THERE ANYONE ELSE
IN OPPOSITION.
SHE NEVER BRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS LOOKING COMMITTEE.
SEEING NONE SENATOR WHICH ARE
CLOSE.
THANK YOU I RESPECTFULLY ASK
TRUE I DON'T.
THINK YOU VERY MUCH ASSIST US IN
JOY DO PASS RECOMMENDATION --
WE HAVE A MOTION FOR BURKE A
SECOND FROM HIS CARILLO AT JUST
A QUICK FOR THE MINUTES WILL BE
TAKEN AND PUBLIC SAFETY CRACKED
NOT AT OUR COMMITTEE.
AND SO THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
PUBLIC SAFETY ON MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL WOULD I
WOULD I MAYES.
NOW HERE CURRY.
THANK YOU VERY AYE BIGELOW.
BIGELOW AYE BONTA [inaudible]
BURKE [inaudible]
BURKE.
BURKE I CARILLO.
CARILLO AYE FLORA [inaudible]
LLAMA.
LIMON AYE MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE IS AARON
[inaudible]
RODRIGUEZ [inaudible]
SANTIAGO [inaudible]
THURMOND.
THURMOND AYE RODRIGUEZ AYE AND
WALDRON.
THAT HAS NINE VOTES SO WILL BE
THAT OPEN FOR OTHER STAND ITEMS
TREMORS THINKS SO MUCH SENATOR
[inaudible]
SENATOR MITCHELL [inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
SENATOR LYNCH.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
I'M HERE TO PRESENT --
SENATE BILL.
TEN THIRTY FOUR IT'S A MEASURE
TO ENSURE THAT PATIENTS RECEIVE
INFORMATION ABOUT BREAST TISSUE
DENSITY ON THEIR FEDERALLY
REQUIRED MAMMOGRAPHY WILL REPORT.
IF THEY INDEED HAVE DENSE BREAST
TISSUE.
THROUGH THE KNOW THIS WOMAN
RECEIVE CRITICAL INFORMATION
REGARDING THEIR OWN BREAST
TISSUE DENSITY IN THE GOOD OF
THE BANK SINCE FOR BREAST CANCER
RISK AND SCREENING.
MAMMOGRAPHY IS CURRENTLY THE
ONLY BREAST CANCER SCREENING
TOOL PROVEN TO REDUCE BREAST
CANCER MORTALITY IT USES XRAY
THROUGH TO VIEW THE BRASS.
AND IS A FAST AND WIDELY
AVAILABLE SCREENING METHOD.
THE PROBLEM HOWEVER IS WHEN A
WOMAN HAVE DENSE BREAST TISSUE.
IT REFLECTS A DARKENED A
MAMMOGRAM.
WHERE US DENSE TISSUES APPEARS
Y.?
MAMMOGRAPHY RESULTS ARE REVIEWED
VISUALLY BY PROVIDERS IN BOTH
CANCER AND DENSE BREAST TISSUE
APPEAR VISUALLY WIDE ON A
MAMMOGRAM.
ACCORDING TO THE NATIONAL CANCER
INSTITUTE.
THE MAIN CAUSE A FALSE NEGATIVE
MAMMOGRAPHY RESULTS ISN'T DUE TO
HIGH BROWN'S DEATH BREAST
DENSITY.
THIS BILL IS CRUCIAL BECAUSE IT
ALLOWS.
WOMEN TO HAVE IN IT WOULD FORMED
INFORMATION CONVERSATIONS WITH
THEIR DOCTORS ABOUT THEIR OWN
HEALTH AS EQUAL PARTNERS IN THE
HEALTHCARE DELIVERY SYSTEM.
WITH ME TODAY IS AMY COLTON A
BREAST CANCER PREVENTION
ADVOCATE AND SURVIVOR AND DOCTOR
HARRIET BRONSKI MEDICAL DIRECTOR
OF BREAST IMAGING AT MILLS
PENINSULA MEDICAL CENTER.
HI MY NAME IS AMY COLTON I'M A
NURSE AND I'M FROM SANTA CRUZ.
AND I AM THE CONSTITUENT WHO IN
TWO THOUSAND AND ELEVEN APPROACH
THEN SENATOR SANITY IN ABOUT
LEGISLATION. TO INFORM PATIENTS
ABOUT THEIR BREAST DENSITY.
AND A LOT HAS CHANGED SINCE THEN
BUT ONE THING THAT HASN'T
CHANGED I MY PARALYZING FEAR OF
PUBLIC SPEAKING.
SO PLEASE BEAR WITH ME AS READ
MY STATEMENT ON UP BACK IN TWO
THOUSAND ELEVEN I HAD RECENTLY
RECOVERED FROM A BRUTAL BATTLE
WITH ADVANCED STAGE BREAST
CANCER.
PRIOR TO MY DIAGNOSIS I HAD
FAITHFULLY FOLLOWED THE
GUIDELINES FOR SCREENINGS BUT
UNBEKNOWNST TO ME I HAD DENSE
BREAST TISSUE.
THIS MEANT THAT MY MAMMOGRAM
RESULTS WERE MUCH LESS ACCURATE
AND I WAS AT AN INCREASED RISK
FOR DEVELOPING BREAST CANCER.
HAD I BEEN GIVEN THIS
INFORMATION THERE IS A GREAT
LIKELIHOOD THAT MY DIAGNOSIS
WOULD HAVE COME EARLIER
RESULTING IN A MORE FAVORABLE
PROGNOSIS AND SPARING ME A GREAT
DEAL OF SUFFERING.
THE MOMENT I LEARNED THIS WAS
THE MOMENT WHEN I DECIDED THAT
NO OTHER WOMAN SHOULD EVER HAVE
TO SUFFER A DELAYED BREAST
CANCER DIAGNOSIS.
UNNECESSARILY.
THE INTENT OF SB TEN THIRTY FOUR
IS TO EDUCATE AND RAISE
AWARENESS SO THAT ALL PATIENTS
HAVE THE GREATEST CHANCE FOR
EARLY DETECTION.
EVERY PATIENT SHOULD HAVE THE
INFORMATION SHE NEEDS TO HAVE AN
INFORMED DISCUSSION WITH HER
PHYSICIAN ABOUT HER PERSONAL SET
OF RISK FACTORS AND THE BEST
PLAN OF SCREENING.
BASED ON HER RISK FACTORS.
IF THE LAW IS ALLOWED TO EXPIRE
WE WILL GO BACK TO A TIME WHEN
MANY WOMEN RECEIVED NEGATIVE
MAMMOGRAM RESULTS.
WHEN IN FACT THEY DID HAVE
INVASIVE CANCER?
THERE HAVE BEEN NO ADVERSE
RESULTS SINCE THE LAW WENT INTO
EFFECT.
DESPITE THE CONCERNS OF
OPPONENTS IN TWO THOUSAND TWELVE
WOMEN HAVE NOT PANICKED AND HAVE
PROVED THEY CAN HANDLE THIS
INFORMATION QUITE WELL.
A SIGNIFICANT DEVELOPMENT
RESULTING FROM THE WIDESPREAD
BREAST DENSITY LAWS ACROSS THE
NATION IS THAT MEDICAL AND
CANCER ORGANIZATIONS NOW REGARD
DENSE BREAST TISSUE AS THE MOST
PREVALENT AND COMMON RISK FACTOR.
ECLIPSING EVEN FAMILY HISTORY.
THIS MAKES THE CASE FOR
PROVIDING WOMEN INFORMATION
ABOUT THEIR BREAST DENSITY EVEN
MORE CRITICAL. TO GO BACKWARDS
WOULD NOT ONLY BE A GREAT
DISSERVICE BUT POTENTIALLY FATAL
FOR SOME.
WHEN CANCERS DETECTED EARLY IT
IS MORE SURVIVABLE TREATMENT IS
LESS BRUTAL AND IT IS LESS
COSTLY? FIVE YEARS AGO THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR
REALIZE THE VALUE OF DENSITY
NOTIFICATION.
CALIFORNIA WAS ONE OF THE
EARLIEST OF THE THIRTY FIVE
STATES TO ENACT AND MANY OF THE
STATES THAT FOLLOWED HAVE
MODELED THEIR LAWS AFTER OUR OWN.
I AM GRATEFUL THAT SENATOR
MITCHELL AND THE CO AUTHORS
UNDERSTAND AND CARE ABOUT THE
IMPORTANCE OF BREAST DENSITY.
AND I HOPE YOU WILL TO BY VOTING
IN FAVOR OF SB.
TEN THIRTY FOUR THANK YOU
SENATOR MITCHELL GOOD AFTERNOON
MEMBERS OF THE STATE ASSEMBLY IT
IS INDEED AN HONOR. FOR ME TO BE
BEFORE YOU TODAY IN SUPPORT.
I HAVE SENATE BILL.
TEN THIRTY FOUR AS A PHYSICIAN
SPECIALIZING IN EARLY DETECTION
AND DIAGNOSIS OF BREAST CANCER I
AM SO GLAD TO HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY. TO SHARE WITH YOU
HOW THE BREAST DENSITY
NOTIFICATION LAW HAS HAD A
POSITIVE IMPACT IN THE HEALTH
AND LIVES OF COUNTLESS WOMEN.
IN MY OWN COMMUNITY.
HERE IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
AND BE ON AS OTHER STATES LOOK
TO US FOR GUIDANCE IN ENACTING
SIMILAR LEGISLATION.
SCREENING FOR BREAST CANCER HAS
TRADITIONALLY BEEN A ONE SIZE
FITS ALL APPROACH.
WOMEN FORTY AND ABOVE ARE
RECOMMENDED TO HAVE ANNUAL
MAMMOGRAMS HOWEVER.
WOMEN ARE DIVERSE IN AGE RISK
FACTORS AND TOLERANCE FOR
SCREENING AND MAMMOGRAMS ARE NOT
EQUALLY EFFECTIVE IN DETECTING
BREAST CANCER IN ALL WOMEN.
THERE'S AN ENORMOUS HAD
ORIGINATED IN THE MAVERICK
GRAPHIC APPEARANCE OF WOMEN'S
BREAST TISSUE.
DUE TO VARYING COMPONENTS OF
FATTY TISSUE AND FIBROUS OR
DANCE TISSUE.
CANCER TISSUE CREATES A WIDER
BACKGROUND WHICH MAY LIMIT HOW
ABNORMALITIES WHICH MAY BE THE
EARLIEST INDICATION OF CANCER.
AND DENSE BREAST TISSUE ISCOMIN
4250% OF US WOMEN WHO HAVE
MAMMOGRAMS HAVE HETEROGENEOUS WE
DANCE ARE EXTREMELY DENSE TISSUE
WHICH IS ALSO NOW RECOGNIZED.
AS A SIGNIFICANT INDEPENDENT
RISK FACTOR FOR DEVELOPING
BREAST CANCER WOMEN WITH DENSE
BREASTS IN FACT ARE FOUR TO SIX
TIMES.
HIGHER RISK FOR DEVELOPING
BREAST CANCER SO HOW MIGHT A
WOMAN KNOW SHE HAS DENSE BREAST
TISSUE.
WELL BEFORE BREAST DENSITY
NOTIFICATION LAWS WERE ENACTED
ACROSS UNITED STATES A WOMAN
MIGHT ONLY FIND OUT AFTER
DISCOVERING A CANCEROUS LUMP.
WARREN ADVANCED BREAST CANCER
DESPITE YEARS OF HAVING NORMAL
MAMMOGRAMS. THIRTY FIVE STATES
NOW HAVE ENACTED BREAST DENSITY
NOTIFICATION LAWS.
THE IMPACT OF THESE LAWS HAVE
BEEN AN INCREASED AWARENESS
ABOUT THE LIMITATIONS OF
MAMMOGRAMS AND WOMEN WITH DENSE
BREASTS.
A MORE INFORMED DISCUSSION
BETWEEN WOMEN AND THEIR
HEALTHCARE PROVIDERS ABOUT
ADDITIONAL SCREENING OPTIONS.
IN INCREASING UTILIZATION OF
WHAT WE CALL SUPPLEMENTAL OR
ADDITIONAL SCREENING WITH
ULTRASOUND AND MRI AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY.
AN INCREASE IN BREAST CANCER
DETECTION.
AT THE CENTER WHERE I AM
PRIVILEGED TO SERVE AS MEDICAL
DIRECTOR THE ADDITIONAL THE
ADDITION OF SUPPLEMENTAL
SCREENING HAS INCREASED OUR
EARLY STAGE BREAST CANCER
DETECTION RATE BY 10%.
OVER THE PAST FIVE YEARS SINCE
THE LAW WAS ENACTED. NINETEEN
ADDITIONAL EARLY STAGE BREAST
CANCERS WERE DETECTED IN OUR
SCREENING PROGRAM LAST YEAR
ALONE DUE TO SUPPLEMENTAL
SCREENING AND WOMEN WITH DENSE
BREASTS.
SENATE BILL TEN THIRTY FOUR IS
ESSENTIAL IN PROVIDING WOMEN AND
THEIR HEALTH PROVIDERS WITH
INVALUABLE INFORMATION NEEDED
FOR INDIVIDUALIZED INFORMED
DECISION MAKING AND ANY CHEERING.
OUR MUTUAL GOAL.
EARLY DETECTION OF BREAST CANCER
WHICH SAVES LIVES THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
REMOTE CHáVEZ THERE'S IN
SUPPORT.
SIMONA HODAK MARTIN AS A WOMAN
I'M IN SUPPORT --
MYCORRHIZA GAN ON BEHALF OF THE
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS OF SANTA
CLARA COUNTY THE SPONSOR THE
BILL WANT TO THANK SENATOR
MITCHELL.
AND CONVEY THE THANKS OF FORMER
SENATOR SUPERVISORS MAYBE AND
FOR AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
SECURING MEMBERS BOB ACT ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
RADIOLOGICAL SOCIETY WE ARE
NEUTRAL ON THE BILL RADIOLOGISTS
ARE THE ONES WHO PROVIDE THE
SCREAM OUT FOR SERVICES PROVIDE
THE NOTICE IN THE REPORT.
WILL COME FOR THE LANGUAGE OF IN
DOING THAT AND ARE NEUTRAL
[inaudible]
ANYONE ELSE. THREE ONE IN
OPPOSITION.
YOU KNOW WE'RE BRINGING BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS --
IV ACCEPTED THE AMENDMENTS.
SENATOR.
WITH A GREAT RESERVATION.
OUR ANY IRRITATION YES.
CRITICALLY THINKS NO OPPOSITION
SHOWED UP.
WITH A GREAT IRRITATION.
THE MOTION IS A TO HAVE A MOTION
WHERE MOTION BY A MISSILE MONA
SECOND BY MISS KOREA MOTION IS
PASSED AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS MADAM SECRETARY
WOULD LIKE. TO CALL THE LEFT TO
CLOSE IF I MAY BE GIVEN THE
OPPORTUNITY CERTAINLY --
IT WAS SUGGESTED THAT THE
AMENDMENTS WERE NECESSARY --
FOR FOR BRADLEY REASONS FIRST IT
WAS SUGGESTED THAT THE GOVERNOR
PROBABLY WOULDN'T SIGNED A BILL
WITHOUT THE AMENDMENTS.
I WOULD REPORT WERE REFER YOU
ALL TO PAY SEVEN IN THE BILL
ANNOUNCES.
THAT QUOTE'S THE GOVERNOR'S VETO
MESSAGE ARE ON A PREVIOUS
VERSION OF THE BILL.
AND HE VETOED BECAUSE HE WAS
CONCERNED THAT THAT LANGUAGE
ADVISE THAT ADDITIONAL SCREENING
MAY BE BENEFICIAL THE LANGUAGE
THAT WAS FINALLY SETTLED --
AND FIFTEEN THIRTY EIGHT AND IS
ON DUPLICATED AGAIN AND TEN
THIRTY FOUR DOES NOT SUGGEST
THAT SCREENING MAY BE BENEFICIAL.
IF I MAY MISTER CHAIR JUST TO
BRIEFLY READ WITH THE STATEMENT
S. SO EVERYONE IS CLEAR ABOUT
ALL WE ARE ASKING.
STATEMENT READS YOUR MAMMOGRAM
SHOWS THAT YOUR BREAST TISSUE IS
DEATH.
DENSE BREAST TISSUE WITH COMMON
AND IS NOT ABNORMAL HOWEVER
DENSE BREAST TISSUE CAN MAKE IT
HARDER TO EVALUATE THE RESULTS
OF YOUR MAMMOGRAM.
AND MAY ALSO BE ASSOCIATED WITH
INCREASED RISK OF BREAST CANCER.
THIS INFORMATION ABOUT THE
RESULT OF YOUR MAMMOGRAM IS
GIVEN TO YOU TO RAISE YOUR
AWARENESS.
AND TO INFORM YOUR CONVERSATIONS
WITH YOUR DOCTOR TOGETHER YOU
CAN DECIDE WHICH SCREEN OPTIONS
ARE RIGHT FOR YOU A REPORT FOR
YOUR RESULTS WITH SENT TO YOUR
POSITION --
SENATE HEALTH COMMITTEE
REQUESTED --
A LIT REVIEW BE PERFORMED JUST
THIS YEAR BY TWO BURKE.
THE LIT REVIEW ASK QUESTIONS
BEYOND THE SCOPE OF THE LANGUAGE
IN OUR BILL.
BUT ULTIMATELY ONE OF THE KEY
FINDINGS WAS.
YOU BURKE CONCLUDES THAT THERE
IS INSUFFICIENT EVIDENCE
REGARDING THE EFFECTS OF THE
NOTIFICATION LAWS ON AWARENESS
OF PERSONAL BRENT YESTERDAY
DENSITY.
INSUFFICIENT EVIDENCE IS NOT
QUOTE EVIDENCE OF NO EFFECT IT
IS POSSIBLE THAT IT IMPACT COULD
RESULT FROM THESE LAWS BUT
CURRENT EVIDENCE IS INSUFFICIENT
TO INFORM AN ESTIMATE.
SO MY ARGUMENT IS SIMPLY THAT.
WOMEN HAVE A RIGHT TO KNOW ABOUT
THEIR OWN BODIES.
AND WE ARE SIMPLY ASKING THAT
WOMAN BE INFORMED SO WHEN THEY
ENGAGE IN A DIALOGUE WITH THEIR
HEALTH PROVIDER THERE ON EQUAL
FOOTING AND COULD PROVIDE
CRITICAL INFORMATION --
THE SUNSET --
IF THE EXPECTATION ON THE SUNSET
IS THAT THE RESEARCH MAY
ULTIMATELY COME UP WITH A
DIFFERENT FINALLY I DOUBT THAT
EVERY WILL IT EVER WILL QUITE
FRANKLY.
BECAUSE FRANKLY WERE ASKING THE
WRONG QUESTIONS BUT IF A WOMAN
OR TEN THOUSAND WOMEN OR THREE
WOMEN.
ARE EMPOWERED WITH INFORMATION
ABOUT THEIR OWN BODIES.
AND THEREFORE HAVE EQUAL FOOTING
TO HAVE A CONVERSATION WITH
THEIR HEALTH CARE PROVIDER
THAT'S A GOOD THING.
AND IF WE HAVE TO COME BACK AND
SPEND TAXPAYER DOLLARS EVERY
FIVE YEARS TO HAVE ANOTHER BILL
TO EXTEND THE SUNSET I GUESS
THATS WHAT WILL HAVE TO DO.
SO WITHOUT AYE ASPIRIN AYE VOTE
[inaudible]
SENATOR.
THAT WE WILL HAVE [inaudible]
CALDERON [inaudible]
WOULD.
WHAT I MAYES?
AGUIAR-CURRY.
THANK YOUR CURRY AYE BIGELOW.
BIGELOW AYE BONTA.
BURKE [inaudible]
BURKE I CARILLO.
CARILLO AYE FLORA.
FLORA I'LL AMONG [inaudible]
MCCARTY.
MCCARTY I THIS AREA.
RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ SIZE
SANTIAGO.
THURMOND THURMOND AYE WALDRON.
YOU DOES OUTLINES DON'T THINK
SENATOR THANK YOU [inaudible]
THEN
.
OKAY GOOD AFTERNOON THAT A CHAIR
MEMBERS.
FIRST OF ALL I'D JUST LIKE TO
MAKE NOTE THAT --
THE CHAIRS UP PERHAPS --
CERTAINLY MORE EXPERT AND MYSELF
AND PERHAPS MORE SO THAN ANYONE
ELSE IN THE LEGISLATURE ON THIS
ISSUE.
AND I WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE
CHAIR OF THE COMMITTEE FOR
WORKING WITH MY OFFICE AND I'LL
BE TAKING THE CLARIFYING
AMENDMENTS LAID OUT THE ANALYSIS.
S. B. ELEVEN FORTY EIGHT WILL
ALLOW THAT ISN'T REGISTERED
DENTAL HYGIENIST IN ALTERNATIVE
PRACTICE AND THEN TO CAL PROGRAM
TO BILL FOR SILVER DIAMINE
FLUORIDE.
WHICH IS INTERESTING AGENTS --
AS LONG AS CONSULTATION OF THE
PATIENT HAS OCCURRED.
AND APPROPRIATE FORM CONSENT IS
GIVEN AND IS PART OF A
COMPREHENSIVE --
TO THOUGH TO TO CASE PREVENTABLE
IT REMAINS THE MOST COMMON
CHRONIC DISEASE OF CHILDHOOD AND
CONTINUES AFFECT PEOPLE CROSSED
OUR LIVES.
S. THE EFFORTS OF A DINING
FLUORIDE HOLDS THE PROMISE OF
REDUCING BURDEN OF THIS DISEASE
AS WELL AS SLOWING OR STOPPING
DISEASE PROGRESSION.
I'D THE STF IS A LIQUID THAT'S
TIE APPLY TOPICALLY TO THE
TOOTH'S IT BASICALLY HELPS
ARREST THE GROWTH --
S. B. --
ELEVEN FORTY EIGHT ONCE ALSO
INCLUDE STF AS ONE OF THE
OPTIONS THAT'S AVAILABLE FOR
DENNIS TO TREAT AND NOT JUST
PREVENT DENTAL DECAY EXPECT WE
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTES HAVE
WITNESSES.
AFTERNOON TURN MEMBERS MY NAME
IS MARY ME KIANA WITH THE
CALIFORNIA DENTAL ASSOCIATION
REPRESENTING OVER TWENTY SEVEN
THOUSAND DENNIS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE.
AND WE'RE PROBABLY SPONSORING SB
ELEVEN FORTY EIGHT BY SENATOR
PAN.
IN TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN AFTER
THE FDA APPROVED STF PAVING THE
WAY FOR ITS WIDESPREAD USE IN
THE U. S..
NOW STF IS NOT APPROPRIATE FOR
ALL PATIENTS INSIST LOW COST LOW
COST SAVE AND NONSURGICAL
DISEASE MANAGEMENT APPROACH.
THAT CAN BE APPLIED IN JUST A
MATTER OF MINUTES.
I MAY NOT FULLY ELIMINATE THE
NEED FOR ADDITIONAL TREATMENT --
BUT IT CAN BE PARTICULARLY
BENEFICIAL IN REALLY THREE
CATEGORIES OF PATIENTS WE HAVE
ARE A YOUNG CHILDREN WE HAVE ARE
DEVELOPMENTALLY DISABLED OR
THOSE WITH SPECIAL NEEDS AND WE
HAVE A FRAIL.
ELDERLY I'M IN SPECIFICALLY FOR
THE WALDRON STF SHOW SPECIAL
PROMISE AND AS HAS THE POTENTIAL
TO DO TO DELAY PEDIATRIC DENTAL
ANASTASIA.
RATHER THAN UNDERGOING A MORE
TRADITIONAL RESTORATIVE APPROACH
AS SUCH AS A FILLING --
DE CHILDREN CAN ACTUALLY UNDERGO
STF IF APPROPRIATE AND EITHER --
DELAYED THE NEED FOR ANASTASIA
OR IF THE BABY TOOTH FALLS OUT
POTENTIALLY YOU DON'T NEED TO
HAVE ANY TRUE.
TRADITIONAL TREATMENT AT ALL.
AND A SUPER IMPORTANT TO NOTE
THAT THERE IS ONE SIGNIFICANT --
SIDE EFFECTS STF ANNOUNCED THAT
LIQUID WILL TURN JUST THE ON
MEDICAID PART OF THE TOOTH BLACK
AND BECAUSE OF THAT WE HAVE I'M
INFORMED CONSENT IN PART OF A
BILL AS WELL --
STF HAS BEEN USED IN OTHER
COUNTRIES SUCH AS JAPAN AND
AUSTRALIA FOR SOMETIMES UP TO A
HUNDRED YEARS SPENDING ON THE
COUNTRY --
SEVERAL OTHER STATES HAVE
ALREADY MADE THIS A MEDICAID
BENEFIT INCLUDING OREGON AND WE
ALREADY HAVE OUR COMMERCIAL
INSURANCE IS WITH IN CALIFORNIA.
REIMBURSING FOR THIS BENEFIT
ALREADY.
I'M IN SEEING HOW EFFECTIVE IT
IS -- WITH
FEEL THAT HAVING THIS IS
IDENTICAL BENEFIT WOULD REALLY
PUT SOME PARITY BETWEEN ALL
PATIENTS AND IN CALIFORNIA AND
THAT'S WHY WE STRONGLY URGE AYE
VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OTHERS.
JENNIFER TANNAHILL WITH AARON
READ AND ASSOCIATES ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA DENTAL HYGIENISTS
ASSOCIATION WE WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR AND SPONSORS FOR WORKING
WITH US AND THAT HIGH TENNIS
THERE SOME HYGIENISTS THAT DO
YOU HAVE --
PATIENTS THAT CAN REALLY USE
THIS AND HAVE ACCESS TO ADD THIS
TREATMENT AS WELL AND SO WE'RE
REALLY GLAD THE AMENDMENTS ARE
GONNA BE TAKEN SO THAT THAT --
RTG PEOPLE BE ABLE TO BILL WITH
THIS CODE TO THINK IF.
YOU VERY MUCH.
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION.
SAY NO ONE WILL BRING BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS.
IN I HAVE A COMMENT AND JUST A
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS BILL
FORWARD THIS THAT THIS IS A A A
GAME CHANGER FOR A LOT OF PEOPLE
AND THE ONE NOTED SIDE EFFECT --
IS A STATIC --
HOWEVER THE AMOUNT OF POTENTIAL
PAIN AND SUFFERING THAT THIS
MIGHT ALLEVIATE FOR FOR CHILDREN
I THINK IS IS HUGELY OUT WAYS
THAT -- SO I
I VERY MUCH APPRECIATE YOU
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD --
DOES OF JOY A DO PASSED
[inaudible]
MAYES.
BIGELOW WHICH ELECT CLOSE CENTER
PAN.
THAT'S AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS ESTIMATE NO THANK
YOU I TO AS A PEDIATRICIAN TAKE
CARE OF PATIENTS WHO OFTEN HAVE
CHALLENGES GETTING ACCESS FOR
PARTICULARLY I'M MORE SURGICAL.
INTERVENTIONS AND BE ABLE TO
HAVE ACCESS TO TO THIS TREATMENT
THAT FROM THEIR DENTAL PROVIDER --
DENTISTS I THINK WILL CERTAINLY
HELP A LOT EXACTLY ASK WHEN I
BUT SECRETARY SO MASH MOTIONS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS MASSACRED PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
WHAT I WOULD AYE MAYES MAYES AYE
AGUIAR-CURRY?
BAKER CREE AYE BIGELOW.
BIGELOW AYE BONTA.
BURKE BURKE AYE CARILLO.
CARILLO AYE FLORA.
FLORA AYE LIMON.
MCCARTY AYE MCCARTY AYE NAZARIAN.
RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ I SANTIAGO.
THEREIN.
THURMOND AYE WALDRON. TWO ZERO
YOU BILLS OUT WILL LEAVE IT OPEN
FOR OTHERS TO ATLANTIC CENTER
PATH [inaudible]
MISTER MONEY.
I AND NUMBER SIXTEEN THE SENATE
BILL
.
ELEVEN NINETY TWO MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS.
CALIFORNIA'S CURRENTLY FACING
OBESITY AND DIABETES CRISIS
EFFECTIVE WHICH IMPACT THE
QUALITY OF LIFE OF OUR
CONSTITUENTS AND DRAIN THE
RESOURCES OF OUR PUBLIC HEALTH
SYSTEM.
OBESITY RELATED MEDICAL
EXPENDITURES COSTS THE STATE
OVER NINE POINT ONE BILLION
DOLLARS EACH YEAR WITH TYPE TWO
DIABETES ADDING AN ADDITIONAL
ONE POINT SIX BILLION DOLLARS
PER YEAR. TO CALIFORNIA'S
HOSPITALIZATION COSTS
OVERWHELMING SCIENTIFIC EVIDENCE
HAS SHOWN THAT SUGAR SWEETENED
BEVERAGES ARE ONE OF THE LEADING
CAUSES OF THE INCREASE IN THESE
CHRONIC HEALTH CONDITIONS.
SUGARY DRINKS PROVIDE NO
NUTRITIONAL VALUE AND ARE THE
LARGEST CONTRIBUTOR OF ADDED
CALORIES IN THE AMERICAN DIET.
CALIFORNIAN DIETARY HABITS HAVE
CHANGED GREATLY IN THE PAST FEW
DECADES WITH MORE AND MORE OF
OUR FOOD BUDGETS BEING SPENT ON
FOOD PREPARED.
OUTSIDE THE HOME.
MOST MEALS OFFERED AND MARKETED
TO CHILDREN IN RESTAURANTS
INCLUDES SUGARY DRINK.
WHICH OFTEN CONTAINS MORE THAN
THE WEEKLY AMOUNT OF SUGAR
RECOMMENDED FOR CHILDREN.
MANY RESTAURANTS AND FAST FOOD
ESTABLISHMENTS HOWEVER HAVE
ALREADY TAKEN STEPS CHANGE WHAT
BEVERAGES THEY OFFER IN THEIR
KIDS MEALS.
RESTAURANTS LIKE MCDONALDS JACK
IN THE BOX APPLEBEE'S WENDY'S
SUBWAY PINERA AND I HOP HAVE ALL
VOLUNTARILY MADE EFFORTS TO
OFFER MORE HEALTHFUL BEVERAGE
OPSINS [inaudible] FOR CHILDREN.
NUMEROUS LOCAL CITIES AND
COUNTIES THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA
HAVE ALSO TAKEN STEPS TO IMPROVE
NUTRITION STANDARDS FOR
CHILDREN'S MEALS.
LONG BEACH STOCKTON DAVIS DALY
CITY SANTA CLARA COUNTY IN THE
SITTING COUNTY OF SAN FRANCISCO
HAVE ALL ADOPTED ORDINANCES
WITHOUT OPPOSITION.
THAT REQUIRE HELP FULL DRINK
OPTIONS IN MEALS MARKETED TO
CHILDREN.
SENATE BILL ELEVEN NINETY TO
FOLLOWS THE LEAD OF THE
RESTAURANT INDUSTRY AND OUR
LOCAL COMMUNITY LEADERS AND
IMPLEMENTS A STATEWIDE.
HELPFUL DEFAULT BEVERAGE POLICY
IN CALIFORNIA.
SEPARATELY THIS BILL WILL
MEAL PRIMARILY OFFERED FOR
CONSUMPTION BY CHILDREN. TO MAKE
THE DEFAULT DRINK OPTIONS SERVED
IN THOSE BUNDLED MEALS A HELPFUL
BEVERAGE SUCH AS WATER SPARKLING
WATER FLAVORED WATER WITH NO
ADDED SWEETENERS.
OR UNFLAVORED MILK.
IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT
CUSTOMERS CAN STILL EXPLICITLY
ASKED TO REPLACE THE HELPFUL
DRINK WITH A SUGARY BEVERAGE IF
THAT IS THEIR CHOICE.
FALL BEVERAGE OFFERED IN A
CHILDREN'S MEAL MUST BE THE
HELPFUL HELPFUL OPTION.
MEMBERS WORD A CRITICAL JUNCTURE
IN CALIFORNIA WHERE PUBLIC
HEALTH POLICIES LIKE THE ONE
FOUND IN THIS BILL CAN HAVE A
DIRECT IMPACT.
AND EDUCATING PARENTS ABOUT THE
SEVERE AND CHRONIC HEALTH
IMPACTS THAT POOR NUTRITIONAL
CHOICES HAVE ON OUR CHILDREN.
MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME
IN THE PERMISSION OF THE CHAIR
WOULD LIKE TO PER PRESENT
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
PLEASE YOU THANK YOU.
AFTERNOON CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE REBEKAH DELLA ROSA
DEPUTY DIRECTOR WITH LATINO
COALITION FOR HEALTHY CALIFORNIA.
OUR MISSION IS TO ADVANCE THE
HEALTH OF THE LATINO COMMUNITY
ACROSS THE STATE AND THE S. B..
ELEVEN NINETY TWO I WOULD
DEFINITELY SUPPORTER --
AS IN CURBING THAT CHRONIC
DISEASE RATES --
AND REALLY PREVENTING THAT THE
EPIDEMIC RATES THAT WE SEE IN
OUR COMMUNITIES --
IT -- IN
ADDITION TO OTHER TOOLS AS BELOW
NINETY TWO WOULD --
MAKE SURE THAT FAMILIES ARE ABLE
TO MAKE THAT THE HEALTHY CHOICE --
THE EASY CHOICE AND AGAIN WITH
THE BUSY SCHEDULES --
FAMILIES ARE CHALLENGE SPECIALLY
IN LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES AND
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR TO BE ABLE --
TO PROVIDE HEALTHY MEALS FOR
THEIR CHILDREN AND SO THAT'S WHY
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT RESTAURANTS
OFFER A HEALTHY FOOD AND
BEVERAGE.
OPTIONS SPECIALLY FOR OUR
CHILDREN.
AND WE ALSO KNOW THAT SUGAR
DRINKS ARE THE BIGGEST SINGLE --
SOURCE OF COLORS AND IN TEAMS
DIETS AND THIS IS AN AREA OF
CONCERN --
62% OF CALIFORNIA TEENS CONSUME
AT LEAST ONE SUGARY DRINK A DAY
AND THAT WE KNOW THAT --
SPECIAL WITH TEAMS OF COLOR
CLOSER 280% --
AND WE ARE AS ADVOCATES STE --
EDUCATING AND YOU KNOW OUR EACH
IN OUR COMMUNITIES --
BUT WE DEFINITELY NEED TO HAVE A
COMPREHENSIVE APPROACH --
AND THAT WE BELIEVE SB ELEVEN
NINETY TWO IS THE WAY TO GO.
AND IN ADDITION --
ES AND THEIR MONEY MENTION TODAY
ONE OUT OF TWO A LATINO AND
AFRICAN AMERICAN KIDS A WILL
DEVELOP TYPE TWO DIABETES SO
IT'S TIME THAT WE DO SOMETHING.
TO CURB THIS EPIDEMIC --
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS
CHRIS LEAPED WILDLY EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR FOR THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ALLIANCE OF YMCAS HERE
TODAY REPRESENTING THE THIRTY
ONE YMCAS AROUND THE STATE AND
THAT THREE ARMED SERVICES YMCAS
TOWN IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
COLLECTIVELY WE SERVE OVER EIGHT
HUNDRED THOUSAND KIDS AND THEIR
FAMILIES EACH YEAR THROUGH --
RANGER PROGRAMS.
A EARLY EDUCATION BEFORE AND
AFTER SCHOOL --
RECREATION SPORTS AND BRADY
CAMPS AND ACROSS DOLLAR PROGRAMS
WE UPHOLD STANDARDS FOR HEALTHY
EATING AND PHYSICAL ACTIVITY --
IN MANY CASES IT'S ACTUALLY PART
OF THE CURRICULUM AND WE WORK
WITH KIDS AND FAMILIES --
SPECIFICALLY ON MAKING HEALTHY
EATING CHOICES HEALTHY BEVERAGE
CHOICES ARE IT'S PART OF OUR
CHARITABLE MISSION AND IT'S PART
OF OUR NATIONAL COMMITMENT STATE
BY STATE TO REDUCE CHILDHOOD I
OBESITY.
AND TO REVERSE THE TREND TOWARDS
TYPE TWO DIABETES IN ADULTS AS
MY COLLEAGUES HAVE POINTED OUT
DUH DUH REALITIES CLEAR.
DRINKING JUST ONE TWELVE OUT
SODA A DAY WE THE CITY IN A
CHILD BY 55%.
AND 62% OF KIDS IN CALIFORNIA
AGE TWELVE THROUGH SEVENTEEN OR
DRINKING AT LEAST ONE SUGARY
BEVERAGE TODAY.
AND THAT ONE SUGARY BEVERAGES
DAY WILL INCREASE THE LIKELIHOOD
OF DEVELOPING TYPE TWO DIABETES
BY 26%.
AS I'M SURE THE COMMITTEE IS
AWARE ALREADY HERE IN CALIFORNIA
AMONG ADULTS MORE THAN HALF OF
ALL ADULTS CALIFORNIA EITHER
SUFFERING WITH PRE DIABETES OR
TYPE TWO DIABETES.
SO IF WE DO NOTHING AND STE JUST
CONTINUE TO RELY ON THE HARD
WORK OF COMMUNITY ORGANIZATIONS.
THAT'S THE TREND THAT'S THE WAY
IT'S GONNA GO SO WITH THIS BILL
WE HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO DO
SOMETHING.
WE HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
SUPPORT FAMILIES MAKING HEALTHY
CHOICES FOR THE KIDS SUPPORT
KIDS IN SETTING HEALTHY HABITS
EARLY IN THEIR LIFE.
AND AN OPPORTUNITY TO BRING
RESTAURANTS INTO THE EFFORTS TO
BUILD A HEALTH EACH THAT NEXT
GENERATION SO RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR SUPPORT TODAY IT'S WHY
WE'RE HERE SUPPORTING THIS BILL.
MISTER CHAIR JUST MULLIN FOR THE
LOCAL ENVIRONMENT HEALTH DEREK'S
IS WE HAVE POLITICALLY PLEASE
FOR THE WITH THESE AMENDMENTS
THAT ENABLES US TO ENFORCE THIS
MORE EFFECTIVELY WILL ENJOY A
VOTE OKAY THANK YOU SO MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
[inaudible]
SUPPORT.
EMILY CHEN ON BEHALF CALIFORNIA
PENITENT BECAUSE THAT WORK IN
SUPPORT.
ALTAMONTE IN SMITH WITH THE
AMERICAN CANCER SOCIETY CANCER
ACTION NETWORK ALSO IN SUPPORT.
CAT DE BURKE WITH THE HEALTH
OFFICER'S ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
A DAVID GONZALEZ OF THE AMERICAN
DIABETES ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
VIDEO BORN AMERICAN CATTERY
PEDIATRICS CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
NURSES AND SUPPORT.
SECOND ON THIS PUBLIC HEALTH
STUDENT AT UC BERKELEY INST
SUPPORT.
CUT THE MUSTARD AMERICAN HEART
ASSOCIATION COSPONSORED SUPPORT.
MUNICIPAL TINA COALITION FOR
HEALTHY CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
BRENT IN MARCH YOU WITH THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
ALSO IN SUPPORT.
KELLY TRUCKS ON BEHALF OF THAT
COUNTY HEALTH EXECUTIVES
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA HINTS
PART.
AND JACOB MAWSON TO HAVE A
PUBLIC HEALTH ADVOCATES IN
SUPPORT.
ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES POOR.
SEEING NONE I WILL GO TO
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION OF ANY
WITNESS THAT OPPOSITION.
SING NOW WILL COME BACK TO THE
THE COMMITTEE.
AND TO MR MCCARTY.
FIRST WE HAVE AN MOTION I
BELIEVE THAT WAS JUST THURMOND
MOVED.
THANK YOU. TO HAVE SECOND.
OKAY YEAH HERE'S A SECOND YOU.
THERE WE GO.
WELL FIRST THAT THANKS FOR
BRINGING THIS ISSUE. TO A
SENATOR --
YOU KNOW AS YOU KNOW WHEN I WAS
A COUNCIL MEMBER AND YOU WERE AT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WE ARE WORKING
ON THIS ISSUE.
A DECADE AGO ON SUGAR SWEETENED
DRINKS AND THIS IS THE SAME
ISSUE A DIFFERENT VENUE --
PLEASE THE LAST FEW YEARS TO SEE
STEPPING UP LIKE YOU MENTIONED
THE RESTAURANTS.
WHO ARE CHANGING THEIR THEIR
PATTERNS TO TO FOCUS ON?
NON ALTERNATIVES DEALING WITH
OUR CRAZY OBESITY EPIDEMIC I I
CAN'T BELIEVE THAT ONE AND TWO
KIDS ARE ON A ON A ONE WAY GOT
TRAINED TO TYPE TWO DIABETES AND
WASN'T THAT WAY LONG AGO AND IT
ALWAYS BLOWS MY MIND TO KNOW
THAT.
THIS RIGHT HERE.
IS IS IN MY OFFICE MY BECAUSE
CHAU TO AND I FIRST GOT HERE
BECAUSE THEY HAD THIS WHEN I WAS
ON THE COUNCIL THIS IS. NINE
POINT FIVE TEASPOONS AND THIS IS
THE AMOUNT OF SUGAR.
IN A CAN OF COKE TELVE OUNCE
TWELVE OUNCES THAT.
ARE MANY TIMES THE OPTIONS FOR
KIDS AND WE HERE THE STATISTICS
IT JUST DOESN'T MAKE SENSE I
THINK ONE THING YOU DO IS IF YOU
MANDATE THAT YOU SHOW THIS
AMOUNT OF SUGAR TO ALL CONSUMERS
AND THEY WALK IN.
THEY PROBABLY WOULD CHANGE THEIR
BEHAVIOR AS WELL BUTTON NOT GOOD
FOR PUBLIC HEALTH AND THIS IS A
SOUND MEASURE SO THANK YOU.
ANY FOR THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
[inaudible]
ALRIGHT.
SANDERS I TO CLOSE.
YES SIR THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIRMAN WANT TO THANK --
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MCCARTY FOR HIS
LONG TERM COMMITMENT ON THIS
ISSUE AS WELL I WOULD ENCOURAGE
AND AMENDMENT OF YOUR EXHIBIT
HOWEVER BECAUSE MOST VENDING
MACHINES SOUTH TWENTY FLUID
OUNCE BOTTLES.
THAT HAVE SIX TEEN TEASPOONS.
OF SUGAR SO THE COMMON DELIVERY
MECHANISM NOW SET TWENTY FLUID
OUNCE BOTTLE YEAH THAT
DISPLAYING HIS OFFICE ALSO
HOOKED IT --
AND JUST BRIEFLY WE'VE ENJOYED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IN THE SENATE
I HOPE WE CAN ENJOY BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT IN THE ASSEMBLY IS WELL.
THIS IS A I THINK A WELL
TAILORED BILL ARE AMENDMENTS
ADDRESS SOME OF THE CONCERNS OF
PUBLIC HEALTH.
OWNERS -- OR
OFFICERS AS WELL AS SMALL
BUSINESS OWNERS ARE I WOULD JUST
ADD TO MY CLOTHES.
MY WIFE'S A PUBLIC HEALTH
PHYSICIAN WORKS IN DIABETES
PREVENTION IN THE SALINAS VALLEY
WITH MOSTLY IMMIGRANT PATIENTS --
IT USED TO BE CALLED ADULT ONSET
DIABETES.
IT'S NO LONGER CALLED ADULT
ONSET Y. HIS WERE SINGING
TEENAGERS AND YOUNGER AGAIN.
THE AMERICAN.
ACADEMY OF PHYSICIANS THE
PRIMARY LEADING CAUSE OF
INCREASED.
CALORIES IN CHILDREN'S DIET.
SUGAR SWEETENED BEVERAGES WERE
UP AGAINST MASSIVE ADVERTISING
FORCES THIS IS A SMALL MEASURE
TO TRY TO EXPAND PUBLIC
EDUCATION WHILE PRESERVING
CHOICE. FOR CONSUMERS AND
PARENTS RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR I'M
WE WE HAVE A MOTION BY MISTER
THURMOND A SECOND BY MR MCCARTY.
SO THE KIDS DOWN THE END THERE
[inaudible]
I HAVE.
THE BUSH'S DO PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS MEN SECTOR PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
WOULD I WOULD I MAYES.
WITHOUT VOTING AGUIAR-CURRY.
HACKER CURRY I BIGELOW.
BIGELOW AYE BONTA [inaudible]
BURKE.
BURKE I CARILLO.
CARILLO AYE FLORA.
FLORIDA VOTING.
LAMONT.
MON I MCCARTY.
MCCARTY I NAZARIAN [inaudible]
RODRIGUEZ.
RODRIGUEZ I SANTIAGO.
CURRENT.
THURMOND AYE WALDRON.
WALDRON AYE.
YOUR YOUR BILL HAS TEN VOTES IS
MORE THAN ENOUGH TO GET OUT OF
COMMITTEE AND WILL BE THE ROLL
UP FOR OTHER SATELLITES THINK
IT'S THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
THANK YOU MEMBERS [inaudible]
SENATOR LEYVA.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR.
YEAH ANNOUNCED THAT AYE PRESENT
MY SECOND BILL FIRST SO THAT MY
WITNESSES HAVE TO CATCH A PLANE
CAN TESTIFY CHURCH.
SO THAT'S ARMED TWELVE EIGHTY
EIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
I'LL GET STARTED AND THE
INTEREST OF TIME AS THEY COME UP.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
FIRST THANK YOU VERY MUCH I
WOULD FIRST LIKE TO BEGIN BY
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS AND THANK YOU FOR
YOUR WORK ON MAKING THIS A
BETTER BILL.
SP TWELVE EIGHTY EIGHT EMPOWERS
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH CDP H. TO ENSURE
PATIENT SAFETY BY ENFORCING
NURSE TO PATIENT RATIOS AND
FINING HOSPITALS THAT REPEATEDLY
BREAK THE STANDARDS.
DESPITE MANDATED A LONGSTANDING
NURSED BREAK PATIENT RATIOS SOME
HOSPITALS CONTINUE TO VIOLATE
THESE VITAL REQUIREMENTS.
FROM 200-082-2000 SEVENTEEN
THERE WERE A TOTAL OF SIX
HUNDRED AND THIRTY TWO
ALLEGATIONS MADE SPECIFICALLY IN
REGARDS TO OUT OF REISSUED
DIFFERENT DEFICIENCIES.
REPORTED THE CDP H..
UNFORTUNATELY THE DEPARTMENT'S
CURRENT ENFORCEMENT MEASURES ARE
SIMPLY NOT ENOUGH CURRENTLY THE
DEPARTMENT CONDUCTS SURVEYS
EVERY THREE YEARS TO ENSURE THE
HOSPITALS ARE COMPLYING WITH THE
LAW.
HOWEVER THIS PERIODIC CHECK IS
TOO FAR AN INFREQUENT ALLOWS
HOSPITALS TO PREPARE FOR THE CD
PH OFFICIALS TO CONDUCT THEIR
SURVEY.
S. B. TWELVE EIGHTY EIGHT WOULD
ADDRESS THIS PROBLEM BY
REQUIRING THAT THE DEPARTMENT
CONDUCT UNANNOUNCED VISITS TO
HOSPITALS TO INSPECT FOR
COMPLIANCE.
WITH NURSE STAFFING REQUIREMENTS
THIS MEASURE WOULD ALSO ALSO
EMPOWER THE DEPARTMENT TO
ENFORCE THE STAFFING RATIOS.
WITH FINES AND CASES WERE
STAFFING RATIOS HAVE BEEN
VIOLATED.
SP TWELVE EIGHTY EIGHT IS
VITALLY IMPORTANT SO THAT WE CAN
CONTINUE TO PROTECT.
PATIENT HEALTH AND SAFETY
HEARING CALIFORNIA HERE IN
SUPPORT TODAY IS THE PRESIDENT
OF SEIU ONE TWO ONE ARE IN JAIL
BATISTE AND MARK WINDOWS OF WITH
SEIU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS.
MY NAME IS GILBERTESE.
I AM OF THE PRESIDENT OF SEIU
LOOK ONE TWO ONE HOUR AND WE
REPRESENT ARE REGISTERED NURSES
THROUGHOUT SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
I'M ALSO AN OPERATING ROOM NURSE
THAT DIGNITY NORTHRIDGE HOSPITAL --
I STARTED MY NURSING CAREER
THIRTY FOUR YEARS AGO. TO TAKE
CARE SICK PATIENTS THE SICK IN
THE VULNERABLE.
I'M HERE TODAY TO ASK YOU FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE ON SP.
TWELVE EIGHTY EIGHT CLOSE TO TWO
DECADES A COAT AGO THE
LEGISLATURE AND GOVERNOR PASS AB.
THREE NINETY FOUR THE ORIGINAL
LEGISLATION THAT CREATED THE
NURSE TO PATIENT RATIOS.
THE RATIOS ARE INTENDED TO KEEP
OUR PATIENTS SAFE AND PRODUCED
THE MOST OPTIMAL HEALTH OUTCOMES
FOR PATIENTS.
HOWEVER THE ENFORCEMENT
MECHANISM FOR TITLE TWENTY TWO
REGULATIONS NEED TO BE
STRENGTHENED.
CURRENTLY THE PENALTIES FOR
VIOLATING A RATIOS ARE
NONEXISTENT [inaudible]
IN FACT.
MOST OF THE TIME WHEN A HOSPITAL
IS FOUND TO BE IN VIOLATION OF
THE NURSE TO PATIENT RATIOS CD
P. H. ADMINISTERS A STATEMENT OF
DEFICIENCY.
IN TURN HOSPITALS ARE REQUIRED
TO CREATE A PLAN OF CORRECTION
THAT REMEDIES THE SPECIFIC
SPECIFIED DEFICIENCY.
SURPRISINGLY THERE IS NO LIMIT
ON HOW MANY STATEMENT OF
DEFICIENCIES A HOSPITAL CAN GET.
AND MOST IF NOT ALL HOSPITALS
ARE NEVER FIND.
THAT IS WHY HOSPITAL'S ARE
WILLING TO CONTINUOUSLY BREAK
THE LAW INPUT PATIENT SAFETY AT
RISK.
AS A NURSE I CAN TELL YOU THAT
VALUE TO COMPLY WOULD NURSE
STAFFING RATIOS PUTS PATIENTS AT
RISK ADDITIONALLY.
THE NURSES HERE TODAY CAN ATTEST
TO THE IMPORTANCE OF NURSE
STAFFING RATIOS AND HOW TITLE
TWENTY TWO REGULATIONS PROTECT
THE HEALTH AND SAFETY OF
PATIENTS. FOR EXAMPLE CATHY A
RIVERSIDE ARE IN WHICH TELL YOU
HOW A PATIENT DEVELOP SERIOUS
SECONDARY ILLNESSES AS A DIRECT
RESULT OF DANGEROUSLY LOW
STAFFING LEVELS.
IMAGINE IF THAT PATIENT WAS YOUR
MOTHER YOUR FATHER YOUR WIFE THE
HUSBAND ARGUE CHAU OR EVEN YOU.
SEE A NEED CALIFORNIAN IS TO
PROTECT OUR PATIENTS BATTER.
AND ENSURE THAT THEY RECEIVE THE
HIGHEST QUALITY OF CARE WE'VE
DONE A POOR JOB OF DOING THAT.
S. B. TWELVE EIGHTY EIGHT
REQUIRES UNANNOUNCED INSPECTIONS
TO ENSURE COMPLIANCE WITH THE
NURSE TO PATIENT RATIOS AND
FINDS HOSPITALS THAT REPEATEDLY.
PLACE PATIENTS HEALTH AND SAFETY
ADDRESS.
THAT IS WHY S. B. TWELVE EIGHTY
EIGHT IS COSPONSORED BY.
SEIU ONE TO ONE OR AND NEO NECK.
THE MEASURE IS ALSO SUPPORTED BY
THE BOARD OF REGISTERED NURSING.
THAT --
AMERICAN NURSES ASSOCIATION.
CNA THE CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS THE CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION CONSUMER
ATTORNEYS AND PLANNED PARENTHOOD
OF CALIFORNIA.
AS THE NURSES WE TOOK AN OATH TO
PROTECT AND ADVOCATE FOR OUR
PATIENTS.
S. B. TWELVE EIGHTY EIGHT IS
SOUND POLICY OUTLINES WHAT OUR
BOAT.
ON BEHALF OF ALL THE NURSES AND
AS SEE YEAH YOU WANT TO ONE ARE
A AND AND THROW CALIFORNIA.
I RESPECTFULLY URGE YOU TO PASS
SP TWELVE EIGHTY EIGHT TO
PROTECT OUR PATIENTS THANK YOU.
YOU VERY MUCH.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MARK
WINDOWS WITH S. YEAH YOU
CALIFORNIA --
AS HIGHLIGHTED BY SENATOR LEYVA
I'M PRESIDENT PETITS CALIFORNIA
HAS GONE TOO LONG WITHOUT A
STRONG ENFORCEMENT MECHANISM TO
ENSURE COMPLIANCE WITH NURSE
NURSE TO PATIENT RATIOS.
IN TWENTY THIRTEEN C. P. H.
IMPLEMENTED REGULATIONS ON
ADMINISTRATIVE PENALTIES FOR A
BROAD RANGE OF VIOLATIONS.
INCLUDING VIOLATIONS OF THE
NURSE TO PATIENT RATIOS.
WHILE THESE REGULATIONS WERE
INTENDED TO INCENTIVIZE
HOSPITALS TO COMPLY WITH THE
NURSE TO PATIENT RATIOS.
DE THREE THESE REGULATIONS HAVE
UNFORTUNATELY HAD THE OPPOSITE
EFFECT.
NOTABLY SINCE TWENTY THIRTEEN
WHEN THE REGULATIONS WERE
IMPLEMENTED WE HAVE SEEN SOME OF
THE HIGHEST RATES A VIOLATIONS
OF TITLE TWENTY TWO REGULATIONS
IN THE PAST DECADE.
EVEN MORE NOTABLE IN TWENTY
THIRTEEN CITY PEACH STATED THAT
IT DOES NOT ROUTINELY CONDUCT
FOLLOW UP SURVEYS AFTER
REQUIRING A PLAN OF CORRECTION
TO CORRECTED EFFICIENCY. TO
DETERMINE IF HOSPITALS ARE
ACTUALLY COMPLYING WITH NURSE TO
PATIENT RATIOS.
S. B. TWELVE EIGHTY EIGHT
CREATES A STRONG PROGRESSIVE
FINE SCHEDULE FOR HOSPITALS THAT
REPEATEDLY AND WILLFULLY VIOLATE
THE NURSE TO PATIENT RATIOS.
MOREOVER THE MEASURE WOULD ALLOW
HOSPITALS TWO CHANCES TO COME
INTO COMPLIANCE WITH TITLE
TWENTY TWO REGULATIONS.
BEFORE RECEIVING A MORE HEFTY
FINE FOR THE THIRD VIOLATION.
THE CONCEPT OF NURSE STAFFING
RATIOS HAS BEEN IN PLACE FOR
OVER FOUR DECADES AND IS ALLOWED
HOSPITALS AMPLE TIME TO COME
INTO COMPLIANCE WITH THE RATIOS.
AS DECIDED IN NINETEEN NINETY
NINE AND CURRENTLY UNDERSCORED
IN ACADEMIC LITERATURE PROPER
NURSE STAFFING SPECIFICALLY
STAFFING ACCORDING TO THE RATIOS
PRESCRIBED BY CPA EACH.
LEADS TO BETTER PATIENT OUTCOMES.
AYE URGENT AYE VOTE ON S. B.
TWELVE EIGHTY EIGHT TO OUGHT TO
NOT ONLY PROTECT OUR NURSES BUT
ULTIMATELY TO ENSURE THAT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA IS DOING
EVERYTHING POSSIBLE. TO
PRIORITIZE A PATIENT'S HEALTH
AND SAFETY THANK YOU
[inaudible]
OTHERS THIS [inaudible]
GROUP ERIC ROBLESS WITH UNITED
NURSES ASSOCIATIONS OF
CALIFORNIA PROUD SPONSOR UP.
OF THE BILL WITHOUT AS CA YOU
WANT TO ONE ARE AND YOU KNOW
JUST OUT.
REALLY QUICK GUIDE WEEK
SPONSORED COUPLE BILLS ON THIS
ALREADY IN THE PAST AND AS YOU
CAN SEE THE PROBLEM HASN'T BEEN
RESOLVED SO SAFE STAFFING
CONTINUES TO BE A PROBLEM IN.
ALL OF OUR HOSPITALS AND WE'RE
HOPING NOW WE CAN RESOLVE THE
ISSUE THANK YOU.
MEMORIZATION PLEASE SIR FOX
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
I BEEN VISE ROOM ARE REGISTERED
NURSE WITH PROVIDENCE AND JOSEPH
MEDICAL CENTER AND BURBANK ON
STRONG SUPPORT.
STACY BERMAN BOARD OF REGISTERED
NURSING IN SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON ROSANNA MENDEZ
SEIU LOCAL ONE TWO WHEN IRAN
REDERI REGISTERING SUPPORT ON
BEHALF OF NURSES WHO HAD TO
LEAVE EARLY TO CATCH A FLIGHT
THANK YOU.
DOUG SERVERS I MAY HAVE A
CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS AND SPORTS THINK.
MEDIA BORN REPRESENTING
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL NURSES AND
SUPPORT [inaudible]
ANYONE ELSE.
YOU IN OPPOSITION.
IF YOU COULD PICK.
POLITICIAN CATHERINE'S GOVERNOR
THE CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION I'M WE DO REMAIN
OPPOSED TO THE BILL AND DEBBIE
ROGER JUST --
THE HOSTELS ASSOCIATIONS HERE TO
TALK A LITTLE BIT MORE ABOUT THE
PROCESS AND HOW WE SEE THE
PROCESS --
MANAGES AND ADDRESSES PATIENT
HARM A POTENTIAL PATIENT HARM
CURRENTLY --
AND THEN I'LL BE HERE FOR ANY
QUESTIONS AFTER.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS --
MY NEEDS TO BE ROGERS ON
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION --
WE ARE THIS BILL DOES A CUP.
IN ESSENCE ARE ALREADY IN PLACE --
TOOK COVER --
THE HOSPITALS ARE PERIODICALLY --
SURVEYED THOUGH LAW REQUIRES
EVERY THREE YEARS --
ALTHOUGH SURVEYS ARE ANNOUNCED
AND IN FACT --
WIN BUT DEPARTMENT GOES IN FOR A
COMPLAINT INVESTIGATION OR ANY
SORT OF IN DESTINATION.
IT'S ANNOUNCED AND AS HAS BEEN
TALKED ABOUT THERE ARE
ADMINISTRATIVE --
PENALTIES --
FOR EVENTS THAT CAUSE PATIENT
HARM.
SO WHEN WE TALK ABOUT THE
LICENSING SURVEY THAT HAPPENS
EVERY THREE YEARS --
THIS IS THE DEPARTMENT'S --
MANUAL THAT THEY GIVE THEIR
INSPECTORS OF ALL OF THE THINGS
THAT THEY NEED TO LOOK AT INSIDE
THE HOSPITAL THIS ONE IS I DON'T
KNOW BUT CLOSE TO THREE HUNDRED
PAGES.
AND INCLUDES OF THE SURVEY
PROCEDURES FOR THEIR STAFF TO
LOOK AT AND ONE OF THE THINGS
THEY DO SUPPOSED TO DO ON THIS
LICENSING SURVEY.
IS LOOK FOR STAFFING RATIOS ON
EVERY SINGLE UNIT THEY'RE
SUPPOSED TO PICK ONE PATIENT ON
EVERY UNIT --
OR OF ONE UNIT TO LOOK AT THE
STAFFING RATIOS --
WHEN THERE IS A PROBLEM WHEN
THIS HOSPITAL ISN'T COMPLIANT
WITH SOMETHING THERE'S A
DEFICIENCY THAT'S ISSUED THIS IS
YOUR NON COMPLIANT WITH THIS IN
THE HOSPITAL AS WAS STATED
BEFORE IT DOES A PLAN CORRECTION?
IF THAT DEFICIENCY REACHES A
LEVEL WHERE A PATIENT HAS HARMED
BECAUSE OF IT OR THERE'S THE
POTENTIAL FOR HARM.
THAT'S WHERE THE ADMINISTRATIVE
PENALTY REGULATION I'M COMES
INTO EFFECT AND HERE'S A LITTLE
STAFFING UP A LITTLE.
MIX OF HOW THEY LOOK AT THE
COUNTIES AND ONE OF THE THINGS
THEY LOOK AT IS THE SCOPE AND
SEVERITY OF THE DEFICIENCY IS
THIS A ONE TIME INCIDENT BECAUSE
SOMEONE CALLED AND COOK SICK AND
THEY COULDN'T GET STAFFING FOR
THE DAY.
OR IS THIS WHOLE WIDESPREAD --
EVENT THE US RELATIONS REQUIRE
THE DEPARTMENT TO LOOK AT ALL OF
THE FACTORS THAT RELATE TO THAT
DEFICIENCY NOT JUST BEING OUT OF
COMPLIANCE.
DIDN'T HARM THE PATIENT TO THE
HOSPITAL IDENTIFY IT IN ADVANCE
IT'S A FILL FACILITY HAVE A
HISTORY OF OUT OF COMPLIANCE
WITH THIS SORT OF VIOLATION.
SO WE BELIEVE THAT THERE ARE
SUFFICIENT MECHANISMS IN PLACE
THAT IF.
A VIOLATION OF THE STAFFING
RATIOS REACHES A LEVEL OF
PATIENT HARM A POTENTIAL PATIENT
HARM THAT THESE REGULATIONS
WOULD KICK IN.
ANYONE ELSE OPPOSITION.
KELLY BUCKS ON BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA CARE
DISTRICTS ALSO HEAR AN
OPPOSITION'S FOR THE REASONS
REASONS PREVIOUSLY STATED
[inaudible]
ANYONE ELSE.
SIR BUT DISTRICT HOSPITAL
LEADERSHIP FORUM IS ALSO IN
OPPOSITION.
PRE BACK TO COMMITTEE FOR
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
[inaudible]
IT'S RODRIGUEZ.
I DON'T THINK THAT'S SENATOR FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD
SOMETHING --
THAT I CAN ATTEST TO THAT I'VE
NOTICED IN MANY YEARS WORKING
THEM AS INDUSTRY.
BEING A MANY HOSPITALS AND
PRIMARILY SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
WORKED OUT.
STEPHAN IS ALSO A BIG ISSUE BACK
THEN IT IS STILL IS NOW OFFICE I
HAVE A LOT OF FRIENDS AT WORK IN
THE AND THE CARE FOR A SPECIAL
pTIME TO TIME THERE ARE ISSUES
OUT THERE WHERE THERE.
UNDERSTAFFED IN THE NOT ONLY
BURDEN ON THEM WHAT THEY'RE
DOING WITH THE WORKING BUT MOST
APPOINTED THE CITY FOR THE
PATIENT THAT THERE TO TAKE CARE
OF HOW CAN THEY DO THEIR JOB
WITHOUT BEING SUFFICIENTLY STAFF.
FOR PATIENTS ANOTHER NURSES AND
I KNOW WE TALKED ABOUT THAT THE
MANUALS AND POLICIES THAT ARE
GIVEN BUT UNFORTUNATELY --
A LOT OF FOLKS DON'T FALL BY IT
AND WE HAVE THESE ISSUES WERE --
WASHING SHORTAGE THERE WHETHER
IT'S IN THE VIRTUAL UPON THE
FLOOR BUT CAMERA TAKES A
DIFFERENT SPORT IT'S GOOD BILL.
IT'S WELL OVER DOOM ONLY SEE ONE
PROBLEM WITH THE BILL.
AND I NEED TO BE ADDED AS A
QUANTUM.
SO THAT HAD --
* YOU BRING THE BILL FOR
RIGHT THAT.
PHILIP ENJOYS A DO [inaudible]
ADDITION I AM CONCERNED --
NOT.
THE CONTENTS OF THE BILL BUT
BECAUSE OF THE INABILITY OF THE
DEPARTMENT PUBLIC HEALTH TO
CONDUCT THESE AND TAKE --
EXACT OF EXAMINATIONS OR THE THE
SITE VISITS ON A REGULAR BASIS
THERE ARE BACKLOGS SO THE THE
THE ASSERTION THAT THESE ARE
HAPPENING EVERY THREE YEARS IS
SIMPLY NOT ACCURATE.
THERE BEHIND AND AND THAT IS
THAT IS OF CONCERN.
ALSO I AM CONCERNED ABOUT THE
THE LACK OF FOLLOW UP WHICH AT
WHICH I HAD WITH HIM WAS POINT
UP BY ONE OF OUR WITNESSES HERE
SO IT ISN'T TO ME IT ISN'T JUST
ABOUT.
IS THEIR HARM IS ABOUT ARE YOU
FOLLOWING UP TO MAKE SURE THAT
THE RULES ARE IN PLACE SO THERE
ISN'T FUTURE HARM AND NOT JUST
IT WAS DID HARM ACTUALLY OCCUR
SO.
IT'S APPRECIATE YOU BE BRINGING
THEM GO FORWARD --
IT DOES HAVE A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION IT'S DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
THERE'S A MOTION BY MISTER
RODRIGUEZ A SECOND BY MISTER
THURMOND WHICH LIKE TO CLOSE OFF.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR ACTUALLY
YOU TOOK THE WORDS RIGHT OUT OF
MY MOUTH I AM ALSO WORRIED ABOUT --
IT BEING OUT OF COMPLIANCE IF NO
ONE WAS HARMED WILL WE DON'T
WANT TO WAIT UNTIL SOMEONE IS
HARMED SO WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR --
MEN SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
WOULD I WOULD I MAYES.
MAYES NO AGAR CURRY THANK HURRY
I BIGELOW.
BIGELOW NO BONTA [inaudible]
BURKE.
CARILLO.
CARILLO I'VE FLORA.
FLORA LOW LIMON.
I MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE NAZARIAN.
I'M THE VERY I OF GOOD CHOICE.
RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ AYE SANTIAGO
[inaudible]
THURMOND.
THURMOND AYE WALDRON
[inaudible]
BURKE [inaudible] FOR I'D LIKE
THIS COMMITTEE.
IT HAS ITS MOMENTS YEAH --
CENTER COULD BE YOUR BILLS HAVE.
NINE ZERO BONUS. NINE THREE
EXCUSE ME.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
THINKING MEMBERS.
WILL BE THAT OPEN FOR OTHERS TO
ADD ON YOU HAVE YOUR SECOND BILL.
TWELVE FORTY FIVE YES THANK YOU
VERY GOOD.
GOOD AFTERNOON AGAIN MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS S. B. TWELVE
FORTY FIVE WOULD ALLOW COVERED
CALIFORNIA TO HAVE EMERGENCY
RULE MAKING AUTHORITY FOR NEARLY
ALL OF ITS REGULATORY PACKAGES.
UNTIL JANUARY ONE OF TWENTY
TWENTY TWO THIS MEASURE WOULD
ALSO MAKE SURE THAT THERE WOULD
BE ENOUGH TIME FOR THE PUBLIC TO
REVIEW AND COMMENT.
ON THE PROPOSED REGULATIONS
AHEAD OF IT BEING ADOPTED BY THE
COVERED CALIFORNIA EXECUTIVE
BOARD.
AS YOU MAY KNOW SINCE COVERED
CALIFORNIA BEGAN OFFERING
COVERAGE IN TWO THOUSAND
FOURTEEN THEY HAVE SERVED MORE
THAN THREE MILLIO OF OUR
CONSTITUENTS.
SINCE TWO THOUSAND TEN COVER
CALIFORNIA HAS MADE A DELIBERATE
EFFORT TO MOVE TO PERMANENT
REGULATIONS.
AND HAS APPROVED FOR PERMANENT
WILL MAKING PACKAGES.
AS THE AFFORDABLE CARE ACT
STABILIZED IT WAS EXPECTED THAT
COVERED CALIFORNIA WOULD
CONTINUE TO EFFECTIVELY
TRANSITION.
A PERMANENT RULE MAKING PROCESS
HOWEVER CURRENT FEDERAL POLICY
DISCUSSIONS REGARDING THE ACA
INDICATE THAT THERE WILL BE
POTENTIALLY SIGNIFICANT CHANGES
TO THE RULES GOVERNING HEALTH
BENEFITS EXCHANGES.
LIKE COVERED CALIFORNIA.
DUE TO THE POTENTIAL FUTURE
CHANGES TO THE ACA AND OTHER
RELATED REGULATIONS COVERED
CALIFORNIA MAY HAVE TO CREATE
ADAPT REGULATIONS MORE QUICKLY.
THAN IS POSSIBLE THROUGH THE
PERMANENT RULE MAKING PROCESS
WITHOUT THIS TIMELY AUTHORITY
COVERED CALIFORNIA REGULATIONS
COULD CONFLICT WITH FEDERAL LAW
WHICH HAS THE POTENTIAL TO HARM
ITS ABILITY TO PROPERLY SERVE.
THEIR MORE THAN THREE MILLION
CONSUMERS.
IN ORDER TO PROMPTLY RESPOND TO
CHANGES AT THE FEDERAL AND STATE
LEVELS S. B. TWELVE FORTY FIVE
WOULD ALLOW COVERED CALIFORNIA
HAVE EMERGENCY RULE MAKING
AUTHORITY. FOR NEARLY ALL OF ITS
REGULATORY PRACTICES UNTIL
JANUARY.
ONE TWENTY TWENTY TWO WITH ME
TODAY TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT AS
MARY JUNE FLORENCE WITH HEALTH
ACCESS CALIFORNIA.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
WEARS MATCHING FLOORS WOULD HAVE
ACCESS CALIFORNIA PLEASES
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
HELP ACCESS SUPPORTED THE
CREATION OF OUR STATE'S HEALTH
BENEFIT THAT CHANGE COVER
CALIFORNIA AS AN INDEPENDENT
PUBLIC ENTITY AND STATE
ADMINISTERED MARKETPLACE IN.
TWENTY TEN IT WAS THE FIRST A
STATE RUN HEALTH THE INSURANCE
EXCHANGE ESTABLISH AFTER THE
PASSAGE OF THE ACA AND IS THE
LARGEST EXCHANGE IN THE NATION.
THE EARLY DAYS AND YEARS OF THE
ACA NECESSITATED SUCH.
AUTHORITY WHICH MADE COVERED CAL
AND PROACTIVE IN CREATING THE
RULES FOR A C. IMPLEMENTATION
WHICH HEALTH ACCESS AS ALSO
SUPPORTED.
GIVEN FEDERAL UNCERTAINTY AND
ONGOING FEDERAL ACTIONS THAT
SABOTAGES OUR AC IMPLEMENTATION
AND THREATENS OUR OVERALL HEALTH
CARE SYSTEM.
COVER CALIFORNIA'S SIX SIXTIES
EMERGENCY RULE MAKING AUTHORITY
UNTIL TWENTY TWENTY TO THE BILL
PROVIDES A MINIMUM LEVEL OF
PUBLIC REVIEW AND COMMENT.
WHICH ALLOWS FOR LEVEL OF
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY
BY BOARD ACTIONS FOR THESE
REASONS WE ASK FOR YOUR ARRIVAL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH IF THERE'S A
SUPPORT.
KIMBERLY TEN I'M HAPPY
CALIFORNIA PAN ETHICAL THAT WORK
IN SUPPORT.
GEN FLOOR ON BEHALF OF WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY AND
SUPPORT AND I'LL JUST ADD
SEVERAL STAKEHOLDERS AND HOLDERS
DISCOVERED LAST WEEK THAT WE
ACTUALLY LIKE THIS PROCESS
BETTER THAN THE FORMAL RULE
MAKING --
IT'S BEEN WORKING AND THERE'S
BEEN ROBUST --
STAKEHOLDER ENGAGEMENT AT THE
BOARD MEETINGS WHEN THESE ARE
FIRST PERSON [inaudible]
ANYONE ELSE.
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NO ONE WILL BRING YOU
BACK COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS.
SEEING NONE OF TWO A QUESTION OF
CHART.
KIND OF A COMMON QUESTION.
SO THEY WOULD STILL HAVE A
PUBLIC MEETING.
AND THEM FORWARD --
AND WE KNOW THATJUST FROM YOU
KNOW EVEN OUR UNIVERSAL HEALTH
CARE DELIVERY HE MEETINGS THAT
WE HAD WE SEE HOW.
INFLUX REALLY A LOT OF THIS
ALONE HEALTH CARE YOU KNOW JUST
COVERAGE FROM NOT ONLY THE FEDS
BUT WHAT WE HAVE TO RESPOND OF
THE STATE.
IS CONSTANTLY.
CHANGING ON IT WE AT THE ACA
THEIR COVER CALIFORNIA REALLY
HAS INFLUENCE OVER A LOT OF
PEOPLE'S LIVES IN THE STATE AND
THE SOMETHING THAT'S HELPED US
EXPAND COVERAGE.
THE WAY THAT WE'RE VERY PROUD
[inaudible]
ON SO.
NO I CAN SUPPORT THIS AND YOU
KNOW I UNDERSTAND THE NEED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SHRINK
ASSEMBLYMEMBER ANYONE ELSE
[inaudible]
YES.
A BIGELOW.
MAYBE WE SHOULDN'T GO ON WITHOUT
BEING RECOGNIZED.
ANOTHER ONE COMMENT THAT WAS
JUST MADE THEIR TO AND FROM THE
PUBLIC.
TALKING ABOUT THIS PROCESS BEING
VETERAN EASIER TO GET THROUGH
MUST RECOGNIZE THAT THERE WAS A
PROCESS PUT IN PLACE WHILE
CHALLENGING IT MAY BE.
IS STILL WAS PUT IN PLACE FIRST
VERY GOOD REASONS.
MAYBE WE OUGHT A BE CAUTIOUS
THAT WE DON'T SEE OURSELVES RUN
AMOK.
IT'S JUST TEMPERANCE HERE THAT
I'M LOOKING AT I WOULD AGREE
WITH YOU COMPLETELY I THINK THE
ONLY REASON I ACTUALLY DON'T
THINK I KNOW THE ONLY REASON FOR
THIS BILL IS BECAUSE OF THE FLUX
IN -- AT THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AND WE'RE NOT
SURE WHAT IS HAPPENING SO WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE CAN
TAKE CARE OF OUR PEOPLE HERE IN
CALIFORNIA ALL THE THREE MILLION
WHO HAVE SIGNED UP --
I WOULDN'T SEE ANY REASON WHY
WOULD GO BACK TO THE OLD PROGRAM
IF ONCE WE KNOW THEIR CERTAINTY
FROM THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT BUT
FOR RIGHT NOW WEEKS ONE TO
PROTECT THE PEOPLE WHO HAVE
SIGNED UP IN WITH US AND WITH
THE ON THREE CLUE THAT LANGUAGE
AND THAT SORT. FOR THAT. TO
OCCUR DEL I THINK THAT'S MY
POINT THAT'S MY POINT EXACTLY
RIGHT THERE.
MAYBE WERE SOMETIMES QUICK TO
REACT WHEN YOU REALLY DIDN'T
NEED TO REACT.
IT'S LIKE SOMEBODY JUMPING AND
YELLING SNAKE WHEN THERE'S
REALLY NO SNAKE.
JUST A THOUGHT APPRECIATE THAT.
YOU VERY MUCH ANYONE ELSE.
YOU KNOW ONCE WE HAVE A MOTION
[inaudible]
RODRIGUEZ MOTION THE MOTION --
BY MISTER THURMAN A SECOND BY
MISTER RODRIGUEZ MOTIONS IT
PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS CENTER
PROJECT.
BILL HAS NO OPPOSITION I RESPECT
FLASH FRONT AYE VOTE.
YOU VERY MUCH.
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
WOULD I WOULD I MAYES.
MAYES NOW ACCURATE CURRY THANK A
CURRY AYE BIGELOW.
BIGELOW NO BONTA [inaudible]
BURKE.
I CARILLO CREA I FLORA.
FLORA NO LOW MOAN.
LOW MOAN AYE MCCARTY.
MCCARTY I NAZARIAN.
THIS AREA AYE RODRIGUEZ
RODRIGUEZ SISAL THIAGO.
THURMAN.
THURMOND AYE WALDRON.
WALDRON AYE.
YOU'RE VERY TENTH I'M SO YOU'RE
BUT WITH YOUR BILL.
THE BILL HAS TEN VOTES --
WITHOUT --
WILL LEAVE THE RELATIVE RATHER
SAT ON THANK YOU THANK YOU
SENATOR.
AT THIS POINT LET'S GO TO THE
CONSENT CALENDAR --
DICE THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
THE MOTION BY MISTER BIGELOW
SECOND FIVE MISTER MAYES IF THAT
INCLUDES ITEMS NUMBER
[inaudible] ONE EIGHT THIRTEEN
FOURTEEN TWENTY ONE AND TWENTY
FOUR SO I OVERSIGHT IS SECOND
MET SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
WOULD I WOULD I MAYES MAYES AYE
OCCUR CURRY THANK YOUR CURRY AYE
BIGELOW.
BIGELOW AYE BONTA [inaudible]
BURKE.
BURGER I CARILLO.
CARILLO AYE FLORA FLORA I LIVE
ON MY OWN I MCCARTY.
MCCARTY I NAZARIAN.
NAZARIAN AYE RODRIGUEZ.
RODRIGUEZ I SAW THIAGO.
BERMAN.
BERMAN AYE WALDRON WALDRON AYE.
SO THAT HAS OF THIS CONSECUTIVAS --
THIRTEEN ZERO SENATORS DON'T THE
FINAL BILL OF THE DAY
.
IN VERY PLEASED TO BE HERE TODAY
TO PRESENT S. B..
TWELVE SIXTY FOUR WHICH WE
PROVIDE BETTER CAL COVERAGE FOR
HYPERTENSION MEDICATION
MANAGEMENT SERVICES PROVIDED BY
AN ADVANCED PRACTICE PHARMACIST.
HYPERTENSION CONTROL THE UNITED
STATES HAS HOVERED AT
APPROXIMATELY 50% OVER THE PAST
DECADE DESPITE THE DANGEROUS
ROLE HYPERTENSION PLAYS AND
CARDIOVASCULAR DISEASE IN THE
FIRST LINE.
OF DEFENSE THE MEDICATIONS ARE
FOR HYPERTENSION ARE.
GENERIC AND AN EXPENSIVE.
THE CALIFORNIA HEALTH BENEFIT
REVIEW PROGRAM STATED IN THE
RECENT STUDY THAT THE MOST
PREVALENT CONDITION AMONG NON
DUAL MEDICAL AND RARELY RELEASE
IN.
TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN WAS
HYPERTENSION A 27%.
THE ANALYSIS ALSO STATED THERE'S
A PREPONDERANCE OF EVIDENCE FROM
FIVE STUDIES AT THE RECEIPT OF
COMPREHENSIVE MEDICATION
MANAGEMENT.
IS ASSOCIATED WITH GREATER
REDUCTIONS IN BLOOD PRESSURE
THAT OF USUAL CARE.
THIS INCLUDES ONE STUDY
PUBLISHED THIS YEAR IN THE NEW
ENGLAND JOURNAL OF MEDICINE
DEMONSTRATE IN THAT PHARMACISTS
MANAGING MEDICATIONS.
IN LOS ANGELES BARBER SHOPS FOR
PATRONS WITH UNCONTROLLED
HYPERTENSION.
ARE NEARLY SIX TIMES MORE
EFFECTIVE THAN USUAL CARE IT
ATTAINING BLOOD PRESSURE CONTROL.
WITH HYPERTENSION BEING ONE OF
THE MAJOR CONTRIBUTORS TO
CARDIOVASCULAR DISEASE AND
THEREBY THE GREATEST CORRECTABLE
ATTRIBUTABLE RISK FOR DEATH
WORLDWIDE.
SP TWELVE SIXTY FOUR IS NEEDED
TO HELP BRING DOWN BLOOD
PRESSURE AND LOWER RATES OF
DEADLY CARDIOVASCULAR DISEASE.
S. B. TWELVE SIXTY FOUR WILL
CREATE MORE ACCESS TO
COMMUNITIES THAT CURRENTLY DO
NOT HAVE.
HYPERTENSION MEDICATION
MANAGEMENT READILY AVAILABLE.
ADVANCED PRACTICE PHARMACISTS
WILL BE FREE TO PROVIDE THE
SERVICES FROM LOCAL PHARMACIES
SO PATIENTS DON'T HAVE TO TRAVEL
TO A HOSPITAL OR DOCTOR'S
OFFICES FREQUENTLY FOR
HYPERTENSION MANAGEMENT THAT'S
MAKING.
THE SERVICE EASIER TO OBTAIN AND
MORE READILY AVAILABLE.
ENGAGING PHARMACISTS IN THE
MANAGEMENT OF HYPERTENSION IS
CRUCIAL TO ACHIEVING GOALS FOR
UNCONTROLLED PATIENTS.
COLLEAGUES I WOULD LIKE TO
INTRODUCEDR STEPHEN CHEN
ASSOCIATE DEAN FOR CLINICAL
AFFAIRS FOR THE UNIVERSITY OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA SCHOOL OF
PHARMACY AND DOCTOR RUN VICTOR
DIRECTOR OF THE HYPERTENSION
CENTER AT CEDAR SINAI HOSPITAL
BURNS AND ALLEN CHAIR.
IN CARDIOLOGY RESEARCH IMPRINTS
PERSECUTOR OF THE TRIAL ON
BARBARA BASS INTERVENTION FOR
HYPERTENSION CONTROL IN AFRICAN
AMERICAN MEN THE STUDY
PREVIOUSLY MENTIONED.
S. B. TWELVE SIXTY FOUR HAS NO
VOTES AND APPRECIATE YOUR
CONSIDERATION TODAY IF I CAN
INTRODUCED BY WITNESSES.
SO I AM NOT STEVEN CHOI JUST TO
CLARIFY I'M THE ASSOCIATE DEAN
FOR CLERK AFFAIRS OF THE US YOU
SCHOOL OF PHARMACY --
I'VE PROVIDED ARE DIRECTED OF
THAT HARDNESS MAKES HIS
MANAGEMENT SERVICES FOR THE PAST
THIRTY YEARS MOST RECENT
TRANSITIONING FROM BEVERLY HILLS
TO SKID ROW.
SO WITH THE HEALTH DISPARITIES
OR TALK ABOUT I'VE SEEN FIRST
HAND AYE ANDERSON WHO TRAINS
PHARMACISTS DO THIS KIND OF WORK
MEDICATION MANAGEMENT SWEAT TO
CLARIFY THREE POINTS.
THE FIRST SAYS THIS BILL
PROPOSES THAT ONLY DOCTORAL
LEVEL PHARMACISTS WITH THE
ADVANCED TRAINING AND EXPERTISE
IN HYPERTENSION MANAGEMENT ARE
ALLOWED TO PROVIDE THE SERVICES.
AND THEN BE PAID FOR THEM --
THE SCOPE OF PRACTICE CURRENTLY
AND CALIFORNIA STATE LAW ALREADY
SUPPORTS ALL OF THE SERVICES
BEING DESCRIBED IN THIS BILL.
AS A LAW DESCRIBES A MAKE HUGE
MESS Y. PHARMACISTS IS NOT
INDEPENDENT SERVICE IT'S A
COLLABORATION BETWEEN PATIENT
PHYSICIAN PHARMACIST UNDER A
CLOUD WERE PRACTICES GOING OR
PROTOCOL.
THAT'S AUTHORIZED AND SIGNED BY
PHYSICIANS BY MEDICAL GROUPS FOR
THE HEALTH SYSTEM --
THIS IS. TWO THREE OF ITS AT
THEIR CONSTANT COMMUNICATION IS
REQUIRED BY STATE LAW --
THOUGH THERE'S NO FRAGMENTATION
OF CARE THE CURLERS THROUGH THIS
PROGRAM AND I CAN SEE THAT WITH
COMPAS BECAUSE MY THIRD POINT.
IS THIS PRACTICE OF HAVING
QUALIFIED PHARMACISTS MANAGE
MEDICATIONS FOR CHRONIC DISEASES
LIKE HYPERTENSION HAS BEEN IN
EFFECT IN CALIFORNIA FOR FIVE
DECADES IN THE VA HEALTH SYSTEM
AND KAISER --
THE DIFFERENCE IS THAT THIS
BILLS PROPOSING MEDICAL PAYMENT
FOR THE SERVICES TO ALLOW THE
SERVICES TO BE PROVIDED MORE
WIDELY A CENTER STONE HAS IS AS
DESCRIBED IN NO PUBLIC PLACES
LIKE BARBER SHOPS AND PHARMACIES.
OUT WE RECENTLY COMPLETED A
THREE YEAR GRANT FROM THE CENTER
FOR MEDICARE MEDICAID INNOVATION
IN RULING SIX THOUSAND LETS YOU
KNOW MEDI CAL PATIENTS
HYPERTENSION WAS ONE OF THE TOP
CONDITIONS AND WE DEMONSTRATED
THAT.
HAVING PHARMACIST MANAGE
HYPERTENSION [inaudible]
CARE.
I'M I TO TURN THIS OVER SNOUT
WHO DUCKED AROUND VICTOR.
WILL TALK ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE
AND VALUE OF THIS BILL SWAN ALSO
CLARIFY THAT DOCTOR VICTOR HAS
WRITTEN THE BOOK ON HYPERTENSION
HE IS THE AUTHOR OF THE
HYPERTENSION TEXTBOOK.
THAT THE MEDICAL WORLD READS TO
LEARN ABOUT HYPERTENSION AND THE
AUTHORS THE CHAPTERS I
CARDIOLOGISTS READ TO LEARN
ABOUT MANAGING HYPERTENSION
AFTER [inaudible]
STEVE.
SO HYPERTENSION HIGH BLOOD
PRESSURE.
BECAUSE HIS HALF OF ALL HEART
ATTACKS. THREE QUARTERS OF ALL
STROKES [inaudible]
I'M.
WE WE HAVE WE CAN'T CURE MOST
CASES OF HYPERTENSION BUT WE CAN
CONTROL MOST OF THEM.
WITH REALLY EXCELLENT
MEDICATIONS THERE NOW GENERIC
AND LOW COST.
AND BUT IN THE REAL WORLD.
ON ITS HERE TO STONE POINTED OUT
I'D MAJORITY OF OF FOLKS
EFFECTIVE WITH HIGH BLOOD
PRESSURE.
DON'T ACHIEVE A SAFE BLOOD
PRESSURE LEVEL TODAY.
SO WHAT'S THE PROBLEM MULLIN
PART DOCTORS YOU'RE SO BUSY
GETTING PRESSURED TO SEE MORE
AND MORE PATIENTS.
THE TIME THAT DOCTOR PATIENT
VISIT IS IS WAY TOO SHORT AND
WE'D LIKE.
AND CONDITION PENSIONS CAN PUSH
BACK AND SOMETIMES I DON'T
COMPLY WITH ALL BE ALL THE AS
PRESCRIBED.
THERE HAVE BEEN --
OVER FORTY TRIALS AND HELP
PUBLISHED THEY PROVIDE
OVERWHELMING EVIDENCE.
AND THAT THE BEST WAY TO CONTROL
HYPERTENSION IN PRACTICE IS WITH
THE PHARMACIST PHYSICIAN TEAM
APPROACH TO HYPERTENSION
MANAGEMENT.
NOW IN MY OWN STUDY WHICH IS
RECENTLY PUBLISHED.
ITEM DOCTORATE LEVEL PHARMACISTS
MADE HOUSE CALLS TO AFRICAN
AMERICAN OWNED BARBERSHOPS.
SO THERE THEY MET THE THE
PATRONS ITEM THEY WERE THEY I
RECONCILED THE MEDICATIONS THAT
MEASURE BLOOD PRESSURE.
I THINK CHECK LABORATORY RESULTS
RIGHT THERE IN THE BARBER SHOP.
AND THEY PRESCRIBE MEDICATIONS
UNDER COLLABORATIVE PRACTICE
AGREEMENT.
WITH EACH GENTLEMAN'S OWN AYE
PHYSICIAN.
AND THEN WITHIN TWENTY FOUR
HOURS AYE THEY STE THEY SENT
PROGRESS NOTE.
I TO THE TREATING TO THAT --
SUPERVISING PHYSICIAN
[inaudible]
WHO COULD [inaudible]
COLLABORATION.
AB ALMOST ALL THE TIME IS REALLY
SUPERB.
NOW MY STUDY AS WELL AS MOST OF
THESE OTHER FORTY STUDIES WERE
FUNDED BY THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
THE NATIONAL INSTITUTES OF
HEALTH.
SO PROBABLY HUNDREDS AND
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN RESEARCH
DOLLARS HAVE BEEN SPENT TO
PROVIDE THIS EVIDENCE.
IN MY OPINION THIS BILL.
AND WOULD BE A HUGE STEP FORWARD --
IN MAKING THIS HAPPEN IN IN REAL
PRACTICE [inaudible]
I'M SO.
I'M ENCLOSING AND ONE THIRD OF
OUR TRIAL PETITION PARTICIPANTS
WHERE I'M MEDI CAL BENEFICIARIES.
I AM AND IT TWELVE MONTHS AND
THE PHARMACIST LED PROGRAM HAD
NO EFFECT ON THE FREQUENCY OF
DOCTOR VISITS.
SO WAS IS THAT WERE TAKING
BUSINESS AWAY FROM THE DOCTORS.
AND THERE WAS 64% OF THE MEN IN
OUR TRIAL IT SIX MONTHS ACHIEVED.
I'M SAFE BLOOD PRESSURES WITH
WHITE PERSIAN THE ONE TWENTIES
EVERY SEVENTIES.
I COMPARED 212% OF MEN WHO
REFERRED BACK TO THE PRACTICING
DOCTORS.
SO CLOSING I THINK THIS BILL
WOULD PREVENT NEEDLESS HEART
ATTACKS AND STROKES.
IN SAVE LIVES AMONGST THAT THOSE
VULNERABLE AMONG US IN OUR
POPULATIONS THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION [inaudible]
A MUCH OTHERS IN SUPPORT JUST
YOUR NAME AND ORGANIZATION
PLEASE GLORIA AND THE MARTINI
WITH A CALIFORNIA CITING HEALTH
SYSTEM PHARMACISTS SPONSOR AND
SUPPORT.
DAN DAWN AS A PHARMACIST AND
ALSO AS PRESIDENT OF THE
CALIFORNIA SOCIETY HEALTH SYSTEM
PHARMACISTS.
MICHAEL TO WITH THEIR PROBLEMS
ST JOSEPH HEALTH SYSTEM IN
SUPPORT --
DAVID GONZALEZ WITH AMERICA'S
PHYSICIAN GROUPS ALSO IN SUPPORT
WE ACTUALLY SUPPORT ANOTHER BILL
AUTHORED BY THE CHAIR LITTLE
MORE COMPREHENSIVE THIS IS A
GOOD STEP FORWARD.
GOOD AFTERNOON SHIPMENTS WITH
GROWING IN BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CHRONIC CARE
COALITION IN SUPPORT.
SHARIF US WITH CALIFORNIA
PHARMACISTS ASSOCIATION SUPPORT.
THREE ONE IN OPPOSITION
.
MR MEMBERS TIBETAN REPRESENT THE
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER THE AMERICAN
COLLEGE OF CARDIOLOGY I MEAN WE
ARE OPPOSED S. B..
TWELVE SIXTY FOUR I'M BEFORE IT
TURNED OVER TO MY WITNESS --
DOCTOR NORMAN THE POORER
CARDIOLOGISTS AND FORMER
PRESIDENT OF OUR ORGANIZATION.
JUST WANT TO MAKE A QUICK
COMMENT ON AND IF YOU THE
REMARKS --
THE CENTER MENTION THIS BILL
ONLY APPLIES TO ADVANCE PRACTICE
PHARMACISTS AND THAT'S ACTUALLY
NOT CORRECT.
THE WITNESSES ALSO MENTIONED
THAT IT ONLY APPLIES TO A
PHARMACIST WITH ADVANCED
DOCTORAL DEGREE THAT'S ALSO
INCORRECT.
SO WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE BILL
SPECIFICALLY ON PAGE.
TWO LINES. THIRTY TO THIRTY FIVE
TWO CODE SECTIONS THAT IT REFERS
TO ARE JUST FOR A PHARMACIST SO
THIS COULD BE A PHARMACIST TO
GRADUATE FROM SCHOOL AND IS NOW
ELIGIBLE TO PRY THE SERVICES.
AND LINES.
THIRTY SIX TO THIRTY EIGHT IT IS
SPECIFIC TO ADVANCE PAST
PRACTICE FARCES SO THE SENATOR
IS CORRECT IT DOES APPLY TO THEM.
BUT IT IS --
APPLE TO A BROADER GROUP OF
FARMS IS THEY DO NOT HAVE THE
ADVANCED LEVEL OF TRAINING
EDUCATION THAT IN ADVANCE
PRACTICE FARMS DOES SO WITH THAT
PRESET ELECTED TURN IT OVER TO
DOCTOR THE POOR. TO GO MUCH MORE
DETAILS ON SUMMER CONCERT
[inaudible]
VERY MUCH.
THANKS FOR THE OPPORTUNITY --
TO FOR A FEW MOMENTS TO PRESENT
OUR VIEWS OF THE CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER AMERICAN COLLEGE OF
CARDIOLOGY.
MY UNDERSTANDING IS HISTORICALLY
THE PURPOSES BILL WAS REALLY TO
PROVIDE IMPROVED ACCESS --
TO MEDICAL CARE TO THOSE WHO ARE
IN NEED --
I'M NOT AN EXPERT AT THE ENGLISH
SHE'S THAT THESE BILLS ARE --
WRITTEN AND HOWEVER I REALLY AM
HARD PRESSED TO FIND REALLY HOW --
THIS SEEMS TO BE --
THE CASE THERE'S NO QUESTION
THAT THE EXCELLENT WORK UP
PRESENTED.
REALLY CREATES A CLOSED LOOP.
EFFICIENT MODEL WITHIN A CLOSELY
WATCHED CLINICAL PROTOCOL.
WHERE THERE IS?
CONTINUOUS COLLABORATION WITH
PHYSICIANS THERE'S CONTINUOUS
COLLABORATION IN TERMS OF THE
MOVEMENT OF INFORMATION.
AND I THINK THAT THAT HOWEVER IS
NOT NECESSARILY HOW THIS PROGRAM
IS GOING TO RUN WITH THIS
LEGISLATION.
THERE REALLY ARE NO CAB YACHTS.
THE WITHOUT REGARD TO EDUCATION
EVEN FURNISHING TRAVEL MEDICINE
FALLS PROTOCOLS FURNISHING THE
LOCKS SOUND.
HAS PARTICULAR PROTOCOLS
ADMINISTRATION HORMONAL
CONTRACEPTIVES IN CONSULTATION
WITH THE AMERICAN CONGRESS OF
OBGYN IMMUNIZATIONS REALLY --
FOLLOW PROTOCOL FROM THE CBC YET
HOWEVER THERE REALLY ARE NO
PROTOCOLS THERE'S NO
CERTIFICATION AND THERE IS NO
TRAINING.
AND BLOOD PRESSURE IS MUCH MORE
THAN A NUMBER.
THIS IS TWO HUNDRED FIFTY PAGES.
OF THE GUIDELINES FOR THE
AMERICAN COLLEGE OF CARDIOLOGY
AND AMERICAN HEART ASSOCIATION
LIKE THE PAST THIS PERHAPS
AROUND TO THE ARE LEGISLATORS
HERE.
IT REALLY GOES TO SHOW REALLY
THE COMPLEXITY WITH WHICH
HYPERTENS CAMP CAN BE --
EFFECT THAT AND MY CONCERN IS
THAT THE TREATMENT OF
HYPERTENSION UNDER THE PROPOSED
DOES NOT ALLOW FOR THE EFFICIENT
COLLABORATION THE MOVEMENT OF
INFORMATION FROM THE PHARMACY TO
MY OFFICE.
I'M OUT THIS PATIENT IS NOW
GOING TO BE TREATED IN A VERY
DISJOINTED WAY BY THE PHARMACIST
BY THE INTERNET BY THE
CARDIOLOGISTS UNLESS THERE
REALLY IS EFFORTS TO ENHANCE THE
LEVEL OF COMMUNICATION AGAIN.
MY CONCERN IS THE LACK OF
TRAINING THE LACK OF
CERTIFICATION IN TERMS OF THIS
PROCESS ALSO I'M A BIT CONCERNED
PARTICULARLY IF THERE'S BETH
PHARMACISTS ARE GOING TO BE
WORKING IN.
IN -- IN
THERE RETAIL FAR LEARN ABOUT THE
CONFLICT OF INTEREST RIGHT NOW
WE WE REALLY HAVE ISSUES IN
TERMS OF WHAT I PRESCRIBE IN
TERMS OF THE MEDICATION.
AND WHAT THE PATIENT ULTIMATELY
IS PRESCRIBED IT'S EITHER DONE
BY VIRTUE OF DEALS THAT ARE MADE
WITH THE WITH THE PHARMACY OR
THE PBM.
OR WHAT HAVE YOU BUT I'M ALREADY
HAVING ISSUES AND PATIENTS
ALREADY VERY CONFUSED I GET MY
PRESCRIPTION FOR MEDICATION.
DELETE WITH WHAT WITH A AND
ALTERNATIVE MEDICINE.
AND I THINK THAT AND I THINK THE
SECONDARY ISSUES OR THE TERTIARY
ISSUE RELATES THE REIMBURSEMENT
ISSUES BELIEVE ME I PRACTICES
BUSY ENOUGH I STILL MAKE SURE I
TAKE.
PLENTY GOOD CARE PATIENTS
HYPERTENSION IS A PREVALENT
DISEASE AND ONE WITH WHICH WE
NEED TO A TAKE CARE CAREFULLY
BUT I REALLY DON'T SEE HOW THE
WRITING OF THIS BILL --
REALLY LEADS TO ENHANCEMENT OF
CARE IN TERMS OF OF POPULATIONS
ARE NOT WELL SERVED AS WELL AS
THE NECESSARY TRAINING AND
CERTIFICATION AS WELL AS THE
COMMUNICATION THAT'S NECESSARY.
THAT YOU DID SEE IN DR VIKTORS
WORK WHICH ACTUALLY COULD BE A
MODEL FOR HOW WE DO THIS BUT I'M
FEEL THAT VERY STRONGLY THAT
THIS LEGISLATION DOES NOT FOLLOW
THAT MODEL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
IF YOU VERY MUCH --
ARE THERE OTHERS IN OPPOSITION.
JERRY HEX REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF FAMILY
PHYSICIANS WE ARE OPPOSED MONTHS
AMENDED.
JUST ASKING FOR THIS TO BE
LIMITED TO ADVANCED PRACTICE
PHARMACISTS WITH TRAINING AND
HYPERTENSION [inaudible]
ANYONE ELSE.
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
FOR QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
[inaudible]
COMMENTS --
WE WERE MODES.
I HAVE A MOTION BY MISTER BERMAN.
THE SECOND BY [inaudible] THREE
PEOPLE.
BERMAN THIS BERKUS WAVING HER
HAND FRANTICALLY SO WILL GIVE
THAT TO HER --
PERSONAL THAT WERE THANK YOU --
SENATOR FOR BRINGING THE BILL
FORWARD -- I
BELIEVE THE GOALS A
COMPREHENSIVE MEDICATION
MANAGEMENT WHICH IS TO IMPROVE
THE OUTCOMES FOR PATIENTS.
AND REDUCE HEALTHCARE COSTS IN
TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN I CARRIED
AB TWENTY EIGHTY FOUR WHICH YOU
WOULD HAVE PROVIDED MEDICAL
COVERAGE FOR COMPREHENSIVE
MEDICATION MANAGEMENT.
I'M UP I'LL BE SUPPORTING THE
BILL TODAY --
BUT I BELIEVE IT'S ACTUALLY TOO
NARROW.
I BELIEVE --
DE AS IT ONLY APPLIES TO
HYPERTENSION MANAGEMENT --
MEDICATION MANAGEMENT AND IS
BENEFITS TO RURAL AREAS LIKE MY
DISTRICT IS HIGHLY UNCERTAIN.
I DON'T KNOW HOW MANY PEOPLE
WOULD BENEFIT --
AND HOW MANY COMMUNITY
PHARMACISTS WOULD ACTUALLY
PERFORM THE SERVICES AS THE BILL
IS WRITTEN OTHER PROVISIONS --
MOSTLY APPLIED TO HEALTH
FACILITIES WHICH WOULD HOSPITALS
NOT FEDERALLY QUALIFIED HEALTH
CENTERS WHICH IS WHERE 50% OF MY
PATIENTS GET THEIR CARE --
THERE NEEDS TO BE CONTINUED
DISCUSSION ON THE LONG TERM
VISION FOR COMPREHENSIVE
MEDICATION MANAGEMENT I'D I'D I
WILL SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN IF I
CAN ALSO --
RESPECTFULLY RESPONDED THE
OPPOSITION CERTAINLY THANK YOU I
APPRECIATE THAT I APPRECIATE
THEM --
STEPPING FORWARD --
THE INTENT OF THIS BILL AND I
HAVE MY OF WITNESSES CONFIRM HIS
THAT.
THE ENTRY LEVEL DEGREE IS A FARM
DE TO CREATE DOCTOR PHARMACY
DEGREE.
AND IS REQUIRED TO GET INTO AN
ADVANCED PRACTICE --
PROGRAM THAT IS CERTIFIED OUGHT
TO HAVE THOSE QUALIFICATIONS AND
YOU CANNOT PARTICIPATE IN THIS
PROGRAM UNTIL YOU HAVE BEEN
APPROPRIATELY CERTIFIED AS AN
ADVANCED PRACTICE PHARMACIST.
IN THIS PARTICULAR AREA.
NOW THIS DOESN'T MEAN THE
PHARMACISTS ARE GOING TO BE
PUTTING UP A SHINGLE.
AND OPERATING INDEPENDENTLY AS
THE OPPOSITION WOULD LEAD YOU TO
BELIEVE THIS IS A COLLABORATION.
I COLOR THE TRIAD THE PATIENT
THE PHYSICIAN.
AND THE PHARMACIST WORKING
TOGETHER IS NOT A MANDATE THIS
IS A VOLUNTARY PROGRAM.
IF PHYSICIAN GROUPS TO WANT TO
PARTICIPATE IN THIS.
THAT THEY HAVE THAT OPTION NOT
TO PARTICIPATE BUT I THINK THAT
MANY PHYSICIAN GROUPS WILL BE
ARE ENCOURAGED TO HAVE THIS.
COLLABORATION IN THE BEST
INTEREST OF MAINTAINING SOMEBODY
WITH A HEALTHY BLOOD PRESSURE
AND WHEN THE MEDICAID
MEDICATIONS ARE ARE NOT WORKING
OR THERE HAVE SIDE EFFECTS.
THE PHARMACIST WILL COLLABORATE
WITH THE PHYSICIAN TO COME UP
WITH.
ALTERNATIVES IT'S NOT DONE IN A
VACUUM IT'S ALL DONE TOGETHER
AND I LIKE MY COLLEAGUES TO
ELABORATE IF I IF I ME.
SO OUR ART CHILD DEADLOCKED WILL
POUR.
WASTE AND DONE UNDER THE CURRENT
SCOPE OF PRACTICE DEVOID OF
CLINICAL PHARMACIST.
SO SO EVERYTHING THAT WE
FOLLOWED WITH TENDER COURSE
UNDER CALIFORNIA STATE PHARMACY
LA.
I CAN CITIES THIS ONLY APPLIES
TO FARM DIS THEIR DOCTORATE
LEVEL PHARMACY S. THAT'S THAT'S
FOR SURE.
I MEAN WE HAD A CLEVER PRACTICE
AGREEMENT ITEM.
WHICH I SENT YOU TAKE IT'S HE
WOULD LOOK LIKE.
ITEM.
IT'S NOT UNIQUE BUT I'M.
INTAKE INSTEAD OF A HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY FIVE PAGES WITH BOB DOWN
TO ONE PAGE WITH BIG FONT.
WITH THE KEY ISSUE IN IN
TREATING HYPERTENSION WHICH WE
WE PUBLISHED ONLINE [inaudible]
AND AND SO IT IS IT'S IT'S NOT
THAT DIFFICULT.
AND IS LONG AS IT'S IS A GREAT
POINT OUT BETWEEN.
AYE THE SUPERVISING PHYSICIAN
AND THE PHARMACIST THINGS WILL
WORK GREAT AND WE WERE VERY
PLEASANTLY SURPRISED THAT THE
THAT THE PHARMACIST OUR CASE IN
THE IN THE PHYSICIAN'S.
WE'RE NOT IN THE UNDER THE SAME
ITEM BUILDING THEY WERE EMPLOYED
BY THE SAME PEOPLE.
I'M AND THE POSITIONS I WORK
WERE EXTREMELY PLEASED WITH HOW
IT TOOK WORK LOAD OFF OF THEM.
IF WE EVER GET TO VALUE BASED.
I TREATMENT WHERE YOU KNOW THAT
IF YOU HAVE TO GET PATIENTS
BLOOD PRESSURES IN CLASS ROLES
IN OTHER IN.
A ONE SEES TO GO ALL THIS WILL
BE A GREAT BAND PHYSICIAN.
SO I THINK THE REAL WINNERS THE
PATIENT AND I'M THE EXTRA SAFETY
MONITORING THE EXTRA PAIR OF
EYES -- ON
THIS WAS WAS ALL IN THE GOOD FOR
THE PATIENT RIGHT WORKED OUT
GREAT.
I JUST READ.
NOT THIS IS THIS NOT
CONVERSATION BETWEEN THE TWO OF
YOU IS BECAUSE IT BETWEEN YOU
AND US [inaudible]
SO -- AND IS
AT THIS POINT IT'S A
DISCRETIONARY OFFERS SO.
I THINK IT DOES BEEN MOVED AND
SECONDED SO.
THANK YOU --
RESPECTFULLY ASK [inaudible]
FOR THINK.
SO WE HAVE A MOTION --
BY MISTER THURMOND A SECOND BY
MS BURKE THE MOTIONS DEEP HOUSE
TO APPROPRIATIONS --
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
WOULD I WOULD I MAYES MAYES AYE
HACKER CURRY AND YOUR CREE AYE
BIGELOW.
BIGELOW NOT VOTING BONTA.
BONTA AYE BURKE [inaudible]
I CARILLO.
CARILLO AYE FLORA.
FLORA NO LIMO.
THE MOMENT I MCCARTY.
MCCARTY I NAZARIAN [inaudible]
RODRIGUEZ [inaudible]
SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE THURMAN THURMOND
AYE WALDRON [inaudible]
HOLDEN I YOUR BILL AS ELEVEN
VOTES IT'S MORE THAN ENOUGH TO
GET OUT OF COMMITTEE WILL LEAVE
IT OPEN FOR OTHER STATUS THANK
YOU MISTER COLLEGE THANK YOU FOR
CONSIDERATION LIKE YOU VERY MUCH
MR STUFF [inaudible]
OKAY A WE HAVE.
FOR THIS TO WORK TO DO HERE
MEMBERS IF THERE ARE MEMBERS WHO
HAVE --
MISSING MEMBERS OF PLEASE COME
TO THE CAR DIES.
WE HAVE --
ITEM NUMBER --
FOUR SPM --
NINE OH SIX IN SEARCH OF A
MOTION.
CHRIS BEEN MONTHS ARSON MUCH I'M
ON THESE HAVE ALL BEEN MOTIONED
AND MY SO WE'RE GONNA OPEN THE
ROLE AND CALL THE ABSENT.
REYES ITEM FOR IT.
I KNOW SIX MAYES I BONTA.
BONTA AYE LIMON.
IF YOU MOUNT AYE MCCARTY.
MCCARTY I'M THE SYRIAN
[inaudible]
SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE THURMAN.
THURMOND AYE WALTER.
WALDRON AYE. ONE THAT HAS
FOURTEEN IT'S FOURTEEN A THIRD --
THIRTEEN FOURTEEN ZERO ITEM
NUMBER FIVE S. B..
NINE TEN BUT LIFT THE CALL CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
MIX -- BONTA
[inaudible]
BONTA AYE [inaudible]
NAZARIAN.
SANTIAGO BEHIND SANTIAGO AYE
BERMAN.
THURMOND AYE WALTER.
WHILE THEY'RE NOT VOTING.
SO THAT IS [inaudible]
TEN ZERO ITEM NUMBER
[inaudible] SIX LIFT RECALL
CALLED THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
MAYES NO MAYES NO [inaudible]
BIGELOW.
BIGELOW NO BONTA BONTA AYE
[inaudible]
NAZARIAN.
RODRIGUEZ.
RODRIGUEZ AYE SANTIAGO.
SO IN -- SIX
CORRECT AYE.
TERROR I WALDRON.
WALTER NO.
SO THAT IS TEN TO FOR THAT IS
OUT THEN ITEM NUMBER TWENTY TWO
SP.
FOURTEEN TWENTY THREE WITH THE
CALL BECAUSE THE ABSENT MEMBERS
MAYES [inaudible]
MAYES I BONTA.
BONTA AYE CARILLO [inaudible]
CARILLO I THIS AREA [inaudible]
NAZARIAN AYE.
SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE THURMAN.
THURMOND AYE WALDRON WALDRON AYE.
SO THAT'S THIRTEEN TO TWO SO
WE'RE GONNA START AT THE TOP AND
WORK OUR WAY DOWN NOW.
WE'LL START THE CONSENT CALENDAR
ONCE AGAIN --
ITEMS NUMBER ONE QUE. THIRTEEN
FOURTEEN TWENTY ONE TWENTY FOUR
PLEASE LET THE CALL BECAUSE
THERE'S A OPEN THE ROLL CALL THE
NUMBERS.
CALLS [inaudible]
BONTA.
BONTA AYE SANTIAGO SANTIAGO.
TEEN ZERO ITEM NUMBER THREE SB
SEVEN ZERO SEVEN OPEN THE ROLL
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS SANTA.
BONTA AYE KNOWS AREA IN THIS
AREA AND I SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE WALDRON WALDRON AYE
THAT'S FIFTEEN ZERO OPEN THE
RULE ON ITEM NUMBER FOUR WE JUST
DE S. B. NINE NO SIX I THINK WE
JUST TO THAT BUT AS AREAS
[inaudible]
NAZARIAN AYE.
SO THAT'S FIFTEEN ZERO ITEM
NUMBER. SIX NINE TEN THINK.
I DON'T FIVE EXCUSE ME ITEM
NUMBER OF ITS DECLINE.
FIVE S. B. NINE TEN OPEN THE
ROLL CALL IF THE MEMBERS AREA.
THIS AREA AND I VOTES.
ELEVEN ZERO ITEM NUMBER SIX S.
B. NINE SEVENTY FOUR OPEN THE
ROLL CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
[inaudible]
S. AARON [inaudible]
NAZARIAN AYE.
IT'S ELEVEN FOR ITEM NUMBER --
SEVEN SB NINE NINETY TO OPEN THE
ROLL CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
MAYES MAYES I BONTA [inaudible]
BONTA AYE.
THIS AREA.
ASSYRIAN I SANTIAGO I SANTIAGO
AYE THURMAN.
THURMOND AYE WALDRON.
WALDRON AYE THAT'S FIFTEEN ZERO
ITEM NUMBER. NINE SP ONE ZERO
ZERO FOUR OPEN THE ROLL CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS SANTA BONTA AYE.
THIS AREA IN THIS AREA IN AYE
RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ AYE SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE IT'S FIFTEEN ZERO
ITEM NUMBER TEN SP TEN NINETEEN
OPEN THE ROLL CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS MAYES.
MAYES AYE PICCOLO --
TIED TO TENNIS.
TEN NINETEEN BIGELOW AYE BONTA.
BONTA AYE THIS AREA IN.
THIS AREA IRA REQUESTS RODRIGUEZ
I SANTIAGO I'M SEPTEMBER I
THURMOND.
THURMOND AYE.
IT'S FIFTEEN ZERO ITEM NUMBER.
I WANT MY LEVIN SP TEN TWENTY
ONE OPEN THE ROLL CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS BONTA.
BONTA AYE NAZARIAN THE SYRIAN I
SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE WALDRON
[inaudible]
WALDRON AYE. FIFTEEN ZERO ITEM
NUMBER TWELVE S. B. TEN THIRTY
FOUR EPIDURAL CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS MACE.
MAYES AYE BONTA BONTA AYE LEMOND.
LIMON I THIS AREA IN.
THIS AREA AND I SANTIAGO
[inaudible]
SANTIAGO AYE [inaudible]
WALDRON.
WALDRON AYE THAT'S FIFTEEN ZERO
ITEM NUMBER. FIFTEEN SB ELEVEN
FORTY EIGHT OPEN THE ROLL CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS SANTA.
BONTA AYE LOW MOAN.
LIMON I NAZARIAN THIS AREA AYE
SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE THURMAN I'M SORRY
WALDRON [inaudible]
WALDRON AYE.
THAT'S FIFTEEN ZERO AS ITEM
NUMBER.
OF SIXTEEN SB ELEVEN NINETY TO
OPEN THE ROLL CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS.
BONTA.
BONTA AYE [inaudible]
NAZARIAN.
THIS AREA I SANTIAGO AYE AYE
SANTIAGO AYE [inaudible]
YES.
SO MISTER BIGELOW IS CHANGING
FROM.
YES CHINA WRITER NOT VOTING.
BIGELOW I DID NOT VOTING.
SO THAT'S TWELVE ZERO ITEM
NUMBER --
SEVENTEEN SP TWELVE TWENTY EIGHT
OPEN THE ROLL CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS MAYES MAYES AYE BONTA.
MONTHS ARE AYE FLORA. FOR NOT
VOTING.
THIS AREA.
IS ARIANNA I SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE WALDRON
[inaudible]
WALDRON AYE.
THE FLORA AYE [inaudible]
TEENS ARE.
IT'S FIFTEEN ZERO ITEM NUMBER
[inaudible]
WHERE? EIGHTEEN EIGHT EIGHT
EIGHTEEN S. B. TWELVE FORTY FIVE
OPEN THE ROLL CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS.
BONTA.
BONTA AYE [inaudible]
SANTIAGO [inaudible]
SANTIAGO AYE.
THAT'S TWELVE THREE ITEM NUMBER.
AND NINETEEN S. B. TWELVE SIXTY
FOUR OPEN THE ROLL CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS NICE AREA.
THE SYRIAN IRA PREVIOUS
[inaudible]
RODRIGUEZ COVERING [inaudible]
THAT'S RIGHT [inaudible]
NOBODY.
WELL IT'S 12-1 IT'S TWELVE ONE
ITEM NUMBER TWENTY S. B. TWELVE
EIGHTY EIGHT OPEN THE ROLL CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS [inaudible]
BONTA [inaudible]
BONTA AYE [inaudible]
SANTIAGO.
I SANTIAGO AYE [inaudible] THREE
TWELVE THREE EITHER.
WHO WAS WALDRON IS A NO WATER NO?
BUT I CAN'T WORK [inaudible]
REALLY [inaudible]
MEMBERS --
SO THAT'S ELEVEN FOR ITEM NUMBER
TWENTY TWO S. B. FOURTEEN TWENTY
THREE OPEN THE ROLL CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS.
EVERYONE'S ON THAT AND THEN ITEM
NUMBER TWENTY THREE SB.
FOURTEEN FIFTY SEVEN OPEN THE
ROLL CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
MAYES MAYES AYE BONTA
[inaudible]
BONTA AYE.
CARILLO.
CARILLO AYE THIS AREA.
SYRIAN AYE SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE THURMAN.
THURMOND AYE WALDRON MODERN AYE
[inaudible]
THAT'S ON FOURTEEN TWENTY THREE
GO BACK [inaudible]
WE GOTCHA.
OKAY WITH THAT --
OKAY.
BUT IT HAS BEEN [inaudible]
NINE TEN WERE.
ABOUT VOTING TO KNOW.
MODERNIZE BE TEN S. B..
NINE TEN NOT VOTING TEN THOUGH.
SO THAT BECOMES ELEVEN TO ONE SO.
OKAY SO WITH THAT THAT CONCLUDES
THE BUSINESS OF THE HEALTH
COMMITTEE TODAY AND WE WILL
ADJOURN THE MEETING THANK YOU
VERY MUCH